Hey programmers, I'm Alvin l come to our course
on dynamic programming. So dynamic programming
is one of my most favorite topics to teach.
But unfortunately, I feel like dynamic programming
also has a reputation for being a very difficult
topic. That being said, I think dynamic programming
can be very intuitive. If we actually take
a nice gradual progression through the material,
right? A lot of students have this habit of
just trying to attempt a pretty hard dynamic
programming problems, without going through
the necessary steps of really understanding
the material, right? It goes without saying,
if you want to do well on those data structure
and algorithm interviews, you definitely need
to know dynamic programming. So I hope to
give you all the background knowledge, you
need to really crush those types of problems.
Now, that being said, What problems are we
going to solve throughout the course? Here
are a few examples. So one question I can
ask you is to calculate the fourth number
on the Fibonacci sequence seems like a very
easy problem, can also ask you to count the
number of different ways to move through a
six by nine grid, or something different,
like given a set of coins? How can we make
27 cents in the least number of coins? A final
example would be given a set of substrings?
What are the possible ways to construct a
string potent pot? And all of these questions
really fall under the umbrella of dynamic
programming. And this is really why I think
the topic has such a bad reputation or being
very difficult, because the problems ranged
so much, right? It looks like these problems
are totally different. And there may not be
any underlying mechanics that we can use to
tackle all of them. But the short answer is,
we really can if we have the correct way of
thinking about these problems. That being
said, let's go over the overall format of
this course, in this course, I think our key
to victory is going to be to really visualize
all of these algorithms, right? So we're going
to spend a lot of time drawing things on the
whiteboard, as well as visualizing things
with animations. To me all the heavy lifting
on an algorithm interview is really done when
you come up with that picture, right? When
you describe that process, and then translating
it into some code is really the easy part.
Right? The hard part is designing the algorithm
in the first place, right? So we're going
to draw out of things to make sure we understand
the structure of the problem, as well as coming
up with a solution. And then once we're really
happy with that pen and paper process, then
we'll hop into my editor, and we'll solve
it in some code, we'll probably have to go
back and forth, until we end up with an algorithm
that runs in an efficient amount of time,
right. So it goes without saying, we're also
going to analyze the time and space complexity
of all of our solutions. I'll be writing my
code in JavaScript, but you'll find it very
easy to translate our solutions into the language
of your choice. So in this course, on dynamic
programming, we're going to divide the material
into two main parts. Part one is going to
be about memoization. And then Part two is
going to be about tabulation. And don't sweat
it if you have no idea what those two terms
refer to, don't worry, we'll reach all of
that material step by step together, I think
you're going to realize if we actually learn
these things in all very logical progression,
we're almost like discovering these algorithms.
And I don't just have to tell us what the
algorithms are. So in terms of prerequisites,
I won't assume you know anything about dynamic
programming, but I will assume that you understand
a little basic recursion, as well as some
basics of complexity analysis, right. So you're
sort of familiar with big O notation. And
I'm sure that we'll be able to review some
of that notation as we move along. So I think
with all that out of the way, and no further
ado, let's hop into the course. Alright, so
where should we start? Well, I want us to
really ease into this new topic. And so what
we'll do is we'll start by attacking a problem
that you probably seen in the past that is
I want to solve a Fibonacci problem. And so
for us, we'll have a particular phrasing of
the Fibonacci problem. What I want to do is
write a function fib of n that takes in a
number as an argument, and I need to return
the nth number of the Fibonacci sequence.
And just to review, how does the sequence
work? Well, the first and second number of
the sequence is just one. And then at any
point in time to generate the next number
of the sequence, you can just sum the previous
two. So for example, these are the first few
numbers of the Fibonacci sequence, right starts
112358, and so on. What I'm saying is your
number needs to take in like a position of
the sequence. In other words, if I asked you
for the seventh Fibonacci number, you need
to return the answer 13, right? Because the
seventh bonacci number is 13. And how do we
actually calculate that 13? Well, logically,
it's just a sum of the previous two elements,
that is five plus eight gives me the 13. So
very, very classic function here. And to really
get us going for what we do later on in the
lesson, I'm going to require us to solve this
one recursively, right, it's really going
to be at the heart of a topic for today. Why
don't we kick things off by quickly implementing
the classic recursive implementation of a
Fibonacci function, probably in this function
a few times in your programming career, usually
one of the earliest examples of recursion
that we face. So we'll just lay out the classical
notation here. So I want to take in a number
and and I want to return the number of the
Fibonacci sequence. Like we expect, the base
case is just about, you know, the first two
numbers of the sequence. In other words, if
I'm given some n, that's less than or equal
to two, then what I should do is just returned
one. And I'm reading this because hey, the
first two numbers of Fibonacci sequence are
exactly one. But in the recursive case, in
general, what I can do is just return the
sum of the Fibonacci number right before the
one I'm asking for, as well as the Fibonacci
number two before the one I'm asking for,
right? Again, the kind of baked in recursive
nature Fibonacci is to calculate some Fibonacci
number, you can take the sum of the previous
two numbers in the sequence right. Now, of
course, we should test our code for some correctness,
what I'll do is call a few examples of this
fib function. So I'll try fib of six, seven,
and eight. And I shouldn't get the answers
of 813 and 21, respectively, right. So let's
give this a go. I'll run this in some JavaScript.
There we have it right. 813 and 21. So this
is a very, very classic implementation of
Fibonacci, you've probably seen this many
times before. And we did solve it recursively.
And really, what I want to do is give some
a larger number to this fib function. So what
if I asked for, let's say, I don't know, the
15th Fibonacci numbers seems like something
reasonable to ask for. So if I give this code
a shot, it looks like the first three calls
of bonacci do work fine, right, I get 813
and 21. But the fourth call is actually still
running, right, my program actually hasn't
finished. And this is a big issue with this
type of implementation with Fibonacci. So
obviously, this Fibonacci function needs some
work. Let's go ahead and head to the drawing
board. Alright, so it's apparent that our
Fibonacci function is correct. And that returns
a proper result. However, if we give it a
large enough value of n, it's pretty slow.
That is our function has correctness but lacks
some efficiency. In the long run, we definitely
want to improve this implementation of a recursive
Fibonacci. But to do that, it's really important
that we identify exactly where there's even
room for improvement. And to do that, I think
we should draw some things. This is something
I think students actually need to work on.
Students have this habit of trying to like
picture everything in their mind. And that
works for some easier problems. However, when
we want to tackle more complex problems, if
we just try to capture all this information,
just mentally without drawing it on, like
pen and paper, or marker and whiteboard, or
chalk and chalkboard, you're going to really
lose track of the finer details in these structures.
So I want us to be very, very methodical,
and we're going to draw really how you should
visualize a problem like Fibonacci. And so
over to my drawing, let's say that I wanted
to trace through what happens when we call
a fib with the number seven. That is I'm asking
for the seventh number in the Fibonacci sequence,
I know that in the long run, I should get
back to 13. Right. 13 is the seventh number
in the sequence. So I'll keep that goal in
mind. But over to my drawing, let's say I
called fib of seven, I'll denote that by really
drawing a circle with my value for n inside.
So I think about this call to fib of seven,
what is it going to do? Well, I know that
seven is not the base case, right? Seven is
not less than or equal to two. So this call
is going to branch out into some more recursive
calls. In particular, on its left hand side,
I'm going to call n minus one, which is six.
On the right hand side, I'm going to do n
minus two, which is five.
And at this point, I carry over the same logic
for the other nodes have the structure, right,
if I look at the six node, if I'm routed right
there, then that will have a left child of
minus one, so five, it will also have a right
child of minus two. So four, you can start
to see a pattern where really this recursive
structure just visualizes as a tree, which
is really neat. I hop over to this five node,
it will have some children, right, minus one
on slept minus two on its right. And we will
actually just continue this process for most
of these nodes. But let's say we pause right
here. So you'll notice that these notes that
have pointed to in red, they're actually the
base case, right? For those nodes, I have
values of two or one. And I know that those
function calls will return immediately. More
importantly, that means they don't branch
into any further calls. So I don't want to
start flushing out the tree of those nodes.
Instead, I look at things that are not the
base case, right? That is these nodes in yellow.
So I'll continue to flush out this tree, but
not branch out further for the base cases.
So at this point, I built out my entire tree,
and I stopped fleshing out the tree whenever
we had a base case scenario. So this is actually
the full recursive tree. Remember that the
numbers inside of the nodes here represent
the end that we passed in. That being said,
if we have this visualization, how does this
tree really calculate the Fibonacci answer?
Right, so let's start to break it down over
here. Let's say I looked at some note, in
particular, this base case note of two, right?
I know that this note is a base case, so it's
going to return the value of one according
to my base case, when we say return, that
really just means return to your caller right
return to your parent. So this note of two
is going to return one to its parent of three.
In the same way, this node on the right hand
side of one is also a base case, two will
return one, both of those values that are
returning, they go back to the parent of three,
and three is actually going to add those two
values up. One plus one is two. And this makes
a lot of sense because we know that the third
Fibonacci number is two. So we can continue
this process. Okay, this node over here. This
is also a base case. So it returns one. And
now the parent node of four is going to sum
up both of its children values. Two plus one
is three. And that makes sense in itself,
because the fourth Fibonacci number is three.
So you probably got the picture. Now let's
speed things up. For all of these base cases,
I know that they're going to return one to
their parent. And for all parent nodes that
have both of their children ready, that is
both of their children returned, they're just
going to add up those values. And this process
just continues all the way up the tree, right?
Just adding our left and right children. To
get the answer that we should return the very
top of our tree at the root of our tree, we
get the final result of 13, which makes a
lot of sense, because at the start, we said
that, hey, the seventh Fibonacci number is
indeed 13. So now that we have a robust understanding
of how to visualize this fib function, what
do we actually know about its speed? What
do we know about time complexity. And so you
may have heard offhand people mentioned that
a classic recursive implementation of fib
is going to be two to the n in time complexity.
And that is the case however, you really understand
the reason why. So hidden in this picture
is the reason why Fibonacci for us is going
to be two to the n in terms of its time complexity.
However, something that's kind of unfortunate
about this drawing is it's asymmetric. And
that's, I think, a big reason why students
have a really hard time convincing themselves
that a function like this has a two to the
n power time complexity. So here's what we'll
do, why don't we warm up and kind of go through
some basic understanding of time complexity?
And I promise we'll answer that Fibonacci
question. So let's do a little warm up. Let's
say that I gave you this foo function, notice
that it's different from our fib function,
right? It's similar in that recursive, this
function is kind of arbitrary, it actually
doesn't calculate or solve any particular
problem. So if I wanted to visualize how this
foo function behaves, let's draw it out. Let's
say I initially call it the top level foo
of five. I know five is not a base case. So
it's going to call upon n minus one, or it's
going to call upon for four calls three, three
calls to two calls one, and then here, we've
actually bottomed out at a base case. If you
look at the number of calls I made, I basically
made exactly five function calls. Which makes
sense, because in terms of our base case,
where do we stop once we hit a number less
than or equal to one and every recursive step,
we just subtract one from our current value
of n. So overall, I have five calls here.
But if I generalize that, for any arbitrary
input, I know that in the long run, I'm going
to have about n different function calls recursively.
And so for that reason, the time complexity
of this is really just O of n time, right?
I have to evaluate O of n different function
calls. While we're at it, why don't we take
a look at the space complexity? Well, you
may have heard in past that when we analyze
the space complexity of our recursive functions,
we should include any of the additional stack
space that our function calls take up right,
when we make a recursive call, we add that
to the call stack, and those must be tracked
by our computer. And so since we have about
five or n different function calls added to
the stack, before we hit our base case, you
can see that the space complexity of this
code is also O of n space, overall, we're
looking at O of n time and open space for
this function. Pretty straightforward stuff,
right? Let's look at another more involved
function. So let's say I gave you now this
bar function, it's another arbitrary function,
it's very, very similar to foo, what you should
notice is, the only difference is when we
make a recursive call, we do an n minus two
instead of an n minus one. So how does that
actually change the time complexity of this
function? So let's say I wanted to trace through
this and I made a top level call to bar of
six, I know six is gonna call upon four four
is gonna call upon to, to call zero and zero
actually hits a base case. So this is very
similar to our last example, except we kind
of see that from one call to the next, we
kind of take a bigger step in time, right.
And so in a way, we can say that we're moving
twice as far upon every recursive call. And
this would actually half the number of recursive
calls we need overall. So I guess we might
be tempted to say that the time complexity
of this one is N over two time, but a keen
observer would note that according to our
bego, you know, understanding, we can remove
any multiplicative constants when we have
a time complexity, so N over two is the same
as one half times n. So this simplifies nicely,
it's just an O of n time complexity. Using
the same exact argument, we can also say that
the space complexity from the stack is also
open space. All right, so let's take a lay
of the land, I showed you two functions that
are very similar, they really only differ
in how they made their recursive calls, right?
One did minus one, the other did minus two.
But in the grand scheme of things, we saw
that they had an identical complexity class,
right? We have O of n time and O of n space
for both of these functions. So after these
two examples, you may be able to see the reason
I wanted to bring them up, right, maybe you're
actually ready to make the logical leap and
make some conclusion about our classic Fibonacci
recursive function. That being said, I don't
want to skip any steps. I want to be super
methodical, I think, if we pay the cost of
understanding fib right now, and I mean, truly,
like Absolutely. Understanding fib. It's really
going to pay off later on in the lesson when
I slam me with some much harder problems.
So let's be nice and methodical over here.
Let's take a look at some other functions.
Let's say I gave you this did function now.
very particular Right, we'll pay it no mind.
What do we notice about this did function?
Well, it has two recursive calls now right
inside of every single call. And they both
do an n minus one. How should we visualize
this one? Well, it's kind of similar to I
guess, our initial fib drawing and shape,
where if we start with some initial call,
let's say five, five is going to branch to
exactly two children, right? Because five
is not yet the base case. And for this did
function, it does a minus one on its left,
and also it's a right child, right. So the
next level is just for next levels, just threes
than twos, then just ones which would actually
hit our base case over here. This is a really
nice, like, beautifully symmetric tree, right?
Okay, so this is a visualization for our dib
function. But what does it tell us about the
time complexity of it? Something you'll hear
me say a lot in this lesson is when we tackle
a quote, unquote, new problem, or a new pattern
we're really trying to do is just leverage
our past experience, right? So when I look
at this tree structure, I'm trying to notice
anything familiar, right? Is there some strand
over here that I can grasp that to really
feel comfortable and kind of extend my previous
learnings, right? Where can I find our base
inside of this drawing? Boop, right here.
So if I look at this path, I've highlighted
in yellow, it's really just the path starting
at the root node going down to some base case
here, I just designated the leftmost path.
And what's really nice about this structure
is just referring to the notes in yellow.
It's a linear structure that we saw before,
right? If I start at the root, it just goes
5432. And one. And so I know that in general,
based on my initial input of n, like the length
of this path that has a number of nodes highlighted
in yellow, there's going to be about n different
nodes. If I kind of adapt that language for
like the tree, I can also say that the height
of this tree is n. So the height of a tree
is really just the distance from the root
node all the way to the far this leaf, in
this case, that just means the distance from
our top level called Five, all the way down
to a base case, which is going to be exactly
five here. Something you may also hear in
passing is we can say that the number of levels
in this tree is also n, this term is pretty
straightforward, right? When we say the number
of levels, a level is just a collection of
nodes that are the same distance away from
the root. So for example, here in yellow,
I have highlighted level zero, this is level
one, this is level two, this is level three,
and so on. But if I rewind things a bit, I
look at the very, very top level, there's
one node here, on the next level, there's
two nodes. On the next level, there's four
nodes, then eight nodes, then 16 nodes, see
the pattern?
So let's try to generalize that. So I know
no matter what, whenever we call some top
level argument for dib, we know that we're
going to have one node at the top level. But
to get the number of nodes on the next level,
we'll just multiply that by two. And the level
after that would also multiply by two and
multiply to again further levels after that.
And I do this a total of n different times,
right? Because I know that the height of the
tree, or the number of levels in this tree
is exactly n. And so what conclusion Can we
make over here, we're basically saying that
to get the total number of nodes, or the total
number of calls a recursive function would
make, you would just take the number two,
and multiply it by itself about n times over.
And that is really the definition of an exponent,
right? This is the same as two to the nth
power. So we can say that this tree structure,
this recursive function has a two to the N,
time complexity. Awesome. So we identified
this dip function is having a two to the n
time complexity. But what do we know about
the space complexity over here, I think a
common mistake I've seen people make is kind
of automatically assumed that the space complexity
of a recursive function will be the same as
the time complexity. And that might be a reasonable
trap to fall into, because we know that in
the long run, we're gonna have to evaluate
two to the n function calls. And so I guess
that means you have to put two to the n function
calls on the stack. But there's actually some
nuance to this, the time complexity of this
is not the same as space complexity. So let's
jump in. Let's say that we made our top level
call to dibba five, we know that that is added
to the stack in the same way five calls for
so it's that the stack, we add a stack frame
for every call that we make down until just
the base case, right. So at this point, I
reached a scenario where I have a base case,
and I'd have about five stack frames on my
call stack. And the important insight is when
we actually hit this base case that I have
highlighted the left one over here, it actually
will return when something returns when a
function returns, its stack frame is actually
removed or popped from the stack. And at this
point, only after I have returned from that
left one, what I actually add the right one
to the stack to be explored. And this process
continues. Notice that any point in time the
most number of stack frames that we use up,
it's exactly five, right, it's not as if we
throw all of these function calls on the stack
at once. And because we have such a nice tree
visual, we know that the number of stack frames
that we're ever going to use is really just
the height of the tree, right, so the height
of the tree is n like we said before, that
means our maximum stack depth is also n. So
we have in space complexity coming from the
call stack. So overall, for a dip function,
we're looking at two to the n time complexity,
but only and space complexity. Alright, so
let's look at one more function. See, I gave
you this very similar lib function. Notice
that in its recursive calls, it does an n
minus two. So by now you should be able to
visualize what structure like this would look
like, say we initially called lib with a value
of eight, what would the full tree look like?
Well, it would just look like this. Notice
that it's still a tree, right where every
node branches to two children. But this time,
we go by twos, right, so if I look for some
familiar ground here, I've noticed that from
one node to the next, I do one minus two.
And this occurs all the way down to a base
case. So we already know that, hey, we can
identify this tree as having a height of about
N over two. So I guess that means that the
time complexity is going to be two to the
N over two power, right, because from one
level of the tree to the next, we double the
number of nodes. So that's that two times
two times two repeating pattern for the number
of levels and our number of levels is N over
two, right? However, we can actually simplify
this time complexity, you can take that n
over to in the exponent and simplify that
to just an N. So overall, we're looking at
a two to the n time complexity. And using
our same arguments from last time, we know
that the space complexity for this from the
stack is also going to be N over two, which
simplifies nicely to N space complexity. So
we see that overall for our loop function,
we're looking at a two to the n time, but
no space complexity.
Alright, so now it's time to look at the big
picture, we looked at two toy functions of
dibben lib. And we saw that the only difference
in how they made the recursive calls, right
did did a minus one and lived in a minus two.
And we saw that despite their differences,
both functions had an exponential two to the
n time complexity, and a linear and space
complexity. That being said, Where does our
original Fibonacci function fit in this picture?
Well, you can imagine that kind of falls right
in between, we know that for our fib function,
it has two recursive calls for the first recursive
call, it makes it does n minus one like did
did. But its second recursive call this n
minus two like lib. So in a sense, it's kind
of like smack in the middle, right? If you
let me abuse the notation a little bit, and
just talking about the time complexity, we
can kind of say that the complexity of fib
is somewhere between dibben lib, but we've
already plugged in some values, right? You
know, that, hey, the lower bound that as Deb
has to to the end, and the upper bound, that
is lib has to at the end as well. So that
means that our fib function must have exactly
two to the n time complexity as well, right?
All three of these functions have an exponential
time complexity. Awesome. So that was a really
complete analysis of why we have this fib
function, it's evident that it has a two to
the n time complexity and an N space complexity.
Right now, the bottleneck that we're experiencing
is, of course, the time complexity, right
two to the n overall, is not undesirable complexity.
But do we really have a nice feel for what
this really implies? So let's take a look
at this to to the end. So what's the implication
of this? Well, you could kind of imagine that,
hey, if I asked for the 50th Fibonacci number,
that would take you know, roughly two to the
fifth power number of steps. And so if you
punch this exponent into a calculator, you're
gonna end up with a result like this, this
is roughly a 16 digit number. So you should
have a vi for you know, this being a very,
very, very large quantity. But I think that,
you know, to really understand the gravity
of what we're really saying here, if we expand
this number, that quantity is exactly this.
That's over one quadrillion 125 trillion,
which is really, really interesting, right?
Because we just asked our Fibonacci function
for just you know, something relatively modest,
right, the 50th Fibonacci number, and it's
gonna take quite literally a quadrillion steps
to do that. And of course, we can probably
do better. So let's work on making this faster.
So if I recognize that the bottleneck for
this fib function is the time complexity,
I know that that comes from the number of
recursive calls that I make. So what I want
to do is look for any patterns that I see
in the recursive nature of this problem, let's
see a quick snapshot of what the recursion
for fib of seven would look like, we know
that it looks like this tree just like we
saw before. So take a moment, look at this
tree, do you notice any interesting patterns
within it?
Well, one thing that I noticed is I can see
this subtree rooted at three, there, I have
two on the left and one on the right. And
if I look at that subtree, I can actually
see it in many different places in this tree,
right? This subtree rooted at three appears
in a bunch of different places, it's very
duplicate. In a similar way, I can look at
other sub trees, let's say I root myself at
four, and see that duplicate four sub tree
all over the place. And it's even carries
over for larger values of n like fib of five.
So I see that this tree has a lot of duplicate
sub trees, right? And I want to now draw a
connection between this diagram and what happens
in my code. I know that if I route myself
in any of these sub trees of five, I know
that each sub tree is trying to answer the
question. Hey, what's the fifth Fibonacci
number? I know that the Fibonacci number never
changes, right? If I calculate it once on
the left hand side, then the answer I should
get back on the right hand side shouldn't
differ at all. And so what I want to do is
possibly reuse these calculations right? If
I calculate the Fibonacci number over here,
then I should just store that because later
on it might be useful when need to recalculate
it over here. I would basically get rid of
a lot of the tree, I wouldn't have to travel
down this entire recursive tree rooted at
five. This pattern of overlapping subproblems
is known as dynamic programming. And so for
us dynamic program is going to be any instance
where we have some larger problem, in this
case, Fibonacci. And we can decompose it into
smaller instances of the same problem, we
also have an overlapping structure. So for
us, right, now, I see that I have to calculate
now let's say fib of five, twice over to calculate
the larger a fib of seven a solution. And
something we're going to be doing a lot in
this lesson is really trying to visualize
problems in terms of like their recursive
nature. So we're going to be drawing a lot
of trees. And what I'm always going to do
is try to really recognize, hey, what pattern
in this tree is duplicate, right? If I do
some duplicate work, if I do some duplicate
drawing that I know I can optimize that out
later on. But that being said, let's go ahead
and get to the punch line on this fib function
and work on optimizing this solution. Alright,
now let me discuss the plan, I think we're
ready to actually implement some code that
will actually carry that plan out. Here I
have our classic bonacci implementation, this
was the one that we ran earlier. And it's
definitely too slow, right has an exponential
time complexity. So I know that overall, when
I want to do is kind of capture a duplicate
subproblems, I want to store any results that
I get that way, if I have to recalculate those
subproblems. Later on, I can just use my stored
data. And so the trick here, it's a very common
programming pattern, we're going to implement
some memorization. memorization is actually
one of the overarching strategies we can use
to solve any dynamic programming problems.
And so just look at the name like why is it
called memoization? Well, this refers to like,
memo, right? So if I have like a memo, and
let's say, like real life, it's really just
like a reminder for myself. So using memoization,
I'm looking to do is store some duplicate
subproblems. That way, I can just get those
results later on. I think a really neat way
to implement memorization in JavaScript, as
well as many languages is to use some sort
of a fast access data structure usually be
like your hash map equivalent in the programming
language of your choice. For us, that'll be
a JavaScript object. And so our plan is to
use some JavaScript object. And so what do
I want the keys to be, so the keys in the
object are going to be the argument to our
function, right. And then the value will be
the return value, that we have a nice napping
for a argument to the function that is a function
call, as well as its return value, right.
And so what I can do for my existing function
is, I kind of just bake in some optional arguments.
So my favorite strategy is to do this, and
assign a memo to be an empty object. So if
you're unfamiliar with this syntax, in JavaScript,
it's pretty useful. What I'm saying is, if
I were to call our fib function, and not pass
in a second argument, by default, it will
create this memo, as containing a new JavaScript
object that is empty, of course, right? So
it's gonna be useful that way, whoever is
actually testing, my code doesn't have to
deal with setting up any memo object. So well,
I prefer this strategy over here. And what
I want to do is treat it as if that, hey,
this memo is going to store n as the key and
values are going to be just the return values
for this function. So what we're going to
see us doing a lot in this lesson is at the
start, we're going to first check for existence
inside of our memo. So let's say that we're
somewhere in the middle of recursion, the
first thing I should do is kind of add an
additional base case and say, Hey, is my current
argument n inside of the memo, and if it is,
then I can just get the stored value from
that memo. And I'm done. So I'm going to do
an early return here, I'm going to return
the value that corresponds to that memos key,
right, I'm just using the original argument
and as a key in my memo, and this condition
is really just some classic JavaScript syntax,
I'm just checking if some key is inside of
a JavaScript object. So
really quick, maybe just to warm us up, if
you haven't seen that syntax before. So let's
say I had some object and had some properties
inside and we had a name of Alvin, that's
me, then it had a favorite color of like gray.
And what I can do is check for an existence
of a key in that object. So JavaScript keys
are mostly strings, right? So I can check
Hey, his name in the object. That's true,
is the fav color in the object, make sure
I spell it right. That is also true, I can
check for a key that's not there, like I don't
know, his location and the object that is
false. And so here, I'm just using that same
pattern, but for and right, which is going
to be a number, technically, it'd be converted
into a string key, which would still totally
work here. Awesome. So I have my memo fetching
logic, right? I check, Hey, is this argument
in the memo, but if it's not, I'm gonna have
to actually manually do the calculation, which
is okay, because I know I need to do a subtree
at least once. So what I'll do is I'm going
to take the exact return value, right, so
this is my return value in the original brute
force. What I want to do is actually store
that entire result inside of my memo and the
key is course and write, the key you use to
access is always just what your argument is.
And I want to complete the original return.
So I can just go ahead and return what I just
put in that memo. So I'm not really changing
any return values, or I'm returning exactly
the expression that I returned before. But
now I'm actually also saving that value inside
of the memo object. What I want to do is make
sure that all of these recursive function
calls are accessing the same memo. So what
I'll do is I'll pass in that object to both
of these calls are really important pattern
here is, I know that I only receive a new
top level metal object, whenever I make a
top level call, that's a fit, right, because
I'm not passing in a second argument over
here. However, if I look at my recursive calls,
I do pass in explicit second arguments. And
so they're actually going to receive the same
memo object, and it would be like passed by
reference, right, because when you pass a
JavaScript object to a function, you actually
receive kind of that exact object, right,
you don't receive a copy of it, which is really
neat. So basically, I'm giving my function
calls a way to sort of communicate to each
other, they all have some sort of global information
to reference across all the recursive trees.
So this is looking good. Again, I just want
to emphasize I only added a new argument over
here, I added a new base case on line five,
then I added my memo storing logic on line
seven, but I didn't change any of the functional
logic here. Let's go ahead and run these test
cases. And we'll see how our code is doing
now. So moment of truth, I'm going to run
this file.
And notice how blazing fast our program was,
I still get the results of 813 and 21. And
the 50th Fibonacci number is indeed have this
very large number. And it basically executed
almost instantly. So let's go ahead and head
back to the drawing board. And really understand
you know, what happens when we execute this
sort of code. Alright, so it looks like we
implemented the improved version of Fibonacci
by memorizing it. And it's clear by running
the program that we definitely had an impact
on the time complexity. However, I really
don't want us to understand you know how the
structure of the recursion tree changes, once
we implemented this memoized version of the
code. So let's say I want to step through
an example of Fibonacci. And let's say I pass
in a number six. So really, what I'm looking
for here is to get back eight, because the
six number of the bonacci sequence is indeed
eight. So we know that we're going to have
a tree that looks like this, right? This is
a tree that would really be the full recursive
nature. So this is how the tree would look
like if I did not optimize it. And what impact
do we have by actually adding this memo object?
Alright, so let's start tracing through this,
I know that when I call fib of six at the
top level, an important thing to know is I'm
not going to pass in some memo object. So
by default, my code says it will initialize
it to an empty object. And the really important
aspect of this is I'm going to create a new
object just for the top level call. But then
that same object is going to be passed down
to my recursive calls, right noticing line
five. And so I'm going to travel down my left
hand path, right, six calls five, five calls
for four calls three, and three calls to,
and right now I've hit a base case. So I know
that this note of two is going to return one.
So that's kind of business as usual, right?
In the same way, now I need to evaluate this
other note of one, which is also base case,
it also returns one. And at this point, my
parent of three is actually ready to compute
the sum of its children, right. So one plus
one just gives me two. So I just add up those
values. And now three is returning two. However,
looking at line five of my code, not only
is this node going to return to to its parent,
it's also going to store it in the memo object,
right? So the key insight is, at this point,
I would add a key to my memo of three, whose
value is to basically in my memo, I kind of
read as if I'm saying, hey, the third Fibonacci
number is two, right? That in itself is logical.
So I can just continue this pattern right?
Now I start to evaluate what happens when
I'm at this note of t, which is also a base
case, it returns one. Now my call to four
is ready to compute, right? It's going to
take the sum of its both children. So it's
going to do two plus one gives me three. But
of course, it's also going to store that inside
of the memo, right? It's going to cash that
result out to be used later on. So that means
I make the N my key and I make the return
value, the value, right, so I'm going to have
four points to three inside of my mental object.
And now here's the beauty of this memoized
solution. At this point, I need to compute
what happens for fib of three. However, this
is actually going to hit one of the new base
cases I added, right? I know that three is
in the memo object looking at line two of
my code, right? It's in the memo object. And
so I just immediately return the stored value.
And so this call to fib of three is just going
to return the stored value of two. And if
I do that, I won't have to travel down the
full, you know, recursive subtree rooted at
three, right? I don't need to travel to these
nodes at all. So I already used some stored
value in my memo. At this point five is ready
to return right five will take The summer
both with children, three plus two is five.
And it's going to store that in the memo,
right? The fifth Fibonacci number happens
to be five. And now the same thing happens
for six is right child. So I have to evaluate
this node now. So what is the fourth of bonacci
number up, that's actually stored directly
inside of my memo. So this actually early
returns the stored value of three, right.
And again, the key insight is, it will return
that stored memo value without having to travel
through that full subtree. And at this point,
I can return for fib of six, so I do five
plus three, that gives me eight, this would
actually technically be stored in my memo
as well. So I have the six of bonacci number
as eight and very happy, right? The answer
is eight.
So it's evident that by memorizing our Fibonacci
function, we definitely cut down on the number
of recursive calls, we want to visualize that
we ended up with this kind of structure. Here
in light blue, I have a circle the nodes that
we technically didn't need to do the full
recursion at, right? So these nodes of two,
three and four, for this small example of
my initial fib of six, I was able to kind
of fetch a value from my memo and kind of
forego traveling down the recursive subtree.
So what do we actually know about the time
complexity of this function now? Well, I think
it's really important that we always try to
generalize things. So we just stepped through
a relatively small example of fib of six.
But how does this sort of scale? So this is
the same tree? Let's see, I kind of tidy it
up a little bit. So I know that in general,
fib of six kind of has this structure. So
I want you to take a moment, look at this.
And in your brain picture, what fib of seven
would look like if I memorize with with seven,
what would its sub trees look like? Well,
it really just looked like this. Notice if
I route myself at the seven node, its left
child is still six, right minus one. Its right,
Charles, still five minus two. So this still
obeys the laws of Fibonacci. If I asked for
fib of eight memoized, the structure would
be like this. And nine would look like this.
See the pattern looks like at this point,
we're just growing this like memoized chain
in a linear kind of way. If you're not convinced
by you know, that just like structural argument,
let's say we were a little more methodical,
we know that in this drawing, there is some
common ground, right? Again, like I always
say, when you tackle these new problems, or
new patterns, try to find some familiar territory,
right? Where can I recognize stuff I've seen
previously. So I look at this chain, I go
98765432, right. So this goes all the way
down in a very, very, very linear fashion,
right, just counting down. So I know that
if I just look at this highlighted chain in
yellow, that's definitely just an notes, right,
where n is my initial top level call. So I
know that what I have highlighted in yellow
is just a linear chain right there exactly
n nodes. But I haven't accounted for everything
in this picture, right, some of the nodes
are still in white, meaning I need to kind
of work them into my description of what the
shape of this tree is, well, I know that each
of those white nodes is actually connected
to some of the nodes, I've colored in yellow,
they're kind of paired off in a way, right?
For every node in my ello chain, it has exactly
kind of one partner node one right hand node
on its right hand edge. And overall, if I
have n pairs, that means I have to end things
overall, right? There are two things in a
pair. So overall, the number of nodes is roughly
two n. And I know that that can actually be
simplified, right? The time complexity here
would be two n, which just simplifies to n
time complexity. And using the same arguments
we did for our space complexity, we know that
the space is going to be n as well. And this
is pretty powerful stuff. by memorizing our
fib function, we brought it down from an exponential
time complexity to just a linear time complexity.
Pretty cool stuff, right? All right, I think
we're ready to graduate from Fibonacci. And
what we'll do is work on a more involved problem,
this one has more of a narrative to it. So
say that you're a traveler on a two dimensional
grid, you begin in the top left corner, and
your goal is to travel to the bottom right
corner of that grid. And the rule is you can
only move down or to the right, that means
you can't move up or to the left, and you
definitely can't move to AGL. That being said,
In how many ways can you travel to the goal?
That is how many ways can you travel to the
bottom rate if you had a grid of dimensions,
m by n. So the first thing I recognize here
is looks like the grid, maybe a rectangle,
not necessarily a square, right. And overall,
what we want to do is implement a function
that calculates this that is our function
is to take the dimensions of the grid. And
so before we hop into sketching the strategy
for this one, I think it's really important
that we make sure that we actually understand
what this question is asking. So let's say
they asked us to calculate grid traveller
of two comma three, that means they're asking
us in how many ways can you travel from the
top left to the bottom right, of a two by
three grid? I will tell you right now that
the answer here should be three. Right? So
there are three ways to do that. And in particular,
you can imagine that we had, you know, a two
by three grid, so that means two rows, as
well as three columns. And we start in the
top left, and our end goal is in the bottom
right. And so why do we say that there are
three ways to get from the top left to the
bottom right? Well, they told us in the problem
that we can only either take a right move
or a down To move, so one of the ways would
be going right right down, right, that would
bring us from the start to the end. And it
would kind of look like this. In a similar
way, another path we can take is doing a write
down, right? It would kind of look like this.
And the only other way would be going down,
right, right, which would look like this path.
And that's why we say there are only three
unique ways to travel not through a two by
three grid.
All right, so that's just one example of how
we might call a grid traveler, I think what's
really important to notice is try to also
frame the problem as if you were given some
relatively small inputs, but I think they're
really important case to think about is, what
happens if they give us like, basically, the
smallest valid grid we can have that is a
one by one grid. This one is kind of trivially
simple, right? A one by one grid only has
one unique way to travel from the start to
the end. And it's kind of concise in that
if you had a one by one grid, there's really
only one position, right? So that means that
the start is really the same as the end, and
kind of you already have the problem solved
out the gate, because to travel from the start
to the end, you kind of just do nothing, right?
So the logic here is in a one by one grid,
there's only one way to travel from the start
to the end, you're kind of already there.
So you don't need to take any moves. Something
else we might think about is what happens
when one of our dimensions is zero. So let's
say someone asked us to calculate grid traveller
of zero comma one, this is a kind of strange
question to ask because for one, if there
are zero rows and one column, that kind of
means that the grid is empty. So I would consider
that as there being zero waste to travel through
that grid because the grid is sort of invalid
in a way. In a similar way, if I asked you
for traveling through a one by zero grid,
there's still no grid to be found here. Right?
So it should also return zero. And likewise,
when either of the dimensions is zero, the
answer should just be zero, right? If one
of your dimensions is empty, then there really
is no grid.
So maybe you're catching on into why I brought
up those trivially small grid examples, right?
Those kind of sound like base cases, which
we can use to reconstruct a larger answer.
But let's stay grounded and look at another
grid. So let's say I asked you to calculate
grid traveler of three comma three, right?
So I want the answer for a three by three
grid. Well, how can we reason that one out?
At this point, what I'm looking to do is sort
of frame the problem in a way where I can
decrease the problem size, usually by mutating
the arguments to my function call. So let's
imagine this three by three grid, as always,
I want to move from the top left to the bottom,
right. So I begin at this position, let's
say, and so I know that overall, I have this
top level problem of saying, how many ways
can I travel through this entire three by
three grid, let's say I took one of the moves,
right, I can move either right or downward.
Let's say I made the decision to move downward.
Well, if I move downward, then I would appear
here now, I know in the future, I can only
move to the right or downward. So now it's
as if my playable area has been reduced to
just this shaded region. And if I look at
what I've actually done to this problem, I'm
still sort of in the top left corner of some
grid, where now I'm really trying to answer
the question, hey, and how many ways can I
travel through this two by three grid. And
this is a really important way that we're
shrinking the problem size, right, I had a
three by three grid initially. Now I have
a two by three grid. And this is really like
the relative grid from my current position,
we'll say, spanning all the way to the end
position. So if you look at this coordinate
of like two comma three, technically, that
is like not the coordinate of the person within
the larger grid. This is really the size of
the rectangle that the person is trying to
cover now. Right. So in a similar way, let's
say that, hey, I want it to move to the right
now. Well, that would also shrink the grid
along a different dimension. So I'd appear
over here. And now I have a two by two grid
that I'm trying to solve. And if I keep following
this pattern, we're gonna keep shrinking on
the problem size over here. Now, I'm asking
for a grid traveller of one by two. And finally,
if I take a right move over here, I'm asking
for grid traveller of one by one, which I
know is one of those sort of base case scenarios
that I had previously. So that's going to
be really useful when we actually implement
this in some code. And so the key insight
here is when we make a move through the grid,
that is when we go right or downward, are
basically shrinking the effective size of
the playable area, right, our grid gets smaller
along one of its dimensions. Awesome. So I
think now we're able to see that, hey, this
grid traveler problem definitely has some
overlapping subproblems. Right. Let's say
I tried to take more of like a programmatic
approach, something that we'll be doing a
ton, like, basically, for every problem in
this lesson is whenever we have a problem
that we kind of know is going to be recursive.
The move is to really structure it like a
tree, right? I want to really visualize this
because I know that if I had a tree structure
on pen and paper, I can implement that with
just some recursive code using some JavaScript,
right. So let's say that I wanted to take
more of a tree based visual understanding
now a grid traveller of two comma three. So
I know that usually the way we do this is
we encode nodes of the tree Using the arguments
to this function right? Now I have two arguments
where I have the number of rows and number
of columns. Whereas before for something simple
like Fibonacci, I only had a single argument.
So in the long run, I know that the answer
I should get back is three. So just keep that
goal in mind. Let's start to flesh out this
diagram. So I'm going to start with that top
level, column two comma three. And now I think
about how this node can transition to other
nodes, right? How does the State of my game
actually change? Well, I know there are really
two options I can take right? You can either
have one child going downward, or another
child going the right word, right? Those are
the two options based on the gameplay here.
And so if I go down, how does that change
of the number I put in the node? That is,
how does it change the dimensions of the playable
grid area? Well, if I go downward, then I'm
reducing the number of rows by one. So that
means my left child is just one comma three.
Now, if I had moved to the right, that would
mean I'm reducing the number of columns by
one. So my right child is just two comma two.
Notice that from parent to child, all I'm
doing is reducing a one of the dimensions
by one, right, that means you're either going
downward or going to the right, and I can
just carry over this pattern recursively,
right. So let's say I'm fleshing out this
node now, five, mat one comma three, then
its children would be just 03. And one, two.
And a similar way. If I wrote myself at two,
two, then I have children of one, two, and
two, one. But now let's notice something important.
Here. I've kind of spotted a node where I
have zero comma three, remember what we trace
through in terms of the visual drawing? What
is this? No trying to answer? Well, let's
notice saying in how many ways can you travel
through a zero by three grid, but if you have
zero rows, and there's really no grid to be
dealt with. And so I think for this note of
zero comma three, or really any node that
contains zero, we don't need to actually flesh
out its children. So instead, I'll work on
recursively, drawing out these other nodes.
So we'll carry over this pattern. At this
point, we've actually hit I think all of our
base scenarios, right. So if I look at these
notes, that have one comma one that was exactly
like the affirmative base case, meaning that
I know, trivially I can solve the one by one
grid. In other words, these function calls
are going to return one, right, in a one by
one grid, there's exactly one way to travel
from start to end, right, you kind of just
do nothing. And on the flip side of that,
for all those notes that contain a zero, they're
also a base case. But they're kind of like
the negative base case, meaning that there
is no way to actually travel from start to
end. So for all of these notes containing
zero, they should return zero to their parent,
right? There are zero ways to travel through
that grid. At this point, I just sum up these
values at the parent node, right? So I just
left these and then I add them together. And
I forget what these things are saying, right?
If I look at like the node one comma two,
above, it is one meaning there is one way
to travel through a one by two grid, right?
You kind of just move rightward. And so I
carry this pattern over, I keep adding the
children nodes at their parents. And this
carries up all the way to the root node. And
what do I know, there are three ways to travel
through a two by three grid. So although there's
like a narrative, and there's some, you know,
cute story behind this problem, it's really
just a spin off of Fibonacci. And that's going
to be the case with many of these dynamic
programming problems. So we've confirmed that
there are three ways to travel through a two
by three grid. And there's also some other
information encoded in this tree. I know that
whenever I took like a left hand edge in this
tree that I presented the choice of going
downward. And whenever I took a right hand
edge in this tree, that represented the decision
of moving rightward. And so if I have that
pattern in mind, that not only have I been
able to count the number of ways that I can
win the game, but I also know exactly which
combination of moves lead to a solution. One
of the ways to win this game is to go down,
right, right. Another way is to go right down,
right, and the final ways to go right right
down. So we can glean a lot of information
just from the same tree structure. Cool. So
I think that's enough drawing for now let's
go ahead and implement this in some code.
Alright, programmers, here we are back in
my text editor. Let's go ahead and implement
this grid traveler function. So you want to
go with that recursive strategy. So I'll start
by just laying down my base cases, I already
refer to the fact that hey, one of our base
cases is we have a one by one grid, just go
ahead and return to zero, right? So that's
really easy to do. So I'll check Hey, if m
is one, and n is one, then the answer is just
trivially one. Right? Then along with that,
I also have the base case when I had like
an invalid grid. That means if either of my
dimensions is zero, so I'm using an order
here, right? If either dimension is zero,
then your grid is empty, which means there's
definitely no way to travel from top left
to bottom right of that grid. Cool. Then my
recursive scenario is very straightforward.
All I need to do is get the sum between me
going downward and me going rightward, right.
So if I go Down number n is the number of
rows, if I go down that I'm decreasing the
number of rows affected rows, that is by one,
but I keep the same number of columns. And
then in a very symmetric way, if I move to
the right, that means I still have the same
number of rows. So I keep him, but I decrease
n, right, I have one less column. So this
code is looking pretty sharp, really just
some reminiscent Fibonacci style code. Let's
go ahead and give this a run. So I'm running
a few examples over here. And these are the
expected results. In some comments, we'll
go ahead and bang this one out, grid traveller.
Cool. So I get the first four results. 1336
looks like it's working just like a charm.
However, for this last example of an 18 by
18 grid, looks like my programs hang right
now, it's actually a little too slow to calculate
an 18 by 18 grid, so you probably see where
this one's heading. Let's go ahead back to
the drawing board and really understand a
why this code is fairly slow. Alright, so
here we are back in the drawing board, because
it looks like we hit a wall when it came to
our recursive implementation of grid traveller.
That being said, I think implementing the
brute force solution here is actually a really
logical first step. And now we can just focus
in on where there is room for improvement.
So our first question is, you know, what is
the actual time complexity of this implementation?
Well, I know when I call a grid traveller
of two, three, the full tree would explore
is this right. And like we said, in our Fibonacci,
to understand the time complexity here, it's
really about to understand the number of function
calls we make, which is really the number
of nodes in this tree. And of course, I want
to generalize my understanding for any large
inputs. So I know that this tree sort of looks,
you know binary in a way, meaning that a node
can branch to up to two children, which makes
sense, because from one position of the grid,
I have two choices to make, right, I either
go down or I go to the right. But that being
said, I need to realize what the height of
this tree is. And this one's pretty interesting,
because out the gate, we actually have two
input arguments to our function, I'm given
two numbers, m and n. And since this function
contains two inputs, it shouldn't be the case
that our final complexity analysis actually
describes it in terms of those two number
inputs. So what I'll do is try to recognize
the height of this tree. And so I'll just
choose some path from the root to the leaf.
And kind of in the recursive sense, that means
I take some path from my top level call all
the way down to the base case, and preferably
the far this base case. So I know my base
cases are either when one of my arguments
turns to zero, or when both of my arguments
turn to one. And I think in general, the farther
base case would be a scenario where both of
my arguments are one. So here I have a path
highlighted that ends in a one one. And in
general, I know from one node to the next,
what I do is either decrease the M by one,
or I decrease the n by one, it's never the
case that I can decrease both of the numbers
by one, because that would kind of entail
that you're moving diagonally across the grid,
which is not allowed in the gameplay. So if
I can either subtract one from em, or subtract
one from n, and overall a path from my initial
input down to a space, like one one is going
to have a distance of n plus m, we basically
had to subtract, you know, n and m from your
initial node to reach that bottom level of
one comma one, that kind of tells me the number
of levels in this tree, right using the same
arguments as before, it's still the case that
most of this tree is going to be binary, meaning
that a node branches to two children. And
so I have that two times two times two pattern
for the number of levels in this tree are
saying that they're n plus m levels. So really,
the time complexity is two to the n plus m
power, right. So still some sort of exponential,
that was just sort of the multi variable exponential,
because I have two variables of m and n.
And likewise, for the space complexity, you
know, the space complexity, in general for
recursive code is just going to be the height
of the tree, the height of the tree gives
us the maximum stack depth of the recursion.
In this case, it'll just be the number of
levels still, which is n plus m. Cool. So
obviously, the limiting factor here seems
to be that time complexity of two to the n
plus m time. Alright, so you probably anticipated
the time complexity of this one being exponential.
That being said, I think it's really important
to still have a nice argument to you know,
say what the time complexity is. That way,
you can get a massive buy in from your interviewer
right. So don't skip the steps of trying to
draw it out and actually defend your reason
for why the time complexity is exponential.
But let's try to improve this now. Is there
any room to actually improve the runtime of
this function? Well, here's that same drawing,
right? Just sort of cleaned up. So I have
grid traveller of two comma three, and this
would be the full tree. We sort of already
know now that I have this recursive tree structure.
What I could possibly do is notice any duplicate
work, right? Is there some work I can prevent
myself from doing here. So take a moment and
really remind yourself of the actions we took
in the Fibonacci problem. And see if there's
any patterns in this tree, probably from the
gate, you notice that? Oh, I have some duplicate
sub trees right? Have one comma two. So in
these the two highlighted sub trees in blue,
that's sort of asking the question, hey, what
is the total number of ways I can travel through
a one by two grid? That being said, I think
there's even more sub trees that correspond
to that particular problem. What if you look
at this far right subtree of two comma one,
if you really, really think about it, asking
the number of ways to travel through a one
by two grid is the same as the number of ways
to travel through a two by one grid, you're
just flipping the rows and the columns, but
the total number of ways should be exactly
the same. So that's actually a pretty interesting
way you can optimize this solution. So I can
still memorize it. That is I have these duplicate
sub problems. But possibly a really cool insight
we can make in this problem is, you can also
sort of flip of the arguments. In other words,
if someone asked you, for grid traveler have
a comma b, then that would be the same answer
for a grid traveler of B, comma a, write the
order of the arguments technically doesn't
matter here, until we can totally encode that
in our memo object. That being said, punchline
here is, we better memorize this one. So I
think let's hop to it. All right, here we
are back in my text editor. And hopefully,
that diagram of how we can improve the time
complexity for this one, make some sense,
let me go ahead and kill this program still
running. And my computer's fan is actually
going crazy. Now it's running the entire time.
Let's go ahead and memorize this one to the
beauty of you know, solving these dynamic
programming like problems is if we have the
initial strategy of implementing, like the
brute force recursion, and we wrote like a
very well formed recursion, meaning that I
actually use return values, and I reconstruct
the sub solutions all the way up to the tippy
top. Because I have a really nice recursion
here. memoization is a very like formulaic
pattern. So it's going to be almost the same
strategy, we did have Fibonacci, even other
problems that we do in this lesson. So we're
going to bake in my default mental as an empty
object. And then along with that, I'm going
to add my memo checking logic. So I know we're
here in general, and to check, hey, are the
arguments in the memo, right, I need to key
into my memory object using all of the arguments.
Now I have two arguments. And since both of
the arguments combined, sort of dictate the
output, I need a key that sort of contains
both of those in JavaScript keys are either
strings or symbols. So for us right now, really,
strings is the most relevant one. So what
I'll do is I'll concatenate both of these
integers together. That way, I have a string
which I can key into the object with. And
we'll all definitely want to do is also maybe
separate them with a comma, let's say, so
I'll say like key equals m plus a comma, plus,
and, and the reason that you probably want
like some sort of separator between these
two arguments in your key is to make sure
the numbers don't get misinterpreted. So I've
actually ran into this issue in the past,
can you imagine like, if I had a scenario
where, let's say m,
was 42. And then we'll say n was a number
three. So what I don't want to do is just
make my key, something like four to three,
because this isn't going to uniquely identify
the exact input argument, right? Because if
this was just my key, then I guess I have
the same key for a totally separate set of
arguments. If I gave you four and 23, right,
both of these combinations of very different
arguments would lead to the same key, they
would collide at the same key. So instead,
I'll prefer to put a comma between them right
now I know without a doubt that this key corresponds
to four comma 23. Right. So that's why I put
a separator between them. And depending on
the language that you know, you're choosing
for interviews, you can find a very similar
construct. Cool. So now I'll go ahead and
check, hey, if my key is in demo, then I have
the Result Cache already. So I could just
return net cash value. So return memo at key.
And then what I want to do is look for my
old return value, right? So here's where I
actually do the manual recursive calculation.
Before I return that I want to store it in
my memo, using the same key and then return
that thing, I just put in the memo just completing
the old return logic. Cool. So you've seen
this pattern before, I just want to emphasize
a few things. Now it's the second time we're
seeing it. memoization, for me, at least,
is a very, very formulaic thing, right? So
I always take the exact expression that I
returned previously, and I put that entire
thing in the memo object, right? Notice that
my key encodes the arguments for this function,
right? Mnn. Something that I've seen students
do in the past is do like very heavy handed
logic, where they try to, you know, check
if the child call is in the memo. In other
words, don't write any pre emptive logic where
you check Hey, if you know m minus one And
so if you like concatenate those two things
together, don't check if like your child's
key is in the memo, right? So imagine like,
this was my key right now. Right? don't check
if that is in a memo. When you write logic
like that, it ends up being very, very duplicate
and a little harder to debug, right? Instead
of writing your function as if it's, you know,
reasoning for its children calls, you know
that once you actually evaluate those child
calls, they're going to cache themselves,
right, they're eventually going to check this
if statement anyway, alright, so don't do
any like the look before you leap logic, just
make the recursive call. That way, every recursive
call doesn't like self service, right? So
I prefer this way implemented. And with that,
let's go ahead and run this code. So I'll
give this a shot grid tremor, I still have
that 18 by 18 grid, which took quite long
last time didn't actually finish while I was
waiting. Looks like I'm still hanging here,
because I'm actually missing a little bit
in my code. So take a moment, see if you can
spot it, I forgot one really important thing.
So I have the logic of checking if my key
exists in the memo. And I also have a logic
of storing something in my memo if the key
doesn't exist, but what I failed to do was
actually passed down the memo object to all
of the recursive calls, I want to pass it
down over here. Remember, the trick is only
top level when someone calls like two comma
three for grid traveller, then we're going
to initialize a brand new empty object, which
will be shared for the rest of the recursion,
because it's passed down by reference at this
point. So that's a common mistake.
Let's go ahead and run this now. Nice. And
there we have it. Look how quick our last
execution was over here now is the expected
answer for an 18 by 18. grid. Cool. So here's
what we'll do, it's evident that we definitely
set up the execution of this one, let's head
back to the drawing board to wrap up this
problem and really see how we cut down the
complexity here. All right, so it looks like
we definitely improved the runtime of our
function. But I want to really understand
you know, what the big O complexity of our
improved function is now. So sort of a way
we constructively argue for what the new time
complexity is, is to think about where the
values of the nodes that will actually have
to travel through. So let's say I looked at
this example, I wanted to find the number
of voice a traveled through a four by three
grid, I know in general, there would be a
top level node, of course, four comma three.
But in general, that refers to m n, right?
So I'm trying to think in a very general way
right now. And so I know when it comes to
the other nodes of this tree, they're all
going to sort of at most be four comma three,
but then probably be less than that, right?
They have like a range of values for the nodes.
It's not as if to solve grid traveler, four,
three, I would have to solve 530, right, that
would be a larger grid. That doesn't make
sense here, right? I'm shrinking the subproblems,
only in this rendition of grid traveler. And
so if I think about some possible values here,
I know that if M is for top level, then all
of the values for m in the rest of the tree
would be from zero all the way up to and including
four, right, it's never going to be bigger
than four. In a similar way, since n is three
here, the only possible values for n in the
rest of my tree are zero through three. Right?
So roughly Mele, we're a little off by one
here, because I have to include zero, because
we know that that's a base case, in our edition
of this problem. That being said, there are
roughly n choices for the first number, node,
and n choices for the second number in the
node. And along with that, we know that we're
not gonna have to travel through many duplicate
sub trees, because we memorize them away.
And so I think what I can say here is the
total number of nodes you can possibly have
is m times n, and I'll be the number of like
distinct nodes, right? Because I have m choices
for the first number in the node and n choices
for the second number. I know that I'm going
to really minimize any duplicate exploration
through the memo object. So the really the
implication here is we started out with our
brute force recursive implementation, which
looked like it was exponential in the time,
right, it was two to the n plus m time. And
then by memorizing this function, we were
able to bring it down to n m times n, time
complexity, which is much faster. Notice that
the space complexity stays here, which is
really fine, because n plus m is some sort
of a multi linear function. Cool. So there,
we have our nice optimal solution for this
grid traveler problem. So key thing I want
you to take away from this one is, although
the initial narrative and the problem made
it seem, you know, pretty specific, and pretty
different from a previous dynamic programming
problem, like Fibonacci, was really the same
sort of story, the most important thing that
we're going to sort of leverage throughout
in this lesson that we leverage twice already
is try to think about your recursive functions
in terms of a tree, right, I get the most
information out of the tree. And then from
there, I can use that tree to not only implement
a brute force, but to also recognize, hey,
where can I optimize this brute force, that
way you can reach for the optimal solution.
Alright, so we've gone over two different
problems together, and hopefully we're starting
to notice how we tackled them in similar ways.
I think it's about Tammy gave herself some
guidelines for solving dynamic programming
problems using a memoization strategy. So
we'll call this our memorization recipe. And
there are three different ways you can go
about learning this topic of memorization.
And you might have different recommendations.
This is just my particular recommendation.
So I think the most important thing to establish
if you want to, you know, solve some dynamic
programming problem using memoization, is
to stick to to like high level steps, we definitely
need to at first just have a solution that's
recursive. So just make it work could be slow,
that's okay. And after that, we make it efficient.
I think this is where a lot of students sort
of try to take on too much at once. They try
to just solve it quickly all in one go. Right?
To me, it should be a very separate process,
right? First, I look for correctness in my
solution. And then once I have correctness,
then I look for efficiency in my solution.
So when we go through step one, if I just
want to get a working solution, then I have
to start visualizing these problems as trees
in dynamic programming problems, the gist
of them are that we have some large problem
that I can break down into smaller instances
of the same problem. So when I visualize it
as a tree, what I'm looking to do is figure
out all right, in the nodes of the tree, that
should represent a problem. And when I draw
an edge between nodes, that should be shrinking
the size of the problem. And depending on
you know how your problem is stated, you'll
have to figure out that logic, right? In the
case of our Fibonacci, it was as simple as
we know, we can decrement our values of n.
But in the case of our grid traveler, what
we had to do was travel rightward or downward.
And once we do that, you want to implement
that tree using recursion. What's great about
a tree is it's already a recursive structure.
Right? So how do you start to translate that
kind of tree visualization to some recursive
code? Well, you think about the leaves of
that tree as your base case, right? Lately,
for us, it's been about some small numbers,
right? So like a grid of size one, or it could
also be in the case of Fibonacci, just our
initial seed values of n equals one, and n
equals two. Now, once you have that baseline
recursion, that's going to be your brute force
solution. And so you'll want to test it. To
me this testing step is really important,
right? So if you pass inputs into your brute
force recursion, it should give correct answers.
Although possibly for large inputs, it may
take a long time, right? To me, there's a
big difference between code that is slow,
and code that is wrong, right. So here, we
should give back valid results, although maybe
our code is a little slow. Once we have our
working brute force solution, making it efficient
using memorization is a very, very canned
scenario. All we do is start by adding a memo
object into the mix. So this memo object needs
to have keys which represent arguments to
our function. And the values of that object
represent the return values for those function
calls. We know that in our functions, a unique
set of arguments should give me a particular
result. So we're just having that sort of
mapping inside of an object, you need to make
sure that this object is shared among all
of your recursive calls. One way you can do
that is to pass them along as arguments. And
lately, I've been doing that by giving myself
a default empty object at the top of each
of my recursive calls right through my top
level call. And once we do that, we need to
add a new base case into our code. So I'm
not going to remove any of the old base cases,
from my brute force solution to me, I'm just
adding a new base case that captures the memo.
In other words, if my arguments are in the
memo object as a key, then I'll return the
stored value, I refer to that as like my memo
fetching logic, right? Looking up some stored
value in my memo. And beyond that, the only
thing we need to do is implement our memo
storing logic. And it's as simple as going
to exactly where we had our return values
in our function. And then we just make sure
that we add those return values into our memo
object before returning, right, so I always
look to the exact return expression, and just
write some code around it, right storing that
result into another mental object before I
return it, right? Step two is actually very,
very easy to implement, meaning it's very
easy to memorize a brute force solution, it's
really coming up with the brute force in the
first place, that kind of feels more difficult.
So as you're learning and practicing memorization
for these dynamic programming problems, I
highly, highly recommend you stay very methodical,
and follow these steps, right? Don't try to
efficiently implement an algorithm from the
get go get a brute force working solution
with recursion, and then implement it using
memoization. Afterwards, right. And as you
get more practice with this technique, soon,
you'll be able to do everything all in one
swoop, but I don't recommend that until you've
definitely finished this course.
So we'll be sure to follow these rules for
falling problems. Alright, so I think it's
tempting increase a difficulty and we're going
to know Their dynamic programming problem.
So let's work on this can some function, what
I need to do here is take in a target some
as an argument, as well as an array of numbers
by function needs to return a Boolean. So
true or false, indicating whether or not it
is possible to generate the target some using
some numbers from the array. And along with
that, we have some constraints here, we can
totally use an element of the array as many
times as we want. And we can also assume that
all input numbers, so the target sum as well
as the numbers of the array are non negative.
So let's try to understand what this question
is asking. Let's say I gave you this example
case. So it looks like our targets, I'm a
seven, and the array of numbers is 534, and
seven, here, the response should be true because
it is possible to generate seven, by adding
some amount of numbers from the array, one
way you can generate seven is by just doing
three plus four, another way would actually
be to just take the loan seven, because seven
is actually a member of the array. So it's
definitely possible to generate seven using,
you know, some amount of numbers from the
array. So that's why we return true. Let's
see, I gave you another example. Let's say
I gave you a target sum of seven again, but
I gave you a different array of just two and
four, this is actually going to return false,
because there is no possible way that combinations
of two and four can actually sum to seven.
Cool. So that's really what the question is
asking. Now let's try to think about how we
can frame this problem of recursively. Right?
Hopefully, you've already gathered in your
mind. If we have a smaller amount of targets
some, then they'll tend to be a smaller, easier
problem than a larger number for targets.
All right, so let's start to think about the
recursive structure. For the first example,
we know in the long run, we should be able
to derive the answer true from the string
that we make. So like, we always say, we should
encode the arguments to our function into
the nodes of our drawing. That being said,
since in the problem, they told us that we
can reuse an element of the numbers array
as many times as we need, I'm just going to
omit that from the node drunk, because basically,
every node every function call is going to
receive the same array. So I'll just list
the target sum in every node. So I start with
seven, and I have to think about how I can
transition to other nodes, right? How can
I shrink the size of this problem? Well, I
know that I only have, you know, four options
I can take right have an option for every
element of the array. So basically, if I'm
at this seven node top level, I can branch
to some children, and sort of the rule for
my transition is you can either take a five,
take a three, take a four, take a seven. And
if I actually take you know those elements
as a choice, they are going to decrease my
current target sum. In other words, seven
minus five is two, seven minus three is four,
seven minus four is three. And of course,
seven minus seven is zero. So notice, we have
a very particular rule from traveling from
a parent node to some child, I can just carry
over this pattern. However, we have to watch
out right, so let's say I tried to flesh out
this note where my target sum is two, if I
look at the options I have, right, I still
have the options of 534, and seven, however,
none of them are really compatible with this
target sum of two, right, what I don't want
to do is take any of these choices, because
that would kind of give me a negative target
sum. So I can't really flesh out this note
two anymore. That is there are no valid options
for this node. However, some of these other
nodes like this for to have valid options.
So what I can do is take a three or take a
four, and of course, I get a one and zero
respectively. And I'll also do this for the
three over here, right? For this three node,
I can only take a minus three as a choice.
Cool. If I look at all of the nodes that I
have, now, I like the leaf level, it looks
like they all sort of bottom out at a base
case, that is there is no further choices
we can take. And I also noticed that some
of my nodes have a zero in them, if I look
at the notes that have a zero in them, they
actually are a really nice base case, because
I basically have found that I can generate
to the original target sum right away, you
can kind of understand the base case, when
the target sum is zero is you can always generate
a sum of zero by taking no elements from the
array, right? So these zero nodes are trivially
solved. And to me, they should return a true
backup to their parent, right. And it's sort
of on the flip side for all of my nodes that
are not zero. And they also can't break down
into any further nodes. Those return false,
right? Because they kind of have a leftover.
And I know there are no possible options I
can take to reduce that further. So all of
these other nodes should return false to their
parent. And remember what this question is
asking, right? It's really asking, Hey, is
it possible at all to generate the original
target sum? And so the logic is when these
values these Boolean values return to their
parent, the parent should just check if at
least one of them is true. And if at least
one of them is true, then that parent should
also return true. And if I look at this for
note, have a tree above it, and that sort
of answers the question, Hey, can I generate
a sum of four using elements of the array
and you totally can because if you look at
the elements of the array, there is exactly
one for so I can just take that into my son.
So I'll be sure to bubble up, you know all
these Boolean values to their parent. And
again at the parent will just make sure that
at least one of the values that gets back
is true. And so if at least one of them is
true, then the parent itself will also return
true. So very reminiscent of some like Fibonacci
bubbling up pattern as well as our grid traveller,
except now we're kind of adapting this for
some boolean data, but it's really the same
structural understanding I have. Cool. So
that was an example where we said true, right,
there is a way to generate the sum. Let's
look at another example. Right? How do we
know the flip side. So if we have this example,
right, seven, and an array of two, four, in
the long run, that's gonna return false, right,
there's no possible way you can generate that
target sum of seven. So the tree for this
example would look like this. So this is a
full tree. Notice that all of the leaves get
as low as one, but they can't be broken down
any further. Like we just said, in our last
sketch all of these ones, since they can't
be broken down any further, and they haven't
reached zero, they're going to return a false
up to the parent. And I know that if I bubble
up all these false values, of course, a top
level call will also return false. Right?
So it looks like a key insight we have for
this problem is, if we find at least, you
know, one base case that returns true, I know
that I can sort of stop early and just return
true all the way up to my parent, because
they're not really asking like, how many ways
can you generate the target sum? They're just
asking, Hey, yes or no, can you generate the
target sum at all. So that's gonna be a really
nice way to implement this code. I think we're
ready to jump right into the code. So let's
do it. Okay, so let's go ahead and implement
this can sum function. So since we're going
to solve it recursively, I think a good starting
place, as always, is to maybe handle some
of the base cases. So when we drew up the
tree, I noticed that one of our base cases
was when the target sum reaches the value
zero, right? If our target sum is zero, then
we have like, basically trivially solved the
problem, because you can definitely always
generate the target sum of zero by taking
no numbers from the array, right? So I'm going
to return true. If ever I reach a zero, then
Apart from that, I think let's go ahead and
work on the recursive scenario. So I know
that I need to establish some logic where
I make a recursive call or a branch for every
element of the numbers array. So what I'll
do is I'll iterate through that array of numbers.
So I'll use some for let of syntax we'll say
let num of the numbers, right. So if you're
unfamiliar with the syntax, all it does is
iterate through every element of the array.
So for example, let's say I just called the
first example for can sum of seven, and an
array of two, three, if I just console dot
log, the num, I'm just going to see the elements
printed out of two, three, right, so let's
give this a quick spot check. Nice, so just
iterating through every number of the array,
no tricks here. But now that I have that number,
I need the branching logic. So remember, the
logic we use for transitioning from one node
of the tree to the next, what we did was subtract
our current choice of number from the target
sum, and they basically gave us like the new
target sum. So I'm going to express that and
maybe some variable, so I'll say, Alright,
I'm going to generate the remainder by calculating
the difference between the target sum and
the number, right, so I'm just subtracting
the number from my target sum, that gives
me my new remainder, which becomes a target
sum. Right? So at this point, I think I need
to call recursively on can some of our pass
in this remaining quantity?
It doesn't need a second argument, still,
I'm still gonna pass in the same exact numbers
array. So I'll still pass in numbers unchanged.
I think that you know, the fact that we pass
in the same exact numbers, right, it's pretty
consistent with the way they stated the problem,
because we can totally reuse the numbers of
the array as many times as we like. Cool.
So now that I'm using our function, again,
I'm making the recursive call, I want to think
about what this call will return. I know at
any point in time, my can sum function is
going to return Boolean. And what's great
about boolean data is there's only two possibilities,
right, either true or false. So I think, based
on what we said about the tree was, if this
call, if that returns true, then I can just
ultimately respond with a true right now.
So I'll write it like this. So this is saying,
All right, if we figure out that it is possible
to generate the remainder now using numbers
of the array, then I can return true for this
larger problem of target some, right? So if
I find at least one way that works out, then
I'm going to do an early return true. And
the really important pattern here is we don't
want to write the LS and then return false.
Instead, we'll want to return false after
the for loop. And so here's the reason why
you want to return false after the for loop.
I only know that after I attempted you know
all possibilities and I found that none of
them worked out Can I actually say that it
is impossible to generate the target some
Right, so I need to make sure that this for
loop tries all possibilities of number. Before
I can say false, the target sum cannot be
generated. That being said, there's one thing
we should add to our code. So if you look
at line six, all right, I'm subtracting our
choice of num from the target sum. And that
means that sometimes the remainder might become
negative. So remembering our tree structure,
we made sure to sort of return a false whenever
we had a sum note, I didn't do any branching.
To kind of account for that I can kind of
bake that into another base case. But this
time, make sure it doesn't return true. So
I'll say, you know, if my target sum is negative,
if it's less than zero, then you've gone too
far. And you can just return false. Here,
it's safe to just automatically return false
if your target sum hits something less than
zero, because you've gone too far. And there's
really nothing else you can add from the numbers
array to ever fix that negative target sum.
Remember, they told us in the problem, that
your numbers are always going to be provided
as positive numbers or just zero, right? So
let's go ahead and give this a go. So I'll
try all of these examples. And we'll see what
we get. So I expect a true true false, true,
false. Cool, so looks like a few of them are
working right, it looks like the first four
are working totally fine. But looks like on
that last example, my program still running.
And if you notice, I chose a pretty large
value for em. So kind of like we expect this
solution has correctness. But it possibly
lacks some efficiency, it looks like it just
finished, the definitely took way too long.
And so it's a very interesting example of
a slow input to can some, because for one,
the length of the array is pretty sure I only
gave two elements here. But it seems like
this number as a target sum really affected
the runtime. So we'll do, let's head back
to the drawing board, and talk about the complexity
of this baseline solution. Alright, so we
implemented the brute force for our khamsum.
But obviously, now we want to make it a little
faster. But before we kind of just jump into
memorizing the solution, let's at least describe
the complexity of our current brute force.
So let's try to visualize this example. So
I have a target sum of eight. And my choices
for my numbers are two, three and five. In
the long run, they should return true, the
visual for the full tree would look something
like this, notice that it's fairly large tree
of forbs and relatively small inputs, right,
I only have a target sum of eight, and only
three choices. So let's try to describe the
complexity of this, I'll sort of generalize
the shape of it, get rid of those numbers.
So this is the overall shape of the tree.
And I know I want to describe my complexity
in terms of the input to my function, this
function has two inputs to the right, I'll
say that M is the size of the target sum,
and n is the length of the array I'm given,
I know that both of these arguments definitely
have an effect on the dimensions of this tree.
So like we did in all of our other examples,
I'll start by maybe analyzing the height of
this tree, that is a what would be the maximal
distance from the top level call to a base
case, or in the structure of the tree, what
is the maximal distance from the root of the
tree to the farthest
leaf. So if you sort of imagine that, we have
m as the root of the tree, imagine that along
the left hand path, we just did a minus one
all the way down, right? So we kept taking
a minus one, right? In the worst case, maybe
there's a minus one present in our a numbers
array. In the worst case, the distance from
the root to a base case would be exactly m,
because you have to subtract one m times,
right. So I can basically say that the height
of this tree is M. And it kind of like we
said in our other problems, that means that
the number of levels is m right. So now that
I've identified the height of this tree, the
move is now to identify the branching factor.
That is, how does the number of nodes change
from one level to the next. Remember that
initially, we described this particular tree
example is having numbers array length of
three. And you'll notice that the maximum
branching factor is exactly three or in general,
N, right? because n is the length of the array.
So for example, if I had three numbers in
the array, then a node would have at most
three children, right? Cuz you have three
options to take. We've seen this pattern before
I have n levels, and from one level to the
next, I would multiply the number of nodes
by n, right? This is the same thing as saying,
Hey, we take n and multiply it by itself,
m times. And this would definitely give us
an exponential complexity, right in particular,
and to the M time complexity, like we always
say another great thing about this type of
diagram is we can also derive the space complexity,
right? So what would be the space used by
the call stack, it would really just be the
height of the tree, which we already described
as M. So overall, our brute force is looking
at an end to the M time complexity, and M
space complexity. So now that we actually
have you know those concrete numbers for our
complexity, let's go ahead and focus on how
you can truly improve this So here's again,
the drawing for this particular example. It's
a fairly large one. And typically, you know,
when you're trying to notice where there is
room to be optimized, you might have to give
yourself a sufficiently large example to see
these scenarios. So in this example, I do
have overlapping subproblems. And in the context
of my tree, that means I have duplicate sub
trees. So I can look at possibly this subtree
rooted at three, notice that the root of that
subtree is trying to answer the question,
Hey, can I generate a target sum of three
using the array? And of course, once you find
that answer, that answer is never going to
change for your target sum of three, right?
So I know that all three of these sub trees
are trying to ask the same problem. And so
what I'll do is I'll just cache those results
in my memo object like we always do. Let's
go ahead and work on that. All right, welcome
back to my code editor. And same stuff, different
days. Let's go ahead and minimalize. This
can sum function, right. Once we've established
the brute force through the recursion, then
memorization is pretty formulaic. Right? Alright.
So we'll start by just baking in our memo
object like we usually do. So if someone calls
our function without a third argument that
is like a top level call, we'll be sure to
give them a new object. And I'll, before I
forget, be sure to pass down this memo object,
I'm going to make sure that every top level
call and it's recursive tree shares the same
memo object. But now I need to figure out
what what should I use to key into the memo
object. So here I have two arguments of my
original function are I have targets summon
numbers, what I want to do is try to notice,
you know, which of these arguments is actually
going to directly impact the return value.
So I know that through the recursive calls
like this call over here, the numbers argument
doesn't change. And so if it doesn't change,
then right now, it doesn't really affect other
return value. So I'd be okay to just use the
target sum as the key into this memo. So we'll
go ahead and do that. So I'll check if my
target sum is in the memo, that I've seen
that sub problem before, so I can just return
the stored value. Cool. And now I have my,
you know, memo fetching logic. But now I need
to actually store things in the memo. And
the trick is, what I want to do is look at
all of the return values that were not base
cases, and I need to now store them in my
memo. So I have to return values here, right,
these two lines, lines, 10 and 14. And so
I need to store data into the memo for both
of those lines, it's as simple as quite literally
going into your memo using your key, so target
some, and then assigning the value we just
returned.
So I'll just write it like this. And this
is going to be sort of a hard and fast rule,
you can always use our for a memorizing a
brute force recursive function, right. So
I'm just going to take exactly the lines or
the expressions that I returned in the recursive
scenarios. And now just store them in the
memo. Cool. So let's go ahead and give this
a shot, this code is looking pretty good.
And remember before this last call with an
input of target, some 300 took notice will
be long. But I think now when I give this
a shot, right, it finishes really quick. So
this is going to be a nice optimized solution
for cancer. Really, most of the work of this
problem was done in the brute force. And then
afterwards, it's really just a minor adjustment
to make it efficient. So to wrap up this problem,
let's go ahead back to the drawing board and
talk about the improved complexity. So we
definitely memorize the heck out of that code.
But let's recap by just understanding what
the new complexity is. So again, we're saying
that M is the target sum, and n is the length
of the array. Initially, we said that our
brute force solution had an end to the M time
complexity, which is exponential. And actually,
once we memorized it, we really cut down on
that complexity, we brought it down to n m
times n type complexity. And so here we say
that the memo is complexity is now m times
n, because of the memo object, right? We know
that the value of the nodes in the tree are
just going to be values up to m or their m
different possible values we can have in a
node. However, it now since we are able to
cache values or cache results inside of the
memo object, I'm never gonna have to re explore
a subtree before M. That being said, I select
the branch and times for each of those nodes,
right. So overall, I have m times n nodes.
So hopefully that can some problem made some
sense, because we want to do now is actually
carryover a lot of that knowledge to solve
this new Howsam problem. So this problem is
very similar, it still asks us to take in
some target some an array of numbers, but
this time around, we want to do is return
an array containing a combination that adds
up to exactly the target sum. And if there's
not any combination that actually leads to
the target some, then I should just return
null. Along with that, if there are many possible
combinations that can reach the target some
that that can return any of those. So you
probably Already recognizing that this house
some problem is very similar in logical structure
to the can some problem right? instead of
returning a Boolean instead now I want to
return exactly the combination of elements
of the numbers array that leads to my target
sum, so it's a little more involved. That
being said, let's take a look at some examples
to make sure we're on the same page. So let's
say someone asked us to calculate how some
and our target was seven, and our array of
numbers are 534, and seven. So there are actually
a few different combinations that can give
you your target sum of seven. One way would
be to take three plus four, that's one possible
answer, another possible answer would just
be returning an array of seven. So no matter
which combination array you return, it'll
be considered correct in either scenario.
Let's say I gave you another example, where
your target sum was eight, and your choice
of numbers were two, three and five. One possible
solution for a combination is two plus two
plus two plus two, right? So I returned that
in an array, another combination would be
just three plus five, notice that no matter
what we're always looking to get back in array,
if it is possible that our target sum can
be generated. But let's look at the flip side.
Let's say that we were given this input, so
I have a target sum of seven, and my array
of numbers is just two and four, the first
thing we notice is it is not possible to actually
generate the target sum of seven. Like they
said, the problem in this scenario, what you
want to do is return Nome sort of symbolize
that, hey, it's not possible to generate any
combination that leads to the target sum.
All right, I think it's important that we
think about one more scenario. So let's say
that I was given a target sum of zero. And
we were given really any array of numbers.
In this case, I just gave us one, two, and
three, we already know that in our previous
problem, we had to return a Boolean result,
we use the target sum of zero as a base case.
And so what I want to think about now is how
is the target sum of zero just trivially solved?
Well, if I want to know the combination that
sums to zero, and that's really just the empty
combination, right. So I think the logical
result here is to return an empty array, when
your target sum is zero. Remember that an
array represents a combination. And if I have
an empty array, that means I take no elements
into my combination, right? If I summed up
all the elements in that empty array, it would
indeed have a sum of zero. So that's going
to be a really important facet that we need
to encode into our logical tree that we draw
next, as well as our code, right. So let's
take a look at how we can structure the tree
and try to take a step toward really understanding
how we can implement it in some code. So let's
say we're stepping through this particular
example of target sum of seven, as well as
an array of 534, and seven. So the full tree
and really the same tree that we drew last
time would look something like this. from
the get go, I see that I have some scenarios
or some nodes where I reach zero, which means
that it's definitely possible to generate
the target sum. That being said, How can I
get back a valid result, right, so I need
to return an array. So you sort of reframe
this problem in that, all right, all of these
base cases that have a target sum of zero,
they are trivially solved because they are
combination would just be the empty array.
Right. So for now, I'll just kind of trace
through how one of these base cases would
return. So I know that this particular zero
is going to return an empty array. And like
we always say, when it returns, it's really
returning that information to its parent,
right. So this array sort of bubbles up to
its parent. And now what I want to do is actually
manipulate this return value, I want to add
something to it. So I want to really put the
number that brought me to that zero in the
first place. And that would really be the
choice of four. So notice along the edge,
I have them labeled with a minus four, meaning
that, hey, I took a choice of four. And I
want to actually add that choice into the
current array. So I'll just really push it
into the right, of course, I actually don't
need a negative sign that was just for the
sake of understanding the math here. But now
that my call to how some of four is returning
an array of four, that array bubbles up to
its parent. And of course, now I need to push
that edge that I took, which would be that
three, so that three gets pushed to the rear
as well. And if I look at what I'm seeing
right now, it looks like above the seven,
we have an array of four, three, which makes
sense, because you can totally generate a
target sum of seven by doing four plus three,
awesome. So four comma three would be a valid
answer in this particular problem. But like
they said, you could return really any valid
combination if one exists. So let's say we
retrace through this far right base case,
we know that this zero is going to return
an empty array, that empty array will be returned
to the parent. But we also have to add the
value according to the edge, right? So I would
press seven in this array. And that makes
sense because I could generate the target
sum of seven by just summing up a loan seven.
So that's still good to go. So I'm feeling
pretty good about how we can return a valid
combination if one exists about let's say,
there are some options that we take that don't
work out. So for example, let's say we explored
this node first, right? This was the first
base case we had and logically in the space
of our code, it really would be right. So
I know that this node can't really branch
out any further. So it's sort of a dead end.
This is a node that should work Turn no meaning
that, hey, there is no way I can generate
a target sum of two using elements in the
array. Or if you look at the elements of the
array, they're all too big, right? So I know
that this base case is going to return null.
But along with that, if you look at the next
base case, we would hit it would be this one,
which also returns Now, if you look at the
next base case, to the right, that's actually
an affirmative one that should return an empty
array. So it's kind of reasoned out how these
return values should be considered at their
parents. So I know that both of these values,
but to the left of the node four would return,
right, so it kind of bubbles up a little bit.
But for the array on the right hand side,
I would also have to push the edge that I
took, which was a four in this scenario. So
now I'm sort of comparing you know, the nollan,
this four, or really, I'm comparing all of
the branches that I take from a node. And
if at least one of the branches gives me back
an array that I know that it's possible, right?
So basically, in this scenario, the array
of four actually wins out over the null, right,
I know it's possible to generate a four. And
I'll just continue this process, right, now
I can return these two values to its parent.
So let's I'm considering them at seven. In
the same way, I would have to add the edge
I took, which would be a three on this array.
And then from there, I know the array would
always override the null, right? So I could
just ultimately return this four comma three.
And a really nice pattern in this code is,
as soon as we find a winning path through
the tree, or that is we find a combination
that creates a target sum, we can actually
return early because we don't need to really
travel through the rest of this tree. We don't
need to explore any other options because
they're happy with at least one combination.
Right? Awesome. So again, to recap, the punchline
is for this tree, I have the information for
a combination, encoded as a path through edges
of this tree, right, so I've looked at this
path I have highlighted in yellow, I see that
I took a three followed by four. And that
eventually led to a zero. So I know that one
valid combination would be four comma three.
All right, at this point, I'm feeling pretty
good. Let's go ahead and work on the code
for this now. All right, here we are back
in my code editor, let's work on solving the
house implementation. So the codes going to
be pretty similar to the cancer problem, it's
the really the whole point, we're just kind
of going to finesse the return date over here,
we're gonna have a very similar base case,
like we said, in the tree diagram, whenever
we have a target sum, that's zero, we have
trivially solved the problem, because I could
just return an empty array. And a similar
way, what we can do is also have a separate
base case, if our target sum ever reaches
a negative quantity, then I'll just return
null. That's because it's never possible to
generate a negative target sum, right? Remember,
in this problem, the array of numbers is only
going to be positive ones. Cool. We ended
up writing very similar base cases for our
last problem, except now instead of returning
true, we return an empty array. And instead
of returning false, we return nil. Nice. So
let's go ahead and get the branching logic.
Right, how do I want to make my recursive
calls, I'm going to need to make a recursive
call for every element of the numbers array.
So I'll say, let num of numbers, we'll just
iterate through every number of this array.
And I'll go ahead and do the same logic as
last time. So I'll subtract the number from
my target sum, they'll give me my remainder,
right? So remainder equals target sum minus
mine number. Cool. So this remainder is now
what I want to find the combination for, right?
So here, I would make my recursive call. So
how some pass in the remainder. And the second
argument will stay exactly the same. I'm going
to pass along the same exact numbers array.
I don't need to remove anything from the numbers,
right? Because they tell us in the problem
that we can reuse the elements
however we see fit, right. Cool. So now I
need to really think about what type how some
returns. So this problem is interesting, because
we basically have two different types, right,
we could get back in array of some elements,
if it is possible to generate the remainder,
or we can get back know, when it's not possible
to generate the remainder. I think no matter
what I get back, I'm just going to save into
a variable. So I'll say console, this is the
result for the remainder. I'll call it remainder
result. Cool. So I know that in the context
of like how I thought about this logic in
terms of the tree, I wanted to basically do
an early return if I found a valid combination.
And so I'll go ahead and check you know, if
the remainder result is not No. So the implication
if I enter this if statement, that means that
it is possible to generate the remainder.
And so what I can do is just return early
and I can return of basically almost the same
remainder is also the same array. However,
I need to make sure I include the element
that I took recall from the diagram, whenever
we had a recursive call that returned in array,
the parent had to also add the number that
it took transition to that recursive call
in the first place, right. So in the context
of the tree, I had to put the labels of the
edges into the array here. means I have to
put the num into this array. So some syntax
I can use for that. So use some spread operator.
So I can copy all the elements of the remainder
result into this new array. But I'll also
add on the number I just took, right. So all
I'm doing in this return line is, I'm returning
basically the same array that I get back from
my recursive call, with the number added to
the end of it. Let's say you're unfamiliar
with this syntax, I can preview it really
quick. It's pretty neat. Let's hop into the,
you know, repple. So let's say I had some
array, let's say it was this array of just
a, b, c, sort of an isolated example, you
can use the spread operator, which is the
three dots here to like unpack an array. And
you can sort of say like, new array equals
bracket. So this gives me a new literal array,
I can spread out the elements of the old R,
right? So if I do that, the new array just
has all of those same elements, vi, capitalize
that and properly, cool, we can extend that
syntax, right. So I still have that array
of ABC. Let's say I had another variable,
we'll call it other array, what I can do is
create a new literal array, copy all the elements
from our using the spread operator. And then
I can comma, separate any additional things
I want to add while I'm here. So let's say
I added a z. So if I look at my other array,
now, it contains ABC, and also this new element
z. So it's all I'm doing on this slide, right?
I'm returning the same combination, that my
recursive call gives back with the number
that I took are added to the end of it. Cool.
So what's really nice about this code is it's
very reminiscent to our previous code, because
we have an early return. So if I find at least
one way, to generate the target sum, I can
just go ahead and return that first way that
I found, right, they say we can return any
valid combination here. But let's say this
for loop finished, and we never found a valid
way to generate the target sum, then after
the for loop, you can just return null, because
it's not possible not to generate the target
sum, apparently. Cool. So this code is looking
pretty good. I think let's let's give it a
shot. It goes without saying no, sometimes
the remainder right will become negative.
But we already handled that with this nice
base case, right. So let's test this code.
So I already have some example outputs over
here. So looks like our first few examples
are working. Obviously, our last one seems
to take quite a long time. So I'll just kill
this program early. But before we talk about
how to optimize for this larger example over
here, if you look at these other examples,
what I can see is this array of 322 does add
to seven. So that's looking good. This array
of four, three, also adds to seven. So that's
good. We already saw that this example of
seven and two for now, that's your return
No, because it's not possible generate that
sum. And it looks like the array for the eight
example is also good to go. So notice here,
there are also some other arrays that we could
have returned and would still be considered
valid output, the exact combinations that
we get back are really just dictated by the
order that we happen to iterate in the array.
So for example, let's say I switch things
around here, like I did 352, it's really the
same array, just in a different order, we'll
probably get a different answer for that particular
one, right? So I'll run this now, notice I
get 233. But either case, that still sums
to eight, so we're
totally good to go. Awesome. They bring this
back to the original code. And yeah, it seems
that now the limiting factor seems to be the
speed of our solution, right? We've been here
before. And so let's go ahead and talk about
the complexity of it. So we know that the
time complexity for this is almost identical
to what we did in the cancer problem, which
is conveniently over here. But sort of refresh.
By now you recognize that all right, the time
complexity should be described in terms of
like the recursive tree, let's let's lay down
the foundation. And we already know that M,
we're going to call the target sum. And let's
also say that n is the numbers dot length.
Cool. And so if I think about the number of
recursive calls that I'm going to make, it's
really the same as last time, right? So I'm
going to say that, hey, the time of this function
seems to be Oh, and I have an exponential,
the base of the exponent is the branching
factor, which is the length of the array.
And then the depth of the tree would be the
exponent, which is just m, right. So this
was the same time complexity as last time
for a brute force writes M to the M power.
However, it looks like we have some additional
time that we consume in this function really
coming from this expression, right. So if
I look at line nine, in particular, this line
creates a copy of an array. So that will actually
take sort of a linear number of steps to copy
over every element of an array right. So I
will have to consider the cost of this operation.
It sort of under the hood like iterates through
the remaining result, I know that the maximal
length of the remainder result I can get back
will be at most m, right? Remember that remainder
result in the worst case is going to be in
array, the longest that array could be is
exactly the target sum, right? Imagine that
we had the most simple, you know, sort of
a combination to generate the target sum.
If it was just a bunch of ones, right, my
target sum was 50. And I had an array filled
with one, then I can just do one plus one
plus one plus 150 times to generate the target
sum. So in the worst case, this copying operation
will take m steps, I need to do that for every
recursive call. And so if I have this many
number of recursive calls, in addition to
that, I do an M operation, you just multiply
that M, right. So the time complexity for
this brute force so far, is n to the n power
times M. Really, the thing we want to optimize
away is this exponential part, right? So I
really want to focus in on that. But while
we're here, let's go ahead and talk about
the space of this brute force. So the space,
there are things to consider the terms of
the stack space, it's going to be the same
as last time, so it's going to be o of m.
But think about any other space I use up I
guess you should also consider the array that
you return back, whoever we know that we're
going to return back like the first array
that we find all the way back up to the top
level call. And the combined length of all
of those arrays that we return is really just
going to be in worst case, M. Right. So I
would still say that the space complexity
for this function is just m right now. Cool.
Obviously, let's work on optimizing this time
complexity. So this was the brute force. So
brute force. And you guessed it, and there
is definitely some people get some problems
in this brute force. So we'll just memorize
it away. So very formulaic stuff, most of
the work is always the brute force. So I'll
start with my empty mental object. And like
we always say, we'll use the target sum as
our key. So if I've seen the target sum before,
that is if it's in the memo, then I'll return
what I have stored in the Mo. And at this
point, what I want to do is make sure I pass
along the same memo object to all of the recursive
calls. That way, they can benefit from any
information or any sub problems that I worked
on over here, right in this stack frame. Cool.
At this point, I need to make sure that I
take all of the return lines that I had before,
and I store them in the memo, right? So the
trick here is I can say, memo of target. So
I'm going to save that array. So notice that
now the values in the array, or sorry, the
values in the memo object are going to be
arrays, because that's the return value of
this. It's either going to be an array or
not right? So I'm just going to complete this
return value by returning what I just put
in the memo.
And in a similar way, I also want to memorize
this late return. So we'll also be memo of
target sum equals No, I can just still return
No. Cool. So with that change, right, it's
very, very straightforward change. Let's see
how this does. Now. I know that for this last
example of how some 300, it is not possible
to generate the sum of 300 using just sevens
and fourteens. So should we get an all for
that one. So let's give that a shot. Nice.
And there, we have a really quick running
a know of that very last example. So we definitely
had an effect on the runtime here. Let's talk
about how we changed up the complexity of
this code. So that was a brute force. Let's
talk about the memoized version. So it's good
with the time over here. So we know that in
terms of the time complexity from the number
of recursive calls that we make, it's the
same story as our last problem, right? We
just have to consider any other time operations,
which would still be this array copying. So
but in just terms of the recursive calls that
we make, it's going to be n times m, recursive
calls. And then in each recursive call, I
need to do this copying pattern, right copying
over the contents of an array, and the array
will be at most m elements long. Alright,
so if I have this many recursive calls, and
each recursive call needs to make an M length
operation, now I just multiplied by another
m term. So right now this looks like n times
m times m, which is the same as n times m
squared. And I'll talk about the space complexity.
So the space complexity will be at least as
big as our brute force, so it's going to be
at least o of M, above, now we have to consider
all the space we use up in the memo object.
So I think about the keys of this memo object,
the keys are just going to be all unique values
of target sum, right? Because I just literally
use target sum as a key on all these lines,
right? But then everything about the value
or the values are going to be Pretty chunky
now, because sometimes of value but in the
object is going to be an array. And I already
said that the maximal length of any of these
arrays that I returned is going to be of length
M. Right. So to me, it's now the case that
your space complexity comes from mostly your
mental object, which is going to be of size,
m times m, right, because you have m keys.
And each key has a value, which is, at worst
going to be an array of M elements. So it's
m times m, which is m squared. Cool. Notice
that we definitely cut down on the brute force
implementation, especially in terms of the
time complexity, obviously, there was a little
trade off that we made here. But now we're
able to run our house and function in a reasonable
amount of time. So to wrap up this problem,
let's go ahead and hop back into the drawing
board. Alright, now that we coded the house
and prom, let's wrap it up by actually analyzing
the complexity of it. So recall that for our
house, some problem, we have multiple arguments,
right, so I need to describe them. So I'll
say that m is my target sum, and n is the
length of the array. Remember that the array
contains the choices we can take. And our
baseline solution, that is our brute force
recursion had an exponential time complexity,
right? It was kind of in the form of n to
the n power times M. And after we actually
optimize it using the memorization strategy,
we actually reduced it from exponential down
to a polynomial time complexity. In particular,
our new time complexity was n times m squared.
So really important fact about our memoized
have complexities, it is no longer exponential.
Please recall that when we have m squared,
that is not exponential, because the exponent
is a constant number. Cool. If I look at the
the space complexity for this, I had to actually
pay a little more cost in terms of the space
because of the memoized object. But that space
complexity we use up is still not exponential,
right? Still a polynomial or quadratic complexity.
So I'm still satisfied with it overall. So
we definitely prefer this memo is complexity
over the brute force. All right, that was
the how some problem but now let's go over
one more variation of it.
In this problem, I'll still give you a target
sum as well as an array of numbers to choose
from. But this time, what you want to do is
return an array containing the shortest combination
of numbers, that adds up to the target sum.
And along with that, if there's any ties for
the shortest combination, you can return any
of those shortest ones. So from this description,
you probably recognize that this is similar
to our last few problems. But now they're
asking for a little bit of an optimization,
right? So I want the shortest sums, that means
an array containing the least amount of numbers,
but it still adds up to the target sum. So
we're really just going to add on top of our
previous understanding, let's take a look
at a few examples. So let's say I gave you
this example. So here, my target is seven,
and the numbers I choose from are 534, and
seven. So there are a few different ways you
can generate your target of seven, one way
would be to do three plus four, that's one
combination. But another way would be just
take the seven because notice that seven is
actually a member of the array. And here I
want to choose the smallest array, which would
be just the lone seven. So that would be the
expected result for this one. In a similar
way, let's see, I gave you a target sum of
eight. And your choice of numbers were two,
three and five, there are plenty of ways to
generate eight, you can do two plus two plus
two plus two, or you can do two plus three
plus three, or you can just do it three plus
five. And here, I want to return always the
shortest combination, which would be the three
plus five. So that would be the result over
here. Cool. So we definitely have some awareness
that Alright, this problem is similar in structure
to our previous one where I need to sort of
generate a way to make the target sum. But
now I want to really specify the shortest
array, right? So let's try to visualize this
as a tree. Like always, let's say we're stepping
through this example, with the target sum
of eight. So we know that the full tree would
look like this. And we've seen this tree before.
But now what we're trying to do is come up
with a different process for the value your
return, right, it's no longer going to be
valid to just return the first way that I
find to generate the target sum. Now I want
the best way. So let's start coming up with
the strategy for this. At this point, we know
that we can definitely implement some logic
in our code where we return an array up our
recursive calls, we did that in the last problem.
So here, we'll sort of use some abstraction
to assume some return values. So let's say
that I'm bringing this problem down, my top
level problem asked me what's the best way
to generate eight. But I see that along that
path, I have to find the sub solution for
the best way to generate six. So let's say
we're rooted at this subtree. And we know
that there are a few ways we can make six,
right? If I look at this subtree rooted at
six, there are two zero base cases downward,
right? So if I look at the first one, I get
this path, I know that my sub tree over here
will be able to know that all right, one way
to generate six would be two plus two plus
two, right? We kind of implemented that logic
in the last problem. But now what I also want
to do is consider any other paths in case
they end up being shorter. Obviously, I know
That this path of three 300 return upward.
And now I have to kind of make the decision,
you know, between these two options for generating
six, I should just prefer the shorter one.
So that means it's sort of two to two versus
three, three. And obviously, the three, three
wins because the array length is shorter.
And if I pause right here, and I looked at
what the diagram is saying, it does make sense
that above the six, we have three comma three,
because that is the shortest way we can ever
make a six, right, just three plus three.
But now I can return this sub array to my
parent. But if I do that, I should also include
the value of the edge along that path, right?
So I also included the two over here. Now
this makes sense, because one way I can generate
eight is three plus three plus two, right?
But we know that's not the optimal way. Let's
say we step through this a little further,
let's say we took the same sort of process
for this other child of five. So I know that
to generate five, there are three options
according to the subject, right? Because I
see three different leaves that are have zero
inside of them. And so I know that for these
paths, they would work out through their own
sub arrays. And here, I really just want to
choose the shortest one, right? So obviously,
the lone five wins out over here. So that'd
be returned all the way up to that five node.
But then that five node will return it to
its parent, then, of course, I need to include
the edge that connects the eight to the five,
right? How did I transition to that five in
the first place, so I go ahead and just add
it in. And now the root node over here has
a decision to make, which one does it prefer
between 332 or five, three, it'll just choose
a shorter one. So the five three should win
out over here. And I just need to continue
this process for any other branches in my
tree, right? I can't return early and this
type of problem because I need to find the
optimal way. And I can't be sure until I've
tried every possibility.
Cool. So
it looks like our overall logic is we want
to explore and find any ways to generate our
target sum. But then when we find a way that's
shorter than our currently tracked way, we
can just replace it, I'll continue that process
through the entire tree. If I checked every
possibility and keep replacing what I consider
the shortest. By the end of us exploring every
branch, we would have the absolute shortest.
Alright, I think we're ready to hop into the
code. Alright, programmers, welcome back to
my text editor. Let's work on coding this
one out. So here I have some initial examples
that we'll use to test our best sum function.
I noticed for this last one, right, I get
my initial target sum of 100. And the best
way to do that is obviously just take a bunch
of 20 fives, right for 20 fives. What else
I want to bring our attention to is this third
example over here. So my target sum is eight.
And my choice of numbers are one, four, and
five. The optimal answer here is four and
four, right? That is the shortest way to generate
at a common mistake I see a lot of students
make is sort of assume that the best way to
generate a target sum always involves taking
the largest choice of number as many times
as we can, right? That is not true. If you
took a five in your your sum, then you would
have to take three ones in the long run, which
is not going to work out to the shortest answer,
right. So it's not the case that just taking
the biggest choice of number always yields
the target sum in the shortest amount of numbers
overall. So don't fall into that trap. Which
means that we have to do the full tree exploration,
right, we have to do that in exhaustive sort
of search using our recursive code. So let's
start with that base case, like we always
do. So bring this a few times, but still right
here. So if the target sum is zero, then I
have trivially solved the problem. So I can
just return an empty array, right? That is
the exact single combination and the shortest
combination that can generate the target some
cool along with that, let's handle that scenario,
if our target sum goes too far downwards,
if it's less than zero, so if the target sum
is less than zero, I'll just return null,
meaning that it's not possible to generate
that target sum. And now we'll use our branching
logic. So I'm going to iterate through all
choice of numbers will say for let num in
numbers. And like we always do, I'll go ahead
and create my remainder, which I know would
be the difference between my target sum, and
that choice of number. Right? So what I'm
doing is I'm choosing the number that decreases
my target sum. At this point, I would make
my recursive call right with that remainder,
passing in the same numbers array. But now
I have to do some thinking, I know that all
right, best sum is either going to return
to me a combination or an array, or it's going
to return null, so I'm gonna have to kind
of differentiate between the two. So over
here, maybe I'll just save this as a result.
I'll call this my remainder. Let's say combination.
And if this remainder combination is not null,
then it can do some other logic, right? So
I'll say if the remainder combination is not
equal to No, then do stuff. So if I enter
this if statement, then that means it is possible
to generate the remainder. And exactly what
remainder combination is, is an array containing
the short This way, I can generate the remainder.
Cool. So if I enter this if statement, then
I also have a way to generate the full targets,
right, I can just take the remainder combination,
copy the elements over from it like we did
last time. And also add on the choice of number
I just took, right. So this would be now a
complete combination for target sum. So I'll
just say that as a regular combination. Cool.
So so far, this is very reminiscent to our
last one. And we need to work in some more
logic relevant for this problem, that is a
very, very important characteristic that we
needed to implement in the tree was, I need
to sort of choose the shortest combination,
RAMs, I'm going to need to work in that logic.
So here's what we can do, I know that I need
to compare basically, all of my branches together,
all of my recursive calls together, and pick
out the shortest combination. So I know that
this for loop is a piece of code that sort
of iterates and attempts, all of my branches.
And so outside of the for loop, I'm going
to need some outer variable, I'll call it
my shortest combination. And over time, I'll
just keep updating this variable if I find
a combination shorter than my current shortest
combination, right? So I'm gonna initialize
this to null.
And the reason is, imagine that we set up
this shortest combination of variables, no.
And then we iterate through the for loop.
And there isn't even any way to generate the
target sum. So this for a loop finishes, and
shortest combination would still be no. And
that'd be great to return, right? Because
in this problem, they said, if it's still
not possible to generate the target sum at
all, you should still return null. So this
is a good initial default value for shortest
combination. But now I need to do my update
logic. So here on line 11, I've actually created
a combination, that gives me the target sum.
But now I need to check, right, so I'll say,
if the combination is shorter, then the current
shortest that I need to update it. So let's
translate that into some code. Just use an
if statement. And I'll start by checking if
the combination I currently have, which is
an array, right? I check if that is less than
in length, then the shortest combination variable.
And really, it looks like shores combination,
it starts as null. So I need to fix this code
a little bit. But if I update it with a valid
combination, then it's going to be an array,
right? So I'm really checking the length of
the arrays here.
So
what I want to do is assign my shortest combination
with the combination that is now shorter,
good. So this means the shorter combination
wins out and gets to stay, right. If I look
at this code, it needs a little bit of work,
because the first time I find some combination,
I know that I be comparing that array length
to no dot length, right? Because shortest
combination starts as null. And I can't do
null dot length in JavaScript. So I'll need
like a nice or clause here. So I'll say, if
it is the case that your shortest combination
is equal to No, then you can go ahead and
replace it. Cool. So this sort of check over
here is going to make sure that I automatically
replace this null value with the first valid
combination. Even if right now it may not
be the shortest, right later on, I'll compare
that combination I have stored to some possibly
shorter combinations. Cool. So this code is
looking pretty good. Let's go ahead and give
it a little test run. Nice. Notice that and
on occasions where we call besam, with a remainder
that is negative because remember, sometimes
we subtract a number that is maybe too large,
that's okay. Because that will actually bottom
out at a base case and return null, which
we sort of check for explicitly in this if
statement. Cool. So let's give us code a run
node best some. So I get an error over here
looks like I get maximum call stack size exceeded,
which means that we didn't really hit our
base case. So there's some work to be done
here. So let's take a look at this code. So
if I take a look at this code, it's a very,
very small typo. It's kind of unfortunate
that it breaks the entire code. But really,
I messed up when I iterated in the for loop
over here. So here I wrote for letting them
in numbers, that would actually give me the
indices of the array. So they'd be like 0123.
Whereas I want the elements of the array,
right? So instead of in any of over here,
so that's on me. So with that small change.
Let's give it a run now. Yeah, it looks like
we're passing these first three examples,
we have 735, and four, four, notice that the
order among the elements in the combination
doesn't really matter too much. But looks
like we're definitely a little too slow on
this last example, over here, right? So obviously,
we know the move is to memorize this because
we have the brute force recursion. But before
we do that, let's just talk about the complexity
of This. So this code is going to be very
similar in complexity to our last how sum
function, sort of compare the two, it's almost
the same code, right? But do these side by
side, right, these two functions look very,
very similar. So we know in the long run,
we probably have the same or close to the
same complexity. Let's be methodical. So we
know that over here, we always like to say
that M is the target sum. And we'll also go
ahead and say that n is the numbers dot length.
So we just did the brute force. And our brute
force shouldn't be the same story as last
time. So talk about the time. So the time
of the brute force is going to be some sort
of exponential, right? If you remember that
tree drawing, in general, the exponential
number of nodes in a tree will be the branching
factor to the height power. So not the branching
factor here is n, right? I branch for every
choice of number, and then the height of the
tree would just be the target sum. So that's
n to the M.
But along with that, we also have some additional
operations, right? If I look at this for loop,
so this for loop gives me the branching factor,
right. But then I also do this operation on
line 11, which is copying over the array of
remainder combination. And that array in the
worst case will be of length m, right? The
largest sort of combination, give me back
is a combination that is just filled with
a bunch of ones, right? If my target sum was
50, the longest combination possible would
be a bunch of ones, so 50 ones in an array.
So what I'll do is, I'll say that for each
of these n to the M power calls, you also
have to do a linear operation in M, right?
So like before, it's n to the m times m. Cool.
And then the space complexity is sort of interesting
in this one, because we're maintaining some
values. So look at this. So I talked about
the space complexity, just from the stack
space, it would just be the heights of like
the recursion. In other words, it would be
m over here, right? So I know it's going to
be at least M. So I'll jot that down. But
then we have also like this variable on line
five, right? So I know that over time, I'm
going to be storing an array inside of this
variable. And this array is going to be in
the worst case, m in length, right? So what
I'm saying is, every recursive call would
have to have its own shortest combination
variable, right? If the shortest combination
variable is going to be an array of length
m, that means I have an array of length m,
for every recursive call right? Before I bought
them out, at like my final base case. And
so also, the space complexity here is m times
m, which we know is the same thing as m squared,
right? And sort of the reasoning is, your
maximal stack depth is still m like last time,
however, now you need to have those stack
frames, you need to store in array, right
as you recurse. Nice. So really, the limiting
factor for us right now is going to be the
time complexity, which is exponential. And
so like we always say, let's go ahead and
memorize this. So memorization pretty trivial
right now, right? You've done it many times.
So I'll just begun my initially empty memo
object. And I'll check, you know, if my target
sum is in the memo, then I should actually
return the stored value. So return memo at
Target sum. So now that I have my memo checking
logic, what I also want to do is add the memo
storing logic, right. So I need to just go
to my return value and store it in the memo
before I return it. Notice that the return
value right now, it's no longer inside of
the for loop, right in the last problem, it
was in the for loop, because I can return
early. But this time, we're going to return
at the very end, so I'll replace it over here.
So I'll say, for here, the memo at Target
sum should be stored with the shortest combination,
I can still return the shortest combination.
And before I forget, let me go ahead and pass
down the same memo object by reference. Alright,
nothing too much to that. Let's go ahead and
try this last example. Now. Give it a shot.
Awesome. And there we have it. We have 425
in this last example. And that is the best
way to generate a 100 is pretty evident that
we cut down on the runtime. So let's talk
about the memoized complexity embolized. And
so the time is obviously much faster should
not be exponential. But if I take a lay of
the land, I know that now that every target
sum is going to be a key of the memo object.
And target some is really just a number, right?
So if my target time is 50, then I basically
have 50 different keys I can never store in
the memo object. So if I have m different
keys in my memo object, I know that I won't
be exploring any full duplicate sub trees
for each of those keys. However, I will slap
the branch for every number in the array,
right? So overall, I'm looking at an m times
n. So so far, I have m times n, but I have
some additional work from this array, right?
So notice that the n over here that comes
from this for loop, I'm iterating through
numbers, but then the additional M comes from
copying over this array, which would be linear.
So it would be m times n times M. And I can
just kind of squish these two M's together.
So it kind of boils down to m squared, times
n, which is really the same thing as last
time. And our space complexity would also
be the same as it was last time, which was
just m squared, mostly coming from the memo,
right? And the logic is, your memo keys have
m possibilities. But for each of those keys,
their value can be an array of length m, right?
So just m times m, or m squared. Awesome.
So looking at this code, you probably, you
know, feeling that Oh, my gosh, like this
best some problem is pretty complex. And I
think it you know, to be honest, it is, however,
what I really want us to focus in on is this,
like progression we took, right, I think that
everyone could tackle this best some problem,
if they warmed up and really understood simpler
problems like can some and how some
write the code is very, very similar. So to
wrap things up, I will let's do some closing
words on the drawing board. So in its best
some problem, right, we had two inputs, we
had m as our targets, and also say that n
is the length of the array. So the brute force
that we initially implemented it with just
some recursion was exponential in time. And
after we optimized it, we brought it down
to just a polynomial time complexity. And
notice that between our brute force and our
memulai solution, they actually have the same
space complexity. So we definitely prefer
this memoized version. So hope you enjoy this
series of problems. That is we worked on the
can some how some and best some problems,
they all had the common frame of us having
some target some that we need to generate
with some options given in an array. And in
particular, if you look at the can some problem
it asks us what that task of generating target
some Can you do it? So yes or no? The house
and problem. So is how will you do it? So
what are the exact combination of elements
that you'll use? And finally, the best son
was the hardest version? And it asked, What
is the best way to do it in terms of the least
number of elements of the array? So there
definitely is a logical progression to these
problems. And in particular, they kind of
capture a different variation of a dynamic
programming problem for our can some problem,
right, we had to return Boolean there. That's
a type of decision problem, right? Yes or
no? Can you accomplish this task? Is it possible?
Along with that the house some problem was
a combinatoric problem, right? We want to
know the exact combination that works out.
And the best some problem was a variation
of an optimization problem, right? I want
the shortest way to generate the target. So
we saw that these three problem types definitely
have some common ground, but they also have
some nuance, depending on exactly the question
we're trying to answer. These all fall under
the umbrella of dynamic programming. That
being said, dynamic programming problems aren't
just limited to number inputs. All right,
I think it's time to work on another prompt,
let's say I gave you this, what I want to
do is write a function called can construct
that takes in some target string, as well
as an array of words in a word bank. My goal
is to return a Boolean indicating whether
or not I can make the target by concatenate
together elements of the word bank. And along
with that, we can reuse as many elements as
the word bank as we see fit. Alright, notice
that in this problem, we're looking for a
Boolean response to start, right. So just
yes or no. Is it possible to generate the
target? So let's take a look at an example
here. Let's say I gave you this. So my target
is abcdef. And I have a nice long array of
some words. And so I'm basically asking, Can
you construct abcdef, using elements of the
array. So if I kind of take a look at the
array, there is exactly just one way to generate
the target string, which are just B, A, B,
C plus D, F. So the answer here is true, because
there is at least one way to make the target,
right. Let's take a look at the opposite example.
So let's say I had this word of skateboard.
And I gave you all of these words in an array.
So take a moment to kind of look this one
over. And you tell me write Is it possible
to generate skateboard here?
And the answer here is no. Right? It is not
possible to generate skateboard using this
array of words. So we should return false,
we can get pretty close to making skateboard.
But we can never build the full string. Alright,
so here are a few ways that we can attempt
but they don't work out in the long run, right?
This is one series we can take, but we kind
of get stuck, as well as this. And also this
way, right? Point being there are zero ways
we can ever generate skateboard. So we should
return false over here. Awesome. So I think
let's look at one more example. We should
already have the vibe that in general, it's
easier to create a shorter string than a longer
string, right? To create a longer string,
you're probably going to need to use more
elements. So if I have that kind of framing
in mind, that I know that possibly the easiest
string to create would be the empty string,
right? So let's say your target was the empty
string and I gave you you know, some kind
of random array of words, really, the array
of words doesn't really matter here. I think
no matter what they should return true. Because
to generate the empty string, you can just
take no zero elements. From the array, and
that kind of line of thinking is going to
help us really start to solve this problem.
So we'll kind of take this example, in stride,
what we want to do is return true if our target
is empty, and that takes place no matter what
array of words we're given, right? Cool, more
or less, that kind of sounds like a base case,
right? But let's go ahead and start to kind
of define some process we can take to explore
all of the options, right? So I want to really
visualize this in a well ordered way. And
that really means a tree. Right? So let's
say we're going to trace through this example
visually. So my target is abcdef. We already
said that, in the long run, we should return
or conclude a true about this input, right?
So we'll just start with the input argument
that is the target string as the root of this
tree. And this is sort of a scenario where
like, Alright, I have two inputs, how do I
know which one to really encode in my drawing?
Well, it's about what will actually change.
I know from like, one instance of like this
problem to the next, the array of words, I
can actually reuse as many times as I need.
So it's not like I'm taking out elements from
the array. So with that in mind, I think it's
better or more reasonable to encode the actual
target string into the nodes of this picture.
Because I'm gonna start with this original
target string of my route. Now I have to think
about how I transition to the children of
this right, so what moves do I take that hopefully
shrink the target string, right, I know I
need to shrink the target string, because
I already have the base case of the empty
string in mind. So I need to get closer and
closer to a length of zero. We'll talk about
one transition we can make. So I know that
I need to sort of use the array of words as
I transition. And so let's say I took a B
as a choice right now, if I take a B, then
I guess I could remove, you know, that sequence
of characters from my parent node. So if I
take a B out of abcdef, then the resulting
child is just C, D, F. Cool. So notice that
as we transition from one node to the next,
looks like we're taking out that substring.
In a similar way, I have another substring,
that I can take out for my word bank, and
that would be ABC, and that would yield in
the child d f. And then I can do this for
some other string inside of the word bank.
And the really important thing to know is,
there's a correct logic to doing this. And
it's also a common trap I see a lot of students
fall into when it comes to this logic. So
right now I'll talk about like the common
mistake. So it would be ill advised to sort
of take out the CD from our root node, if
you took out C, D, then the resulting note
would be a, b, f. And so what we're doing
right now is if we took out C, D, you're taking
out something in the middle. And if you take
out something in the middle, that means that
your resulting string actually creates a new
adjacent sequence of characters. In other
words, I know that this is kind of suspicious,
because look at this little run of characters,
A, B, E, those are now like adjacent next
to each other. Whereas in the original string
of abcdef, A, B, he was not present, right.
So if I kind of take out strings in the middle,
then I'll have this sort of mistake of creating
new adjacencies. Right. And that would actually
impact the moves I take later on. So I don't
want to do that, right. So the move here is
to not take out any characters from the middle
of the string. So what would be the correct
way of doing it? Well, if you look at our
two nodes that we already branched into, a
common factor for them is the fact that we
actually took a prefix out of our original
root node, that is a B as a prefix, and so
is ABC or recall that a prefix is just a string,
that kind of begins some other larger string.
So if I want to transition to a third node
over here, there's only one more prefix I
can take. And that would just be ABCD. Right?
If I take that prefix out, then my resulting
child is just E, F. And so the overall logic
that we want to use when we build this tree
is to only branch to children if we have a
matching prefix in the word bank. And of course,
the child would be the resulting string after
we remove that prefix. So let's keep it rolling.
And we'll apply this logic again and again,
recursively. So let's say I'm rooted at this
CDF node, I'll look inside of the word bank
and notice any prefixes that actually match
here, I think there's only one and that would
just be CD. If I took out the prefix CD, then
my result is E, F. In a similar way, I can
do that for d f, I find that d f is actually
contained in the word bang. So it's technically
also a prefix. If I took the prefix def out
of that node, then my result would be empty,
which is pretty good. At this point, I look
at some other nodes like this EF and they
have no matching prefixes inside of the word
bank. So they sort of bought them out in some
sort of base case. In the long run. If I can
break down EF any further than I know that
it's not possible to construct EF so that
can technically return a false to the parent.
Mr way, if I ever run into the empty string,
that means the job is done. And I can just
return true, right? Something we said earlier
was, whenever we want to generate the empty
string, it is always possible no matter what.
And now this pattern should feel a little
familiar, right? All I have to do now is kind
of bubble up these Boolean values to the parent.
And overall, if one of my children return
true, then I myself will return true, right?
So I'll bubble this up a little bit, bubble
up all the way to the top. So our root note
chooses basically the true value among these
three values it gets from each of its branches.
And so the ultimate answer here is just true,
right. And it is possible to generate abcdef
using words of this array. So you're probably
having deja vu right now, right? We almost
use the same exact logic for the previous
some problem. However, all we did was adjust
how we transition from one note to the next,
really making a compatible for this string
data. But we're going to carry over a lot
of knowledge, right? It's really important
that we understand like the general like knowledge
of dynamic programming and recursive understanding,
we can apply that under any circumstances.
That being said, let's look at one more example.
What I want to do is see an example where
this should return false. So let's say I gave
you that skateboard example from before. In
the long run, this is going to return false.
If I tried to break down skateboard, I would
always try to transition using any matching
prefixes from the array. There are two prefixes
at the start that match, and that would be
SCA and SK, and those would give me t board
and eight board, respectively. And now at
this point, if I route myself at the keyboard
node, I can only take the T, resulting eboard.
In a similar way, if I am at the eight board
node, then I can only transition using the
eight. And I'm left over with board. At this
point, if I look at eboard, that node over
there actually hits a dead end, right, there's
nothing I can actually take out of Eve or
there's no matching prefix, because I basically
need something that starts with E, but no
words of the word bank start with E. So I
guess we have to focus our effort elsewhere.
Looking at this board, I can take either a
Bo or a Bo AR, and I'm left with art and D
respectively. And unfortunately, those two
nodes at the leaf level also bottom out, right,
I can't transition further and take out any
prefixes from those strings. So I know that
those will have to return false. And if all
of these leaf nodes return false, then my
ultimate note at the top that is a skateboard
node at the root, that's going to just return
a false as well. So it's pretty clear to me
that the overall logic we want is if we get
back a single true, then we can just return
true all the way up to the call stack. But
if everything is false, then we'll just go
ahead and return a false. With that, I think
we're ready to code this one out.
All right, let's
go ahead and code this one up. So here I have
some initial examples we can use to test our
code for correctness. Looking at the last
example, over here, it's a fairly long one.
And notice that the target incident F, whereas
no words of the word bank have an F in it.
So we know that that should result in a false.
So let's go ahead and lay down the base case
for this. Like we said, a reasonable base
case is to check if your target is empty,
right. If you have the empty string, then
you can already construct the empty string
by taking no words from the word bank. So
you can just return true over here. And now
I need to make my recursive call in a way
where my target string gets progressively
smaller and smaller toward this empty string.
And so I know that based on the tree I drew,
I need to make a choice based on the words
in the word bang. So I'm going to iterate
through all of the words. So I'll say for
let word of word bank. So I'm iterating through
every element of the word bank. And now that
I have the word element, as I think about
when it's okay, to make the recursive call
using that word, and we spoke about this,
we pointed out that we need to make sure that
the word is a prefix of the target. So I can
do that, I can just check if the target dot
index of word equals zero. So index elf will
just give me the index where I can find some
substring inside of a larger string. If the
index i get back is zero, that means that
the word starts at index zero of the target.
So if you're unfamiliar with this method in
JavaScript really quick, let's say I did potato
dot index of pot, that will tell me the index
where I can find it, which happens to be at
index zero. But if I looked for tayto, I would
get the index of the T, the first t rather
in potato. So this is a really nice way I
can use to check if some substring is a prefix
of another string, right, the index should
be zero within it. So a way interpret this
if statement is if I have a prefix, then I
can sort of use it to shrink the target. So
I'll create another variable here. I'll call
it like the suffix so that's like the string
after I remove the prefix. What I can do is
slice my target string. Except to target that
slice. And what I want to do is start picking
up characters. After the length of the words
I can say word dot length over here. So it's
kind of reasoned out what this logic is doing.
So we'll trace through this, let's say that
I don't know my word. So I'll open up the
note repple. Let's say my word was the string
pot. And we'll also say that my current target
is potato. So I know when I do target dot
index of word, that is going to get back zero.
So this if statement would be true. And then
what I do is target dot slice of word, dot
length. So we're dot length is just the length
of the prefix I took, right? So it would be
three over here, providing the target that
slice starting at index three, that would
give me everything after the prefix, right?
So I basically have removed pots, and got
eight. Oh, cool. So when you use slice, if
you pass in a single argument, that's going
to be the starting position of what you start
grabbing characters, and you'll go all the
way through the end. Cool. And that's the
logic I definitely want here. So back to the
code. Now that I have the suffix, I want to
make my recursive call on that suffix. So
basically asking, Hey, is it possible? Can
I construct the suffix now? And I'll pass
along the same choice of word bank. Nice.
So here's where I should think recursively.
So I'm focused in on what type of data do
I get back from can construct I know I get
back a Boolean, right? True or false, it tells
me whether or not the suffix can be made.
And I want to check, you know, if this call
returns true, maybe I'll be explicit here.
So if the recursive call is true, then I know
that the original target can also be made.
So what I'll do is return true early here.
Cool, I know that if the suffix could be made,
and the word that I use to generate the suffix
is also in the word bank, then the entire
target must also be able to be made. Nice
to hear I have my nice early return true.
Like you expect, where should I return false,
it should be after the for loop, right? Only
after I've tried every possible choice of
the word and none of them worked out, then
can I say, No, the target cannot be created.
So I want to do a late return false over here.
So this code is looking pretty sharp, I think
let's go ahead and test these examples. So
I should get true false true, and then false
for the last one, give this a go.
So I get true, false true. And it looks like
the last example over here is taking quite
some time to finish. So I think our code has
correctness. But it's not efficient enough
to you know, reasonably run this last example.
So I'm going to kill this program. If you
take a look at the example I pass it for this
last one, it does sort of describe the worst
case here. For one, we know that the answer
is going to be false. So you will have to
do a full exploration of the tree, meaning
you can't do any early return trues, right.
And because of like the length of the string,
and also the length of the word bank, I have
a very big tree, right? Notice that there's
going to be a lot of prefixes at work here,
right? every element of this array is actually
a prefix that could be found over here. And
that happens again and again. So I'll tell
you what, let's go ahead to the drawing board.
And we'll try to visualize what the exact
complexity of this function is.
Alright, so we implemented looks like the
brute force for this solution. Let's talk
about how we might want to optimize it, I
think any conversation of optimization should
begin with actually understanding what the
current complexity is. So let's say I gave
us this kind of large example to sort of visualize
with, so my target string is enter a potent
pot, and I gave you a pretty diverse array
of words in the word bank. So I'll just go
ahead and kind of give us though the full
tree in what it would look like, would be
this pretty long tree, right, so I follow
the same logic that we did in our earlier
examples. notice a few things. There are some
occasions where I transition using a single
character prefix, which is totally fine. And
that kind of tends to feel like the worst
case scenario, right? If you take single characters
out of your target string over time, then
you're going to have a very, very tall tree
height, or you're gonna have to take many,
many steps. So that kind of reminds us of
a worst case scenario, like we saw when we
ran the code. But that being said, we want
to generalize this understanding right for
basically some generic size of our input.
So let's say we kind of just looked at this
tree in terms of its overall shape, and then
we'll kind of generalize it. So to me, this
tree has this sort of basic structure. And
let me start by defining the terms I'll use
to describe the complexity right. So I'll
say that M is the target string length, and
n is the number of words in the word bang.
Right, so I'm really trying to use a different
variable for each of my inputs, because I
have the vibe that both of them contribute
to my complexity, possibly in different ways.
So you've seen, you know, us analyze trees
before in terms of like their structure, right,
we're visualizing as a call tree, I know that
the time complexity would be the number of
nodes in the call tree, right. And so let's
start with some familiar territory, I kind
of already know that I need to realize the
height of this tree, the height of this tree
is going to be m, right? Remember that m is
our target string. And so imagine, in the
worst case that we took, or we had to take
a bunch of single character, choice of words
to construct our target string, that means
that the number of things I would have to
take all the way from the root to a base case,
or the root to the leaf would be exactly M.
Right? If I had to take a bunch of single
characters, so we can be confident that the
height of this tree would be m. So I talked
about the height. Now I need to realize the
branching factor, that is from one level of
the tree to the next, how does a number of
nodes change in the worst case? Well, I know
that the branching factor is dictated by how
many words I have in the word bank. And so
that would be some relation on n. So I know
at the root level, I have about one node.
But then in the worst case, to get to the
next level, I will multiply by n, right? Imagine
that, basically, almost every element of the
word bank was a matching prefix, right? So
you'd multiply by n. And let's say that carried
over further, let's say almost every word
of the word bank was still a prefix of those
resulting nodes, I would keep multiplying
by n. And I would do this overall m times,
right. So we already know that this is going
to be exponential, I need to multiply n by
itself, m times over. And so this would give
me an N to the M, time complexity. In general,
if you visualize your recursion using a nice
call tree like this, then the overall time
complexity is going to be the branching factor
to the height power. So we have a branching
factor of n and a height of m. That being
said, this will just really consider the number
of calls that we make, I want to be super
sure and make sure we didn't do any other
kind of performance or costly operations inside
of our code. So here's our code, same code
as we did before, if you look at this code,
some things I need to consider are probably
line six, right? If I look at line six, that
was where I did a target that slice that's
like copying over a part of the target string.
And to do that operation, I would actually
have to iterate through the target string.
Right? So that would actually contribute to
my complexity here. So in the worst case,
would I be slicing? Well, if I'm slicing a
target string, that would have like a maximum
length of M, right. And so in every call to
can construct, I'm going to have to do an
additional m operation, if I have n to the
M calls, then I can just multiply an additional
M over here, right. So I, I added some additional
term into our complexity, just multiplying
by M. Cool. And so overall, if you look at
that time complexity, it was already exponential
so that multiplication by m, doesn't really
make it that much slower, it's really the
N to the M, that makes it unbearably slow
in the first place. So that was the time complexity.
Now let's look at the space complexity. So
if we just refer to the space complexity,
due to the call stack, it looks like it's
going to be the height of this tree, right?
Like we always say, the height of the tree
would mean the maximum number of stack frames,
we would need on the call stack before we
bought them out at the base case, right? Because
when we return from a call, we would actually
remove something from the call stack, right?
The height of this tree is definitely just
M. So we'll say the space from the call stack
is just o of m. But again, we should also
you know, look at our code and see if we created
any other like growing structures. So we look
at the code right now, I see that on line
six, and kind of talking about that slice
statement. Again, the slice returns you a
new string, right. And that new string is
going to tend to be of length M. So on every
call to can construct, I'm creating a new
string, I actually need to maintain it through
the recursion, right, because I actually slice
before I return out on line eight. So because
of that, I know that each of my M stack frames
will have to store a string of length M. So
that just means m times m in my space complexity,
which is really just m squared. Cool, which
isn't too bad of really a space complexity
overall. Alright, so it looks like our final
complexity for our brute force solution is
exponential in time. And it looks like quadratic
in space. So obviously, let's work on improving
the time complexity over here. And so hopefully,
you're seeing where this is heading. Let's
say we jump back into my entropion pot example.
So this was a huge tree. Take a moment look
at this tree, and where can we actually optimize
some work away?
To we're trying to do is notice any overlapping
some problems In the context of our tree,
that means I'm looking for any duplicate sub
trees. And I see duplicate sub trees right
here, right? They follow the same structure
all the way down even to their base cases.
So I've looked at the sub trees, they're really
trying to solve the same problem, right? That
is they're both trying to figure out, can
we construct the string and teapot, right?
And if I saw that once, on the left hand side,
the answer is going to be the same on the
right hand side. So I can just store that
information in a memo, right? So the trick
is here to of course, memorize it using our
classic strategy. So let's hop to it. All
right, here we are back in my code editor.
Let's go ahead and just memorize this one.
So I'll create my memo object. And here, I'll
prefer to use the target as the key to my
memo, I know from one call to the next, the
word bank doesn't change, right? So I don't
need to actually make it a part of the key
for my memo object. So I'll just check, hey,
if my target is in the memo, then what I'll
do is return the stored value of that target.
Cool. While I'm here, let me also squish this
down to a one liner. So I have the memo checking
logic. Now I need to make sure I pass down
that memo to all of my recursive calls. And
then I need to actually store data in the
memo. And the rule is wherever you have your
recursive returns. Now, you should also store
that return value in your memo before you
actually complete the return. Right. So for
both of these lines, I'll make sure I store
them in the memo. So it's a memo at Target
equals that. But I still want to return that
same value. So we'll return true and return
false over here. Again, notice that I'm using
my exact argument targets, right? I don't
need to write any memorization logic about
the suffix, right? Imagine if we made the
call to can construct suffix becomes that
frames target. So the memos ation would still
work properly. Right? So that looks pretty
good. And it wasn't that much code, right?
memoization is always this slightly extra
layer, we add on top of our brute force solution.
So let's try this now can't construct. Nice.
And there we have that last example finishing
fairly quickly, or we do get the correct answer
of false over here. Alright, so here's what
we'll do, we're going to head back to the
drawing board. And of course, we'll come up
with the final complexity analysis for this
function. Some classic memorization, right?
Let's take a lay of the land over here. So
we wrapped up this can construct problem,
let's describe its final optimized complexity.
So again, like before, we'll say M is the
target length, and n is the number of words
in the word bank, our original brute force
had an exponential time complexity, right,
and that was n to the m times m. And when
we memorize our solution, we actually improved
it from exponential. So now, the time complexity
of our solution is n times m squared, right.
And the reasoning is, now we don't have to
fully explore any duplicate subtree, every
time we run into it, instead, we just store
the results in the memo. And we can just kind
of short circuit and fetch the stored result
in the memo. Notice that I have an M squared,
right in the memo, I have complexity, that
second m really comes from the fact that we
still have to do the slice, we have to pay
for that cost. So although we added an additional
object in our memo II solution, our space
complexity would remain in the polynomial
class. So overall, we definitely prefer this
second solution, because we remove some exponential,
you know, complexity. So now it is reasonable
to actually run this in an amount of time.
I think that wraps up this can construct problem.
Now let's work on the counting version of
this problem. In particular, I want to work
on count construct. So we have the same set
up here, I want to take in still a target
string and also an array of words in a word
bank. But this time I want to return a number,
I want to return the total number of ways
that the target can be made using words of
the word bank. And like before, we can reuse
elements of the word bank as many times as
we want. So notice that this question asked
us to do something slightly different, we
don't want just true or false. If it's possible,
we want the exact number of ways that we could
construct the target string. So let's take
a look at some examples. And also, you know,
take a high level view of the strategy here.
So let's say I gave you this string of abcdef.
And this array of words, this particular example
we saw before, and it is possible, and there's
actually one exact way we can generate abcdef.
So we can construct the tree in the same way
we did before. And we end up with this. However,
this time around, we want to choose a different
value to return for our base cases, as well
as changing the logic for reconstructing our
sub solutions, right? And so if I look at
the base cases here,
I wanted to kind of just adapt the return
value for this new type of data that I need
to return which is number. So I think the
move is for these scenarios where we can't
break down our current target any further.
That's your return zero, right? Yeah, f can't
be broken down because it doesn't have any
more matching prefixes from the array. So
that means there are zero ways to breakdown
F. And so we should return zero in those scenarios.
And then when we have the empty string we
know was successful. So we could always, you
know, create the empty string. And so that
should return one. And we've seen this logic
before in problems like Fibonacci, as well
as our grid traveller problem, we just want
to bubble up these values to their parents,
and make sure every parent will add up all
the numbers that come back from their children.
So it just bubbles up like this. And top level
we do zero plus one plus zero, which means
that we can generate abcdef in exactly one
way. And if you look at the way that actually
is symbolized inside the tree, it's exactly
the path from this root node all the way down
to that lone base case that returned an empty
string, right, ABC plus d f. Let's take a
look at another example. So here I have the
target string purple, and I have some other
characters and words inside of the array.
So take a moment to look at the input here
and predict what number they should return.
So the answer here is two, right, there are
two ways to create purple. So if you construct
the tree, we know we start with the initial
unknown of purple. And then we have about
three prefixes that match here. And those
yield some children, we can follow the same
pattern recursively down the tree. So the
full tree really looks like this, notice that
I have a two base cases that actually end
up as the empty string. So I know those are
going to turn one up to their parent. And
on the right hand side, I have a loan II that
can't be broken down any further that returns
zero. And like always, right, I just bubble
up these values, until at the parent, I actually
do one plus one plus zero, which gives me
two. All right, there are two distinct ways
to create purple using this choice of word
bank. All right, I think I'm feeling pretty
good about jumping into the code for this
one, it's really just a small variation of
the last problem we did. So let's hop right
in. Alright, programmers back in the code
editor, let's go ahead and bang this one out.
So I already have some examples that show
us what numbers we should return for this
count construct, right. So I have some examples
here. I'm gonna say even have that big example,
with our large inputs, we know that that will
probably need to be optimized, let's lay the
foundation with a brute force. So we'll start
with the same base case, as always, right.
So if the target is the empty string, then
we have truly solved the problem. Meaning
that there is definitely one way to generate
the empty string, right, just take no elements
from the word bank. Along with that, I need
to make my recursive call. So the usual structure,
right, I want to iterate through every choice
of word. So for let word of word bank. And
then for every word of that word bank, I need
to check if it's a prefix. So we've done this
before, if the target dot index of word bank,
or rather index of word, if that is equal
to zero, then it must be a prefix. And if
it's a prefix, and I can go ahead and take
like the rest of the word that is the suffix
and call recursively on it. So I'll do this
in line now say, count construct, and I'm
going to pass in the rest of the word, which
would be target dot slice, and then I'll slice
starting at word dot length. So this means
that the slice contains everything after the
word or everything after the prefix. And so
Also be sure to pass into the second argument,
the same word bank. Nice. And now I need to
think about what calc construct returns. So
it's returning a number now, right? So in
particular, this will be the will say, num
ways. I'll say no more ways for the rest,
maybe a little wordy of a variable name, but
I think it does describe how exactly what
this returns here, right. So this is a number
of ways that you can generate the suffix with
like the rest of the target. What I want to
do is keep a running total. So outside this
for loop, I need a way to add everything that
the for loop iterates through right, so I'll
create a total count over here. So I'll say
let, I'll say total count. And I'll start
it as zero. And now inside of my for loop,
whenever I get the number of ways to create
the rest of the string, I'll go ahead and
just add that into my total count. So it's
as simple as total count plus equals the number
of ways to generate the rest of the string
right after I've removed the word. And after
I take the total through the entire for loop,
and I can just return the total count. Something
really great about this, this programming
pattern is let's say that none of the choice
of words were a valid prefix. So that means
I finished this for loop. And this if statement
is never true. If this if statement is never
true, that I never add anything into the total
count. So if I return total count afterwards,
I return a still zero, which makes sense because
apparently there are zero ways to make the
target right have no initial step to take
in the word bank. So let's go ahead and test
this one out. So looks like we should get
to 104, and then also a zero at the end. Let's
give that a go.
So 2104. And it looks like the last example
is just a little slow for us. So you already
know where this one is heading. Let me tell
the program, let's just go ahead and just
memorize this one off the bat, right? Hopefully,
I think through all of these examples, you're
feeling really good about memorization. And
it's apparent that we basically have drilled
into our minds already. So if the target is
in the memo, and just return the stored value
memo at Target. And then I'll need to adjust
my return value, right. So where I return
over here is I'll store that total account
as the value corresponds to the target. And
let's not forget to also pass in the memo
to our recursive calls, right? So memo goes
right here. Nice. So let's give that a run
again. I expect a zero for that last answer,
right. So looks like I have an error over
here. And of course, I forgot to actually
replace my return value. So I can still return
the total counts. And addition to that, I'm
actually adding it into my memo. So let's
try that now. Yeah, these answers look correct,
right, I got zero for the last one, notice
that the last one is not possible, because
it ends in an F and all my words only contain
E's. Nice. And if you look at this code, it's
a pretty similar to our previous problem of
can construct if I kind of split these can
construct basically has the same shape. Really,
the only difference is this number variable
that I add into, and of course, the return
values. So we do expect the complexities to
be the same for these two functions. Let's
wrap this one up on the drawing board. Let's
look at the complexity of this. As always,
for this calc construct problem, our M is
going to be the length of a target string,
and our n is going to be the length of the
array, right? So that means a number of elements
in that array. Our brute force is the same
as it was in the can construct problem, right,
so it's still exponential. And using memoization.
We just brought that down from an exponential
to a polynomial time complexity, and the space
complexity remain the same. Really, there
is no additional cost that we pay in our implementation
for this counting version of the problem,
right. The only difference is now we're maintaining
a number that we just add to, you know, on
every iteration of that for loop. But that
doesn't really affect the runtime or the space
complexity at all. So I think this wraps up
this count construct problem.
Now I want to do one more variation of the
string problem. So what I want to do is write
a function called all construct that has the
same setup, right, so I'm going to take in
a target string, as well as an array of words
in a word bank. But this time, what I want
to do is return all of the ways that the target
can constructed by concatenating elements
inside of that word bank. And that means I
should return a two dimensional array, a single
element of that 2d array is going to represent
one of the combinations that can construct
the target, right, and I want to return all
of the ways within a 2d array. And as always,
we can reuse elements of the word bank as
many times as we need. So let's make sure
we understand this question by looking at
some examples and their output. So here's
an example using purple. And it's the one
we've seen before in the last problem. The
last problem I had us return to because there
were two ways to create purple. But now I
don't want the number, I want the exact ways
that actually create purple, that means you
need to return a two dimensional array, the
outer array, or the outer set of brackets
represents the collection of all combinations.
Whereas a set of inner brackets or a sub array
represents one of the combinations that creates
purple. Let's take a look at another example.
Let's say I gave you abcdef. And I gave you
this long array of word bank, notice that
I actually added some elements inside of this
word bank array. It's a little more complex
of in our previous examples. Because of this,
there are actually many ways you can create
abcdef. And this contains all of them, right?
So there are four ways to create our target
string. And again, notice that each sub array
represents one of those combinations of words
in the word bank that creates the target.
Cool. So now that we kind of understand like
the shape of this problem in terms of the
data we should return, let's take a look at
some base scenarios. So let's say I gave you
this example. Right? So I have a target of
Hello. And my words in the word bank are just
Cat Dog and mouse. Obviously, you know, that
is not possible to generate Hello. So there
are really zero ways to create this. How should
we actually return an answer here? Well, I
think it'd be reasonable to return an empty
array. Remember that we're saying the outer
array in this context represents the collection
of all of the combinations that can create
Hello, since there are zero ways to create
Hello, that means that our collection is empty,
right? This has a length of zero meaning there
are zero ways to create Hello. Now let's say
we had another base scenario. Let's say we
have to generate the empty string using the
same array of word bank. And that scenario,
I think it's reasonable to return an array
containing an empty array. And again, the
reason is if it is possible to To create the
target string, then we need to return a 2d
array, right where the outer array represents
the collection. And if there's one sub array
inside of that outer array, that means there's
one way to create the empty string. And what
does that one way? Well, it's to take no elements
from the word bang. So I think this is going
to be consistent logic, this is going to be
a really important way to think about this
problem. That is, when we're given a target
that cannot be constructed using the word
bank, we should return an empty array, right,
a one dimensional empty array, because there
are zero ways to create it. On the flip side,
if I've ever given the empty string, we know
that it's always possible. And so we should
return like a two dimensional empty array.
Cool. So with that, let's look at some tree
examples. Now, let's say I have this large
example from before, we know that the overall
tree like we've always know created would
look something like this. Obviously, now we're
just reframing this problem in the return
values that we do for our base cases. So you
notice that there are four base cases here
that kind of reach the empty string. And I
know that those represent the four ways to
create abcdef. And now I have to adjust the
return values here. So I'm already saying
that if I have the empty string, then that
should return an empty 2d array. So it looks
something like this, right? And how I actually
reconstruct the entire solution from these
very small sub solutions. So let's just stay
focused on the left subtree. Right now, I
know that these arrays are going to return
back to their parents. And when I do that,
I also need to make sure that I include the
edge that I actually use to transition to
the child. In other words, I'm going to be
sure to push the label for the edge into each
of those sub arrays. So the key insight is
this, right? I'm just pushing those edges
into their sub arrays. And from here, I continue
the pattern up a little further, right. So
I know that these arrays return their parent
over here, and I still, you know, push the
edges that I took to get to those children.
So on the left, I'm going to put CD in the
front, and on the right, I'm going to put
C in the front, resulting in this. And then
at this point, notice that this node rooted
at C D E F, that is actually going to receive
both of these collections, right? And what
should this note do? Well, it really needs
to just combine a both of these arrays. Recall
that, you know, we technically receive a two
dimensional arrays, which means that a sub
array represents one of the ways to create
the actual target. So if I just concatenate
these two, two dimensional arrays, that yields
this construct, if I do a quick spot check,
I'll see if this is compatible with what the
question is asking, right? This is a two dimensional
array. And I know there are actually two ways
that we can create CDF, if I look at what
this is saying, The first way is to do C,
D plus F. And the other ways to do c plus
d f. And so this cell problem is correct in
itself. So I'm going to use the same exact
logic to trace through the right hand side,
I know that these cases return to their parent.
And the parent is responsible for adding the
edge to each of those sub arrays like this.
Now, I'm just gonna reorganize everything
at the top just to give us some more room.
And maybe I'll even spread out these brackets
to make a look more symmetric. But I'm not
done here, I still need to consume each of
the edges at the very top of the tree. So
if I look at my left hand set of arrays, I
know that those need to receive AB. In other
words, they need to have a B place at the
front of each of those. So I'll just do that,
right. In the same way, all of the arrays
in the middle, which is really just a one
sub array, need to add ABC to the front of
them, like this. And finally, same thing on
the right hand side with ABCD. Cool. Now if
I look at what I have, these represent the
four ways that we can actually create our
original target string. But at this point,
the root node just needs to concatenate each
of these two dimensional arrays together.
So it really just combines them into a single
2d array like this. And if I do a quick sanity
check, I know that each of these sub arrays
represents one of the paths that I can take
to a base case down my tree, which is exactly
what we intended at the start. So this type
of recursion is definitely more complex than
the previous examples. But hopefully, you
can recognize what's similar to our last examples,
right? Let's do one more together, though,
let's go back to this purple example of the
full tree would look like this. And we'll
trace through this. So on the left hand side,
we're going to start with a 2d empty array,
right, because that's the base case for the
empty string. Meaning that hey, it is possible
to create the empty string in one way, and
that is to just take nothing. So I do the
same logic as our last example, meaning I
returned to my parent, but I'm being sure
to also include the value of the edge, right.
And so the key insight here is, I'm being
sure to add the edge label and not the actual
node label here. The note and the edge happened
to have the same thing le, but I'm really
looking forward to adding the edge right?
So I add Ellie over here. And likewise, this
returns to its parent even further, and so
Add that last edge of perp. Cool. Now I need
to do everything for this middle path. And
so what I'll do is return the empty 2d array
at the very bottom. And this really bubbles
up all the way to the top. And we just accumulate
every edge label as we go, right. So it sort
of looks like this.
And what's really interesting about this a
right hand path, this is actually a base case,
that doesn't work out, meaning we kind of
hit a dead end at EA. And what we said in
our initial examples was, whenever we have
a target string, that cannot be created at
all using words of the word bank, then we're
going to return a one dimensional empty array.
And that actually works out in our favor,
because if we return this empty array to our
parents, our parent is going to try to add
the edge into every element of this empty
array. But if there are no elements in this
array, and it's going to add nothing. In other
words, this one dimensional empty array really
just bubbles up to the very top. And like
always, if I just concatenate all three of
these arrays together, I actually end up with
my final answer, notice that when I concatenate
an empty array to the rest of these, I will
actually contribute nothing to my file answer,
which makes sense because there are no paths
that work out on that right hand side. So
our final answer is just this. Like, we know
both of those sub arrays represent the two
different ways that we can create purple.
All right, I'm feeling pretty good about this
process. Now, let's go ahead and code it up.
Alright, programmers back in the code editor,
another problem, another solution. So let's
start by laying out the base case over here.
Now, like we said, we'll say if the target
is the empty string, then we want to return
a two dimensional empty array, right? Every
single sub array here represents the one way
you can create the empty string by taking
nothing right I take no words of the word
bank. Nice. And then besides that, we need
to make our recursive logic. So that's going
to be very similar to what we've always done
for this style of problem. So I'm going to
iterate through every word of the word bank.
So I'll say let word of word bank word bank.
And I need to still check if there's a prefix,
right? If this word is a prefix, so if target
dot index of word, if that index is zero,
then I know that it must be a prefix, so I
can continue some code inside. Nice. And so
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and create an
extra variable just to store the target after
I remove the word which would give me like
the suffix so I'll say const suffix equals,
and I'll say target dot slice of word dot
length. So you've seen this pattern before.
But just to refresh, this just gives us everything
after the word. So basically, once you move
the word, what is the remainder of the string
all the way to the end. And now that I have
this suffix actually wants to call my function
recursively on that remainder, right? Just
like this, I'll pass along the same word bank.
Cool. And now here's where things get a little
intense, right? So we've been doing a lot
of problems, you know, using this recursive
structure, and then we memorize it in the
long run, I think the most important thing
to do is when you make your recursive call,
you really just assume that your function
works, right. So I think about what type I
should get back from all construct. So I know
that all constructs and give me back an array,
right, it's gonna give me back an array containing
all of the ways to make the suffix. If there
are no ways to make the suffix, then it's
going to give me like an empty array, right.
And so I'm going to assume that here, so I'll
create a variable. And I'll call it, let's
say, the suffix waise. And the reason I'm
naming it like this is, I really want us to,
in our head, think about the return value
from this as an array of all the ways to build
the suffix. Cool. So that's going to be a
two dimensional array, right? There are many
ways to do it. Nice. So if this gives me all
the ways to make the suffix, how can I get
all the ways to make the original target like
in this current stack frame? Well, what I
need to do is really just take each of those
suffix ways, and add my word to the front
of it, right? I used this word to even create
the suffix in the first place. So what I can
do is, I'm going to say my target ways. Right?
So now I want to relate how the suffix ways
can be used to build my original target, right?
All I need to do is really iterate over every
sub array over here and add my word to the
front of it. Right, that's exactly the process
we took in the tree diagram, right? So I can
use some nice JavaScript methods here. If
I just wanted to basically manipulate every
element of the array, I can do a map here.
So I'll say suffix, ways dot map. And I know
that a single element there's going to be
one way he'll say, singular. And then what
I want to do is just take that same way, copy
it over, meaning I just spread It's elements.
But I'm also going to put the word that I
took in the front, we've seen this syntax
before, although maybe this like map method
is maybe new free, maybe you're not super
familiar with JavaScript. I think that's fair
game. So let's hop into the node repple. Just
to demo this, let's say I had some array,
I'll just make this array 1234. So there's
my array. What I can do in general is use
array dot map. And map is a function and you
should pass in a callback. So that means another
function. And what I'll do is this callbacks
gonna take in every element, and it's gonna
be an arrow function, what's going to return
is really just how I want to modify the elements,
let's say I wanted to multiply every element
by two, right, the return value of this callback
function is going to become a new element
of the new array. So notice, I get back 2468,
my original array was 1234. And I get back
a new array using map. And so essentially,
what I'm doing in this example, on line eight,
in my actual code, I'm just taking every sub
array and just inserting my word at the front
of every sub array. So an example that speaks
closer to our exact code would might look
something like this, like suffix ways. And
it's going to be a 2d array. So I'll make
a sub array, and we just an array of some
strings kind of arbitrary right now. So I'll
say x, y, and then z. And then the second
sub array will be maybe I don't know, like,
a x and then a yz. Right, so that's my original
array. And what I want to do is, if I say
suffix ways dot map, and let's say for every
way, that is every sub array, I just want
to copy over that way by spreading out. And
then I'll just go ahead and put I don't know,
like an A at the front, just like this. So
notice what I get back, I basically have every
sub array from before, except now I have a
as the first elements of both of those. Cool.
So that's all I'm doing in this particular
chunk of code. Awesome. So we'll leave the
node repple. Back to our running solution.
And now that I have the target ways, that's
good. It's basically just like a piece of
the answer I need. However, it now this is
really only going to give me all of the ways
to make a target that use this word that I'm
currently like on in my iteration. However,
I know that this for loop gives me multiple
branches, right, it's going to use all of
the words that are possible to create the
target. So I need to kind of gather them all
together. So I'll create a variable on the
outside, I'll call it result mailstore. Everything
right? So across all of these iterations,
I just want to add the target ways into the
results, I'm going to do result dot push target
ways, and I need to actually spread this out
that way, I don't nest things too deeply.
Right? Remember that this is a one dimensional
array, right now, target ways would be two
dimensional, I don't want to just push target
ways into result. Otherwise, I'd get like
a three dimensional array. So I'm going to
be sure to spread out target ways, right.
So with that, let's actually go ahead and
give this run I think all I need to do now
is after my for loop, right, after I'm done
getting all the ways, then I can just return
the results of Mr. Just work recursively.
So let's just try maybe the first example
for now and see how we do. So I should get,
you know, a two dimensional array where I
have two ways to make purple. Right? let's
give that a go all construct. Nice, and that's
looking pretty good. That is a correct answer.
Let's try these other ones. Now while we're
here. So we should get a nice, large array
for that second example. Nice, here it is.
And then the third example, skateboard should
return just an empty array, because it's not
possible. And it looks like that last example
is also not possible. So we do get an empty
array. And if you kind of notice, to get that
last answer, like we did in our other examples,
it does noticeably take us some amounts of
time. But before we get to that, let's take
a look at this code, make sure we really understand
it. So the biggest logical leap we made here
was really, you know, assuming that we get
back valid data from line nine, right? And
then it's all about how we can, you know,
adjust that sub result to get our full answer,
right. So if I get all the ways to make the
suffix, and for each of those ways, I can
just add my word in front of them. And that
would give me all the ways to make my target.
Right. And I need to continue that process
for every choice of word, which is why I'm
maintaining this like a massive results variable
outside of the for just pushing all the ways
into this result over time. And maybe just
to be super clear, you're not familiar with
like this push method, especially when you
use the spread operator with it as well and
really easily step through that. So in isolation,
right, this is just using push and spread
in general, if I had some, let's say, array,
and let's say it was just an array of just
some elements 1234 Then I had another array,
I'll call it just numbs, let's say in nums,
I had elements of seven and eight. So here's
my original array. And here's my nums. And
if I did array dot push nums, you're actually
going to force some nesting in this array.
So array dot push returns the new length.
But it also actually manipulates or mutates,
the argument you call it on. So if I look
at the array, now, notice that it actually
has another array nested inside. That's because
I literally just pushed the entire nums. If
you wanted to do something a little different,
what you can say is array dot push, and you
spread out nums, what's going to do is comma
separates the seven and eight, basically removing
the outer brackets from it. So have a look
at this. Now, look at the array. Notice that
with that second push, now I just added a
seven and eight without those additional brackets.
So that's all I'm doing over here. Like I
said, I don't want to add another level of
nesting to the result array, right, it should
just always remain at most a two dimensional
array. Cool. But overall looks like we have
solved this one. And let's kind of talk about
if there is even a way to make this faster.
This is kind of an interesting problem. So
this is looking pretty good. So earlier, when
we were on the drawing board, we said that,
alright, because of what they're asking in
this problem, it is basically going to require
a full exploration, right? If I want you to
return every possible way, to make the target
string, you'll just have to kind of do all
the work of creating all of those sub arrays,
right, so we can't really avoid that stuff
over here. If you think about this example,
unlike 3334, this is actually not the worst
worst case anymore. All right, here, we know
that eventually we're going to return just
an empty array, because we can never generate
the final z in this example. However, if I
remove the Z, then the result will be a very,
very massive 2d array, because there are a
bunch of ways to actually make this target
string. Right. So we've kind of changed the
direction of what it means to be like worst.
On this example, let's say we brought this
to use the Z. If you really cared about optimizing,
like this particular scenario, you would find
some benefit to like memorizing it, although
it wouldn't really affect the worst case,
because the worst case is actually where you
return a two dimensional array and not just
an empty array. So maybe just because it's
good practice, well memorize this. But when
we go to the drawing board, we'll see that
this actually doesn't affect the true a bigger
worst case. But if you just want to optimize
it slightly, let's say we baked in our memo
over here, then we check, you know, if our
target is in the memo, and if it is, then
we return the memo, add the target, we'll
be sure to pass along that memo to our recursive
calls. And then we just need to make sure
that for our return value on line 16, we actually
store that inside of our demo
using the target as a key, and then we still
complete the return by returning result like
we once did. Cool. So let's run this now.
And I would agree that the last example now
runs faster. But it is not the worst case
is a really important thing to understand
here. Right? The worst case is when you actually
have to create a massive sub array, right.
And so let's head to the drawing board and
see our final conclusion about the complexity
here. Like we usually do, well define m to
be the length of the target string, and n
will be the number of words in the word bank.
We know that this problem asks us to return
an array containing every combination that
generates the target string. And to come up
with that answer, we have to visualize it
like a tree sort of like this. In our previous
drawing, we saw how each leaf of this tree
represents one way we could create the target
string. In other words, if we can figure out
the total number of leaves in a tree like
this, then we will basically have the number
that represents how many different ways or
how many sub arrays we have to generate in
this problem. We already know that based on
our process, we described that there are dimensions
to this tree, we know that the height of this
tree is going to be m and we know that from
one level to the next, we really just multiply
the number of nodes by n. And that means at
the base of this tree, we would have entity
m number of nodes, right, so we have n to
the M leaves, which means that we have n to
the M different combinations that generate
the target string. And if we have to represent
each of these entity m combinations, then
we definitely need n to the M sub arrays in
our output. And so what we're saying here
is no matter what clever implementation we
create, we really have to return a result
that is exponential in size. And that's really
going to drive the complexity of this one.
You can't do any better than exponential over
here. And its overall will say at the time.
complexity of this is n to the M or just exponential.
If you want to split hairs here, you can really
multiplied by some additional factors of m.
However, the exponential nature of this alone
really gives us the overall complexity, right,
because once something is exponential, there's
really no coming back from that. And in a
different vein, we can say that this space
complexity for this is O of M, like we usually
say, it's really just the height of the recursion
tree. And an example like this, where output
is very large, we usually don't include the
size of the output of the size of the result
into our space complexity, which case obviously,
would also be exponential in space, because
the result is exponential. Right. So here,
we'll just refer to the additional space we
use for the call stack, which would be o of
M, right, any solution you come up with for
this problem would be just about this fast.
Alright, and there, we have our all construct
problem.
So at this point, we've gone over many dynamic
programming problems, and we use that memoization
strategy to work out a solution for all of
them. However, memoization is only one of
the ways we can actually implement a dynamic
programming solution. Right now I want to
revisit all of those problems, but this time
use a different lens of understanding. As
always, I want us to ease into things. So
we'll warm up with this fib function, this
is the same problem as last time. In other
words, I want us to return the F number of
the Fibonacci sequence. Here, I'll say that
the zeroeth number of the sequence is zero.
And the first number of the sequence is one,
you might notice that this time around, I'm
saying that the zeroeth number is zero and
the first number is one. Whereas in the first
time we did this, we said the first number
is one and the second number is one However,
no matter how you start the sequence, they
will both actually give you the same series
of numbers. In other words, down below here,
I have some examples for n as well as what
the output for our fib function should be.
In other words, if I asked you for the six
Fibonacci number, the answer there is eight,
like we always expect, alright, let's get
into the heart of this strategy, right? What
does tabulation even mean? Well, it's all
about building a table. So what we'll do now
is step through a tabulated strategy for calculating
fib of six. I know that in the long run, I
ought to return the final answer of eight,
right? So I hope that I get the answer right
by the end of this little trace. So with tabulation
we're choosing to do is really think about
this dynamic programming problem, still in
terms of subproblems. But instead of doing
it recursively, we do it iteratively by building
a table, really just an array, and I'm going
to begin it with roughly the size of the input.
In other words, if my input here is the number
six, then I basically want an array of length
six, notice that if I want the indices of
this array, it's kind of line up perfectly
with the original input number. And I'm going
to have to actually add an extra position.
In other words, this array spans indices zero
through six, which kind of means that there
actually are seven different elements here,
right, the length of this array is seven.
So something very common that I see when students
try to implement a tabulated strategy is they
kind of overlook this off by one nature, right?
So technically, I'm creating an array that
has one greater length than my number input.
But any case, if this is my array, what do
I want it to represent? Well, in the long
run, I want to actually fill out this array
in a way where each subproblem corresponds
to an elements of this array. So here's how
I'm going to begin this table. The move here
is to actually initialize every position of
this table with zero. And the reason for me
initializing zero everywhere in this array
is the fact that I know Fibonacci requires
me to take a sum, right, and zero is a really
great starting value when I need to calculate
a running sum, right. But along with that,
I need to be sure to seed the starting values
within this table. In other words, if I look
at the zero position of this table, it already
has a zero, which makes sense because the
zero number on the Fibonacci sequence is zero.
But what I should also do is make index one
contain a value of one. And that kind of entails
that, hey, the first Fibonacci number is indeed
one. And now at this point, once I've seeded
those initial values, now I can actually run
the general algorithm to fill out this table.
So now it's just a matter of iterating through
this table, so I'm going to start you know,
at the very first position of the table, probably
just with a regular for loop. And what I need
to do is really remember the definition of
Fibonacci, right. So if I have this number,
currently in the array zero, that's a zero
Fibonacci number, what I can do is just add
this current number that I have kind of pointed
to in yellow to the next two positions. And
the reasoning there is a Fibonacci number
is used to contribute to the sum of for the
next two Fibonacci numbers. So I'm going to
do is take the zero and add it to the next
two positions, obviously, since it's zero,
actually don't change the values of those
next two positions. It's nothing really is
calculated on that first iteration. But any
case I can continue on to the next iteration,
so my current position is always in yellow,
and the next few positions are pointed to
in blue. At this point, my current position
says one is what I should do is take one and
add it to both of my next positions. So that
means two and three are indices two and three
are contained both a one and a one which so
far, make some sense because at least for
the to the second number of the Fibonacci
sequence is indeed one, I can do the same
thing, right, my current position contains
a one. So I'll add that one into my next two
positions. Keep doing this, I add two to my
next two positions, at three to my next two
positions.
And at this point, I sort of reached the end
of my array. So I know that I probably shouldn't
step out of bounds. So really just want to
look one position ahead over here. And at
this point, I just add five into my next position,
which actually works out to an eight being
stored in index six of this array. Which makes
sense because logically, the six number of
the Fibonacci sequence is a just like we intended.
That's all there is to tabulating Fibonacci,
the most apparent difference from our previous
like recursive strategy was, this is not recursive,
right? This really just requires us to iterate
through an array. So to fully iterative process.
And at this point, the actual complexity of
this is really straightforward to kind of
foresee, we know that we're just going to
iterate through an array of size n, that must
mean that our time complexity is just n. In
the same way, the only space we use is really
just the space of the array, which I know
is still going to be sighs and as well. So
overall, we're looking at a linear solution
for fib. So before we hop into the code, for
this one, I just want to draw a really important
connection. So although at face value, this
iterative strategy looks very different from
the recursive solution, a lot of the logic
really carries over, I'm still using my overlapping
subproblems to solve this one. So for example,
I know that every index of this array really
corresponds to some number input for fib of
n, right? So I can kind of visualize it like
this, right? Like we said, the six of bonacci
number is eight. So I'm just going to choose
a position of this table, let's say I looked
at fib of six. So I know that to calculate
fib of six, what I did was really add the
previous two numbers into this position, right.
And if you kind of see that the shape of this,
I kind of dropped the table, and even just
ignore the rest of the subproblems. This is
basically just a tree that can kind of shift
things around. And it really looks like this.
So overall, you're looking at really the same
relationship for calculating Fibonacci. It's
just encoded in a table instead of the recursive
tree. But overall, if you understand, you
know, the recursive solution, you should still
find, you know, some comfort inside of this
iterative solution. But I think at this point,
let's hop into the code for this one. Alright,
programmers, let's go ahead and translate
that strategy into some code. So I'll start
by creating a table, which really just means
creating an array, we'll call this table.
And I need this array to have certain dimensions
that are roughly the size of n. So to do that,
in JavaScript, I can say array and call a
static method and pass in my desired size.
So here, I want to say n plus one. For the
reason we did in the sketch, right, I need
to make sure that the last index of this array
is exactly n, I have to do a plus one here,
because of course, indices start at zero.
Cool, that should give me an array of that
n plus one size. And then at this point, what
I want to do is assign particular values into
this table. So let's just say I console dot
log, what this table looks like, I'll just
run this first example of fib of six. So I'll
give this a go. So notice that the array that
prints out is this, it says like seven empty
items, which means that the elements are undefined
right now, according to our strategy, but
we should do is assign these all to zero.
So what I can do is, after I initialize the
array over here, I can fill it up with all
zeros using the dot fill method, right? It's
an array instance method. So with that change,
now I should have a seven zeros inside of
this array. Cool, so it's looking pretty good.
At this point, I also need to fill up a particular
value inside of the table, I really need to
make sure that the index one contains a value
of one, right so I can say table at index
one equals one. So we're seeding index one
with a value of one to symbolize that the
first bonacci number is one, remember that
we kind of have like two base scenarios. In
Fibonacci, let's just console that log with
this table looks like now to make sure it's
in the correct state before we actually iterate
through it. Cool. So this is a good starting
point for our table. So at this point, what
I want to do is iterate through the table.
So use a regular for loop for that. We're
gonna need access to the indices. So I'll
say let i equals zero. And I'll go up to and
including, and basically give me iterations
through the entire table. And I'll do i plus
plus, I'm going to hit every position. Cool.
According to what we did in our strategy.
What I should do is look at the next two positions
after I right, so I'll say as I'm gonna look
ahead and table and I'll look at positions
I plus one, and also i plus two, right? Of
course, right now I'm currently situated at
position I. And what I did was I added into
those two neighboring positions, I added my
current value in the table. So what I'll say
is, in my next position i plus one, I'm going
to increment it by exactly what table I says,
right? So I'm incrementing, my next position
by the value in my current position. And the
same will hold true for the next position
two spaces away, right, so they both get plus
equals table. I
know nice. So this is looking pretty good.
After we're done doing this process for the
entire table, where we're just going left
to right, filling in our next two neighboring
positions, what we'll do is just return our
answer, which should be table at position
n, right? To finish this off, I just want
to return the table at index n, because the
elements of this array correspond to the Fibonacci
number, right? And the index is sort of the
input to my function. So let's try these examples.
We'll give them all ago.
Cool. So I get 813 21. In this very large
number, this actually looks correct. Nice.
This is a fair implementation of Fibonacci.
Notice that because we're already using an
iterative strategy, we already satisfy a decent
complexity for even this, this last example
over here, we already mentioned the time and
space complexity of this strategy, right,
it gives us a linear time and space. However,
you may already have in your head that we
could actually optimize a little more here
and just use a constant amount of space. However,
if you want to kind of subscribe to just a
generic tabulation strategy that I know is
going to be useful in most problems, I will
kind of stick to this overarching pattern
right of initializing our table upfront, that
is roughly the size of the input, and then
iterating through that table. Of course, you
can probably finesse this fib function to
only track two variables represent your last
Fibonacci number, as well as your last last
Fibonacci number. But I'll leave that to you
because it's not really a classic tabulation,
which is a topic want to drill into our heads
right now. Let's head back to the drawing
board and do another problem. All right, now
let's revisit that grid traveller problem
using tabulation. So like before, we're going
to have a 2d grid, and we start in the top
left corner. And our goal is to go to the
bottom right corner, we only have two possible
moves at any point in time that is to move
down or to the right. And how many ways can
we actually travel to the goal, if we had
a grid of dimensions, m by n. And we want
to write our function to actually calculate
this. So let's trace through how you can build
a table for this one, let's say we're going
through grid traveller of a three by three
grid, that means that our output should be
six in the long run. So like before, our first
step in this tabulation recipe, is to create
a table that is roughly the size of the input.
And so here I have two inputs, and they really
represent the number of rows and number of
columns. So I can create a 2d array to correspond
to that. Like before, if I want the indices
to match up here, I'm going to have to make
sure that this two dimensional array has dimensions
four by four, right? If I give it a four by
four array, that means that the bottom right
index is really three comma three, which works
out nicely, very similar to what we did in
that last fib problem. Cool. So I established
the dimensions for my table. Now I have to
figure out what should I actually begin my
table with, right? What are the good seed
values to use here? Well, I know this is a
counting problem, right? Because they're asking
me to count the number of ways to travel through
this grid. For these counting problems. Good
initial value to choose is usually zero. So
I'm going to put zero everywhere in this grid.
But at that point, I may need to seed another
value in other position in this table, if
you recall our previous discussion about this
grid traveler problem, we said that it's a
really important case that all right grid
traveler have a one by one should return one
right there is one way to travel the gray
one by one grid. And so I'll go ahead and
actually take that information and encode
it into my table. So I'll make index one one,
actually contain the elements of one. And
I should give me a nice starting point for
this algorithm. So at this point, what we
want to do is iterate through this table and
come up with some logic that combines the
values in this table, right, basically combining
different subproblems to solve my larger problem
at hand. So let's just begin in the top left
corner of this grid. In the long run, we can
really implement this kind of iterative pattern
through a grid using just some nested for
loops, right. And the key insight is I know
if I'm at this position, if I see zero at
indices, zero comma zero, that means in a
zero by zero grid, there's zero ways to move
through it, which makes sense, right? Because
if any of your dimensions contains zero, then
that must mean that your grid is empty, right?
So the game isn't even valid. But if we want
to have some consistent logic, the move is
to use your current position highlighted in
yellow right now and add it to your neighbors,
right, according to the game, I can only move
to the right or downward. So technically,
what I'm doing right now is I'm taking my
current positions element, and adding it to
my down neighbor and my right neighbor. Obviously,
if I just have a zero in my current position,
then really no arithmetic takes place. But
let's go ahead and do these iterations just
to make sure we have consistent logic, right,
so they keep adding these zeros to their right
and down neighbors, nothing changes for now,
until I get to the next row, right, this first
iteration, next row, still just add zero to
its down and write. But once I'm at this point,
I'm going to take this one, I'm going to add
it to my right and down neighbor. So that
means they both turn into a one, I keep following
this pattern, right, both of my neighbors
turn into a one. And obviously, whenever I
kind of reached like the bounds of my grid,
I need to probably make sure that I don't
do any illegal Array Operations. But that's
really an implementation detail for the code.
So on to our next row, we contribute zero
to both of our neighbors. Here, we contribute
one to both of our neighbors.
Now we contribute to to both of our neighbors.
And here we contribute three to both of our
neighbors. And finally, things get interesting
in the very, very last row, I contribute zero
to my neighbors, I contribute one to my neighbor,
I contribute three to my neighbor. And at
this point, we've kind of finished iterating
through the entire grid. And if you look at
this position, it contains a six symbolizing
that, hey, how can you actually travel through
a three by three grid? Well, there are actually
six different ways you could do that. So before
we jump into the code for this one, you can
probably already foresee the complexity of
this. So we know that the complexity is really
driven by the dimensions of this table, I
know that this table is going to have m rows
and n columns. So if I need to iterate through
this table, it's just going to take m times
n time. And along with that, what is the space
that we need? Well, it's really just a space
for this 2d array, which is, of course, still
m by n. So overall have m times n time and
space. Let's jump into the code for this one.
Now. All right back into the code editor.
Let's work on implementing this grid traveller
tabulation strategy. So we'll start by initializing
our table, which is going to be a little more
complex here compared to our last function,
because it needs to be a 2d array. So what
I'll do is I'll start by creating, let's say,
the correct number of rows. So that will be
as simple as calling array. And I want really
dimensions m plus one, again, I have to adjust
for that off by one error, because I want
the max index in this table to actually be
exactly right. And I know indices start at
zero, so I'm going to up it by one over here.
Cool. So I'll give me the correct number of
rows. And I want to make sure that the elements
inside of this array are also other sub arrays.
So a trick I can do for that is we're going
to fill this is kind of just a very particular
JavaScript pattern, I'm going to call fill
on this array I just created. And afterwards,
I'm able to map over it. Cool. So maybe I'll
spread this out like this.
And when I map over this array, what I want
to do is make sure that every element of the
array is going to be a new array like this,
this time of dimensions n plus one though,
so I have roughly m rows and n columns. So
let's go ahead and just see what the shape
of this is. When I print out, let's say the
three by two example. So we'll go ahead and
run this code. So notice that if I look at
the arrays I printed out here, it looks like
I have a four by three array, which makes
sense because again, I increase my initial
dimensions by one that looks good to go. However,
what we'll want to do is really understand
how what this map is useful for. So a very
common mistake that you might be tempted to
do is Can't I just, you know, skip this map
part, and then do the fill with the array
of n plus one. So that will look like it gives
you the same thing. So I'll run that code.
But if you write it this way, what you're
doing is you're filling the entire outer array
with a single array instance multiple times,
right? So the shortcoming of this code is
let's say I kind of change only one position
of the table, let's say I just made an X kind
of arbitrarily, that would actually look like
it changed many positions of the grid, right.
And that's because this is technically just
one array that's inserted multiple times into
the outer array, whereas I need a really unique
array references. So that's how we need the
map pattern here. I know every time we evaluate
the callback function to map, it's actually
going to execute this entire function, which
means it's going to give us a new inner array
instance. Right. So if I use this map pattern
I run again, this is really the intended behavior,
right? I have a unique array as a sub arrays
here. And so let's take out this expert. But
that being said, Now that I have the correct
shape of my table, I need to insert some good
starting values, right? So what are the seed
values here, while we're calling in our strategy,
we said that basically the entire table could
contain mostly zeros. So maybe I'll bake that
right into this line. So after I make a new
sub array, I'll be sure to fill it with some
zeros. So if I run that, now, I should have
a nice table, because that's looking pretty
good. At this point, I also need to see another
value, right? We talked about it in that we
should see table at position one, one with
exactly one, this is sort of like our base
case, when we have a one by one grid, there's
definitely only one way to travel through
it. So now we have the elements of one in
position. One, one. Nice. So at this point,
now I need to iterate through my table and
fill in other positions. So I'm going to use
just nested loops for this. So I'll say let's
i equal zero. And I want to make sure that
I goes up to and including m right, basically
the dimensions of the table, and I'll do i
plus plus. And very similar for my inner loop
being sure this time to reference j and j
is gonna go up to n this time, because we'll
just have classic nested loops just iterating
through this two dimensional array, right?
So as I'm iterating through the table, what
was the logic we trace through in our drawing?
Well, I what I needed to do was take my current
element that I'm at, so maybe I'll call it,
let's say, my current. So my current element
would be at table ij. So I need to take this
current element, and I need to add it into
my right neighbor, and my down neighbor, right.
So if my row is I and my columns j, that just
means I do some arithmetic on i and j. Right.
So if I want to increment my, let's say, right
neighbor, what I can say is, look at table,
a position i, j plus one, that'd be directly
to my right. And I'm going to increase it
by whatever this current is, if I want to
look at my down neighbor, and that'd be i
plus one, but I keep j the same. Cool. So
this will add to my two neighbors that are
to the right of me and below me. And at this
point, what we have to be aware of is like
what happens at our edges of this table, we
know that if we're already at like the last
position of a row, if I do j plus one, I'm
gonna go out of bounds. And so to make sure
I don't step out of bounds on these increment
expressions, I'll need some conditional logic.
So I'll say if the right position is inbound,
so if j plus one is less than or equal to
n, then I'll go ahead and increment to the
end should be okay. And likewise, if i plus
one is less than or equal to m, then I'll
also increment right? Notice that when I checked
my like j value, that should be using n, right,
because that's the number of columns and then
I is a number of rows. So it should use M.
Cool. So what I have so far as I'm iterating
through every position of my table, and I'm
going to take the elements at my current position,
and I'm going to add it into my right neighbor,
as well as my down neighbor, about only if
they actually exist. Cool. So once I'm done
filling up the table, then my final answer
should just be at position m, and right just
the very bottom right corner here. So let's
give this code a run. So I should get 1336.
And then there's a very large number, or run
grid traveller.
Nice and looks like this solution is totally
working. And we are already satisfying our
the last example here, right? If you tabulate
off the bat, you will have a pretty quick
solution. And we already traced through the
complexity for this. So take a moment to you
know, look at this code, let it sink in, or
really try to understand how we took that
whiteboard strategy and implemented it in
some code, right? We do have to do some like
kind of fine implementation details, especially
with the bounds checking here. But I think
the most important logic, it's about how our
current position of the table contributes
to our immediate neighbors to the right and
downward. With that, I think let's head back
into the drawing board. Alright, now that
we've seen tabulation in two different problems,
hopefully we're noticing some patterns right?
Let's give ourselves some rules we can follow
to tackle any dynamic programming problem
using a general tabulation strategy. With
this tabulation recipe, it's going to be pretty
different compared to our memoization recipe
in that there aren't two main steps when I
talked about memorization I said, make sure
you implement the brute force first, and then
add the memorization app. Towards. Whereas
if you just try to tabulate a problem, you're
really going to have the most efficient version
of your solution all in one swoop. And so
what is our first step for tabulation? Well,
of course, you have to visualize it as a table.
And that really begins with a conversation
of what you'd like the size or dimensions
of the table V, that should definitely be
correlated based on the size of the input.
So in the case of fibonacci of n, we made
our table roughly, you know, n elements long,
sometimes you definitely have to watch out
for like an off by one scenario, which we've
been seeing lately. In the case of our grid
traveler problem, we saw that because our,
you know, problem represents a grid, we had
to create a two dimensional table at that.
So figure out the size of your table based
on the inputs to the problem. Cool. And once
we do that, we need to initialize some values
within the table. To me, this is always about
choosing compatible types. In other words,
if your problem asks you to return a number,
then it'd be wise to initialize the values
of your table with numbers right? On the flip
side of that, if I was asked to return a Boolean
in a problem, Na, consider initializing true
or false within the table. Cool. And once
I have all of the kind of generic values filled
up in the table, then I choose my very important
seed value, right? I know that this seed value
should capture the scenario, where I have
a trivially small instance of the input where
I automatically know the answer, right. So
in the case of our classic Fibonacci, that
means I just seed the N one and the N two
values of my table with one and one respectively.
And in the case of our grid traveller, we
were sure to capture the scenario where we
had a one by one grid, so you're gonna need
to see those values, because that's the basis
upon which we fill the rest of the table.
And then we have the hard part, which is really
iterating through the table. And you have
to come up with some logic, right, as you
iterate through the table, you have to design
some logic that fills further positions of
the table based on the current position. And
you really have to, you know, look to the
problem to figure out what the logic is. In
the case of Fibonacci, it's as simple as if
I'm at some position of the table, I look
one space ahead and two spaces ahead, very
reminiscent of the pattern Fibonacci, in the
case of our grid traveler problem was about
looking the unit to the right or the unit
downward, effectively shrinking the size of
our grid. So it's really up to you to figure
out the logic, look for it language in the
problem. What I always do is focus on what
options I have at any point in the problem,
right? My options are Do I go rightward? Or
do I go downward in that grid traveler and
problem. So we'll stick to these rules as
we tackle our a tabulation problems, and we'll
utilize them right now.
Okay, so let's work on tabulating our can
some problem now. So recall that in this problem
we want to do is take in a target sum as an
argument, as well as an array of numbers.
And we want to return a Boolean indicating
whether or not we could generate the target
sum. By adding numbers in the array, we can
reuse an element of the array as many times
as we want, we can also assume that all the
input numbers over here are non negative.
So we've solved this problem before, right?
recursively using memoization. But now we
want to use a tabulation point of view. So
let's come up with the strategy here. So let's
say I gave you this input of seven and an
array of 534. In the long run, the answer
is true because it is possible to generate
seven, right, you can either do a three plus
four or a four plus three, and that would
give you your original target. So you know
that in the first step for tabulation, all
we need to do is create a table. But I guess
the question here is, what size table do I
create, I have two inputs, I have the target
as well as the array of numbers, which of
those actually contribute to my initial table.
And so the key insight is to think about,
you know, what's going to change throughout
the problem. In other words, if we can reuse
the numbers of the array as many times as
we need, then it's not like we're shrinking
the size of that array. However, if we think
about the target number of the target, some
that were given, we do have a goal of actually
reaching that target. So now we're going to
increase to it over time. And so I'm going
to use that as a basis for my table. That
is, I want to create an array that is roughly
the size of my target sum. So because the
target sum is seven, I want to make sure that
the indices lined up perfectly. So I'll actually
have to create an array with length eight.
And in general, I just be creating an array
of length target sum plus one, because we
have that classic off by one error over here.
Alright, now that we have the correct size
of table, what do I actually want to store
inside? That is what should the eventual elements
of this array be? So a really nice rule of
thumb you can use for that is to just recognize
what type your answer should be. In the long
run, right, so here, they're asking for a
Boolean answer. So that really tells me that
I should probably put some boolean data as
the elements of this array. So I'm going to
start by initializing every element of this
array with a false value. And the reasoning
is right now we're kind of assuming before
we check anything, that none of these target
sums are actually possible to be generated.
Cool. But neither think about any particular
seed values, I need something inherent to
this can some problem is we treat the target
sum of zero very special, right sort of the
base that we use. In other words, someone
gave me a target of zero, I know that that
is always possible, no matter what elements
I have in the array, because to generate zero,
I can just take no elements of the array.
So that's going to be a really important seed
value here. So I'm going to populate index
zero with the element. True. Cool. So now
that we have some good seed value, now we
want to think about how we can flesh out the
other elements of this array, sort of in a
linear fashion, right? So I'm gonna have to
iterate through this table. So let's just
start at the very first index. So right now
I'm looking at index zero. And if I'm situated
in any position of this array, then the value
I'm currently looking at, should basically
say, you know, is it possible to generate
that index amount? In other words, since I
have a true at index zero, then I know that
it is possible to generate zero using the
coins of the array. But now that I'm at this
position, how can I actually transition into
the further positions of this table. And so
what I want to do now is consider the possible
numbers that I can take into my sum. So I'm
going to start by looking at this first element
of five. I know that if it's possible to generate
zero, then if I also have a five in the array,
then it's also possible to generate five in
the context of my array, that means I should
look about five spaces ahead from my current
position. So I look at this spot, right, exactly
five indices ahead. And right, now I should
actually replace this false value that's stored
at index five, with a true and again, the
reasoning is, if it's possible to generate
my current amount, right, right, I have a
true in the zero, it's possible to generate
my current amount, and I could take a five,
that means that the position of five steps
later should also be true, right. And I want
to actually continue this process for the
other values in my numbers array. So I'm just
going to look at the next element of three,
that's basically telling me that, hey, the
next spot three places away should also become
a true, so I'll just go ahead and make that
a true. And finally, likewise, for the last
element of four, right, the element four spaces
ahead, should also be turned to true.
Cool. And at this point, I think I finished
like my very, very first iteration, that is
when my current is at index zero. And at this
point, I just want to keep iterating through
the array, so I'm just gonna shift my point
of view, or one space to the right. So now
I'm looking at my current as index one. And
what does that over here, my current element
is actually false. So what that means is,
it is not possible to generate one using the
numbers of the array, which logically makes
sense, right, I only have five, three and
four. So there's no way you can ever give
me back a one, right. So if I have a false
value at my current position, then I should
not modify like my further values by looking
ahead. So notice that if I look at my edge
for five, look, five spaces ahead, I am not
going to make that a true because my current
position is not true, right. So I'm going
to keep iterating. Same thing happens when
I'm at index two, because the current value
is false, there's nothing to be done here,
things get really more interesting on this
iteration right? at index three as my current,
then I see a true at this position. So that
means I need to look ahead to my future positions,
and actually assign them to be true. Obviously,
you'll notice over here, if I look five positions
ahead, when I'm currently at index three,
then that would actually be out of bounds.
So I don't need to look that far ahead. So
we'll kind of drop that connection. But at
this point, I should make the space three
positions ahead truth, that's almost a space
for positions ahead. So that means that indices
six and seven are set to true, right? I keep
doing this process all the way through the
entire table. Notice that as I keep iterating
toward the right, these forward looking references
kind of stopped being useful because it goes
out of bounds. But the point is, by the end
of all of these iterations, I do have a true
stored at index seven, which means that it
is possible not to generate a quantity of
seven. And if I do a quick spot check, and
I look at just my entire table right now,
it has very consistent data. In other words,
if I notice where all of the true values are
right there at 03456, and seven, that means
that all of those quantities for target are
actually possible, right? On the flip side,
if I look at the only elements and indices
that are false, like one and two, that makes
sense, because those are the only quantities
that are not possible or you can't possibly
generate a one and two, using a five, three
and four as your option. Adding up, right?
So we know by the end of this algorithm, the
element that is stored at the last position
of our table would be the final answer, right?
So if it's true, then it's possible if it's
false, it is definitely not possible. All
right, so let's wrap up this sketch by actually
talking about the complexity of this, as always,
we'll define our terms. So we'll say that
n is going to be the target sum, which is
just a number. And the flip side of that will
say that n is going to be the length of the
numbers array. And we already have the vibe
that, hey, both of these terms definitely
affect our complexity, right? If you give
me a larger target sum, that's probably a
harder thing to calculate. In the same way,
if you give me more numbers to choose from,
it's even harder to calculate, right. And
we can recognize that the algorithm just has
us flesh out this table. And I know that the
table is of size m, so we're going to have
at least M. However, as I iterate through
every position of the table, what I had to
do was actually look ahead in the table for
every single element of the numbers array.
So I know that that's going to be accomplished
basically, using some nested loops, where
I'm going to have a loop to iterate through
just the table, and then a nested loop to
iterate through every number of the numbers
array. So overall, I'm looking at N, N times
N, time complexity. And along with that, where
does this space here? Well, the space is really
just the exact size of this table, which is
based solely on M. So I have just m space
overall. Nice. So this is already looking
like an efficient implementation, especially
because we're not dabbling with any exponential
complexity over here. I think let's work on
the code now. So here we are back in the code
editor, let's start like we usually do by
creating our table. So I'll store this table,
and like we discussed in our drawing, we need
to make it roughly the size of our target
sum. So I'll create an array, I need to make
sure that the indices lineup directly or at
one index, that is exactly the target sum.
So I'm going to initialize it to target sum
plus one, right. So that means if I pass in
target sum is seven, when I create an array
of length eight, which means that its very
last index is seven, which is perfect. Cool.
And while we're here, we'll go ahead and actually
initialize this array with all false values.
So I'll do that. I need to make sure that
I seed index zero with a true symbolizing
that the target sum is zero, it's always possible
to be made, even before I look at, you know
what's in the numbers array. So I'll just
go ahead and say, table at index zero is equal
to true.
So let's just console dot log, what this table
looks like so far. And I'll just run, let's
say the second example here. So I should see
my array of length beat, up need to go into
this tabulation folder. Now I'm going to run
this guy. Cool. So it looks like a good table,
right? eight elements. And I do have a true
at index zero. Nice. So at this point, now
I want to actually lay out the core algorithm
by iterating through the table, somebody who's
a regular for loop here, let's say let i equals
zero, go up to I can even include if I wanted
to, up to an including the table dot length
is you could also say a target some here some
thing based on target some I'll do i plus
plus. And here I'm going to choose to iterate
using, you know the manual index, because
I know I have to do some arithmetic to look
ahead on the array. But as I iterate through
every element of the array, I want to actually
check you know if this position is true, so
I'll check if table at index AI is true. Cool,
they know inside of this if statement, I need
to basically jump ahead or look ahead, based
on what's in my numbers array. But I only
need to do that if my current position is
true, right, I only got to look ahead, if
it's even possible to get to this current
amount, right, the current amount I'm sort
of tracing through would be at index i. So
at this point inside of my if statement, what
I want to do is now look ahead for each a
number of this array, so a nested loop here.
And I just want to look at the elements of
this array. So I'll say for, let's say, let
num of numbers. So I'm grabbing each element
this time. And now for this number element,
I want to look that many spaces ahead. So
I want to look at basically table at index
i plus the number. Cool. So imagine that I'm
on like the first iteration of this, I know
is going to be zero. So that's the very, very
first index of my table. And if my num is
five, then I'm going to do zero plus five
looking five spaces ahead right just like
we did in our trace. And for this position,
that is like five spaces ahead. I want to
assign it to be true, basically saying that,
hey, if my current position is reachable,
and I can take a step of exactly numb then
that must mean position. I plus numb is also
reachable write that entire for loop goes
inside of this if statement, right? So this
code is looking pretty good. So far, I think
the last thing we need is just to return our
final answer. After we're done iterating through
the table. So here I'll just return table
at index targets. Cool. So let's, let's go
ahead and run these examples. Maybe we'll
have to debug some stuff. Looks like I have
a probably an infinite loop. Yeah, my program
crashed with some massive error. So let's
debug this one together. There's something
that I'm not considering in my code. But we
did consider when we drew it out. So something
that is probably breaking right now is having
to do with like the bounds checking. Something
that's kind of unfortunate in JavaScript is
this characteristic, this may have different
behavior, depending on the programming language
that you're following along in. But I know
in JavaScript, I had some array, let's say,
array, and I set it equal to just a handful
of elements, let's say a, b, and c, if you
actually do like array, at some out of bounds
index, like index, I don't know 10. And I
assign it like x, that will actually change
like the effective length of this array. So
if I take a look at what happens here, so
I'm just running this kind of offhand example,
when we run this, notice that we have about
seven empty items before we have the X. Basically,
when you do this type of weird assignment
in JavaScript, it's going to like lengthen
your array. That way, it makes sure that this
Hey, new element of x is placed at exactly
index 10. And so why is that relevant? Well,
in my code, here, I don't really check if
I'm out of bounds, right, and I just assign
to something that's potentially outside of
the current length of my array of my table,
rather. And if I do that, then this condition
is a little suspicious, right? Because if
I do this assignment on line nine to an out
of bounds position, then the length will get
longer. And that's sort of like a circular
argument, right? I keep iterating, only to
make more stuff out of bounds, only to lengthen
the table even more. So that's why I ended
up with like an infinite loop over here. One
way I can fix that is to just maybe limit
this, so I won't make a table outline that's
a little too dynamic. I know, I can basically
stop once I reach the targets. So that might
actually be the better move over here. Pretty,
pretty fair bug though.
With that, let's go ahead and run this code
again. give that a shot. Here we see true
true, false, true and false. And that is the
correct answer over here. Nice. So here's
a nice tabulated solution for our khamsum
problem. And we already spoke about this code
having n m times n, time complexity. Now it's
really obvious, right? Because I can see how
these exact the loops. And our space complexity
is simply based off of M right. Cool. With
that, let's head back into the drawing board
for another problem. All right, now let's
work on the house some variation of this problem.
So like before, I'm gonna take in the target
some as well as an array of numbers. But this
time around, what I want to do is return an
array containing a combination of elements
that actually adds up to the target sum. Right?
So here, I want to return exactly one way
if it's possible. And along with that, let's
say that it's actually not possible to return
the target sum, then I should just return
the null value. And if it's the case that
there are actual multiple combinations that
can generate the target sum, I can return
any one of those. So we expect the strategy
for this one to be very similar to our last
problem. However, we will need some nuanced
logic to return the array now, right? Because
I don't want just boolean data once return
an array. So let's sketch this one out. Let's
see I'm stepping through this example. Or
my target is seven and my array is 534. For
this input, a reasonable answer to return
would be an array of three comma four, right?
Because I can add three plus four to get seven.
You can also I guess, switch around the order
of these elements. So if you also returned
four comma three, I think that would also
be a valid answer. Point being, I just want
to return at least one way that can generate
the target. So we know we want to solve this
one with tabulation. And so we'll just follow
our recipe right? And I need to construct
an initialize some table, we already know
that the size of this table is going to be
based on the target sum, so roughly seven
elements. But we of course, have that classic
off by one nature, right? Because I want the
last index of this table to align with the
actual number argument. And in general, I'm
going to initialize this array with a length
that is target sum plus one. Cool. So now
that I have the correct shape of table, what
do I actually have to initialize as elements
inside of this table? Previously, like the
Boolean version of this problem, we initialized
everything as false, right. And the reasoning
there was, before we actually try all the
possibilities, we're going to just assume
that it's not possible to generate every quantity.
We just want to adapt that for this new type
of problem. They tell us that if it's not
possible to generate
amounts, then we should just return null.
So I think null is actually a great initial
value to just put everywhere in your table.
So at the start, we're going to assume that
none of the values or none of the amounts
are actually possible to be generated. No
is sort of the analog for false in this rendition.
Cool. So now that I have most of the values
added to the table, now I need to figure out
what's the appropriate seed value, I need
some actual data to begin and get the ball
rolling on this one. So like we expect, it's
about having an amount of zero, right, no
matter what if you're given an amount, or
a target sum of zero, and no matter what array
of numbers are given, you can always actually
generate that quantity of zero, by just returning
the empty array, right, you can take zero
elements from the numbers array, and there
you have an array whose sum is zero. So of
course, that means at index zero of our array,
we're going to initialize it with just an
empty array. And at this point, what we want
to do is, of course, iterate through our table
and come up with some logic we can use to
fill out further positions to the table based
on our current position. So let's say we begin
at index zero. So here I am. And I have to
figure out which further positions of the
table should I be looking at, we've seen this
pattern before, I should just base that off
of what I have as options in my numbers array.
So look at my first number of five, that means
I could look exactly five spaces ahead in
the table at this position. And so if I know
that my current position is possible, but
I see that I have an array and my current
position, I know it's possible. If this current
position is possible, then a position exactly
five steps later would also be possible, right.
And so what I'll do is I'm just going to copy
my current value into my further value. In
other words, I want to put an empty array
at position five, right. However, I also have
to include the number that I'm using right
now, right, I took a five to actually get
to this position in the first place. So I'm
also going to add a five into that array.
Cool. If I do a quick spot check, this is
a reasonable thing to do. Because if I look
at the state of that index five, it contains
an array of five, meaning that hey, you can
return a sum of five by just taking a single
five. And with this, I want to do the same
logic for the other numbers of the numbers
array, right. So if I have the three, I'll
look three positions ahead of my current place.
And I'll also start by copying over the array
at my current position. So I copy over the
empty array. And after I copy that array,
I actually want to populate it with the number
that I took to get to the spot in the first
place. So I just go ahead and put a three
in that array. And the same thing happens
for before.
So if you go to the next iteration, you see
that our current element is null, that means
that the amount, right in other words, our
index amount, is actually not possible, it's
not reachable, meaning we can't get an amount
of one by adding up any numbers of the given
array. So what I should not do is actually
manipulate any further values from this position.
So I just continue these base iterations.
Same thing happens when I'm at index two,
things get more interesting when I'm at index
three, right, I see that the element here
is not null. So it is possible to generate
three. And so what I want to do is go ahead
and look at my my forward values, and for
copy my current array over. So I know I don't
need to look five spaces ahead, because that
would be out of bounds. So I'm going to look
at the position exactly three spaces ahead
in the table and copy over my current array
like this, what I also need to do is make
sure that I include the number that I'm using
right now, which is three, right, because
I'm looking three spaces ahead. So I end up
with three comma three, at index six of my
table, which is reasonable, right, I also
want to do something very similar for the
position four spaces ahead. So I'm going to
copy over my current array, but then also
include the four that I'm using up right now.
So now have three four over here. Cool. At
this point, you can kind of see where this
is heading right, I've actually already populated
index seven of my table, and three comma four
is exactly a one way we could create the seven.
So we could stop here. However, let's say
that you continued the algorithm. So in the
next iteration, I know that this space for
the indices ahead would be out of bounds,
so I don't need to look there. But according
to our general logic, I would actually manipulate
the spot of the table three moves ahead, right.
And so what I'll do is if I, you know, follow
the same exact logic, I'm being consistent,
not really changing any of the rules here,
I would copy over my current array into that
position. So I basically overwrite index seven,
with just an array of four. But then at this
point, I would also be sure to include the
number that I'm using right now, which is
three, right, because I'm looking three spaces
ahead. So I end up with four comma three,
which happens to be like another way I can
generate these seven. So it doesn't matter
if you actually continued this algorithm,
right? So if I continued on basically just
keep iterating until I hit the very And and
what do I know the element at index seven
is exactly an array of four, three. Cool.
So the point is you actually don't have to
like exit early. As you iterate through the
table, you'll be okay to just finish all of
your iterations. And you'd still have a valid
answer, right? Because in this problem, they
just want any way to actually make the target.
And if I take a quick look at my table, I
think all of the stored values here make some
logical sense. For example, if I look at index
two, there's a null, meaning that it's not
possible to make a two by using elements of
the array. In a similar way, if I look at
index four, there's a sub array of four, meaning
you can just take one four, to make a some
before. Similarly, you can take two threes
to make a sum of six. And of course, you can
make a seven by doing four and three. So now
that we have a plan of attack, let's look
at the complexity for this. So of course,
the M will represent the target sum, and our
n represent the length of the numbers array.
So if we begin with just the time complexity,
we know that we're going to at least iterate
through the table and the tables of size m,
right. So I have at least an M in my time
complexity. But for every space in the table,
or in every iteration of that loop, I need
to also iterate through all of the numbers
in my number input array. And so I can multiply
by n over here. Nice. But at this point, now,
let's say that I actually need to take a valid
step here, then what I also did was copy over
the array at my current position into that
forward looking position, I know that a sub
array will be at most of length m, remember
that m is our target amount, the worst possible
or largest way we can generate the target
sum would be to have an array of exactly m
ones, right. And so we'll say that in the
worst case, we have to copy over an array
of an additional length m, that means our
time is really m squared times. And now let's
come up with the space complexity for this,
we know that the initial size of the table
is definitely based on M. However, in the
long run, we could be storing a sub arrays
as elements. So this is going to actually
be a 2d table. In a sense, I know that the
size of any particular sub array here is also
going to be m for the same reason we just
said, and so we'd have a m squared space complexity.
So overall, we're pretty satisfied with the
complexity of this. Because it's polynomial,
right? It's not an exponential quantity. So
it should run in a reasonable amount of time.
All right, I think we're ready to hop into
the code for this one.
Alright, programmers back in my trusty editor,
go ahead and tabulate this one out. So we'll
need to create the table to begin, right.
So I'll create my table, and it should have
roughly targets some positions in it, really,
I need to increase it by one. So I'll say
array, and I'll pass in target sum plus one,
that way the final index aligns, I'm going
to go ahead and fill this table up with all
of those nulls. Right, exactly what we did
in our drawing. What I also need to be sure
to do is make sure we populate index zero
of our table with an empty array serves as
sort of like a base case, in that we know
that the target sum of zero can always be
generated, right, you can generate the target
sum of zero by taking no elements from the
numbers array, right? If you took the sum
of this array, it would be zero. Nice. This
point, we need to iterate through our table.
So you've seen this code before. I equals
zero, go up to and I won't mess this up this
time, I go up to an including target some
I'll do i plus plus. So so far, very similar
in shape to our last problem. Now that I'm
iterating through every element of the table,
I need to add some conditional logic. If you
remember, from my drawing, we only did like
the heavy logic when our current position
was not null, right? Because if it is no,
you can't even reach this current position
in the first place. So I'm going to check
if my current amount is attainable. In other
words, if table at index i, which is my current
amount, if that is not know, if it's not know
that I can generate amount I goal. So if I
can generate amounts i that i know some other
things could also be generated. That is, I
want to look forward in my table for every
number in the numbers array. So I'll say let
num of numbers, so I'm getting the elements
of the numbers, right? And I need to look
that number of positions ahead right. So if
I'm at i right now, that means that a forward
looking position would be at Table A plus
num. Cool, and I need to assign something
over here. So I'm going to do is start by
copying over the sub array at position I at
my current position, right. I know that if
table I is not know the only possibility that
it could be is an array, right can be array
of zero elements are going to be an array
of many elements. So no matter what that array
looks like, I'm just gonna copy over that
array. So I'm going to spread out all of the
elements table I. And so far like this logic
is looking pretty good because I'm basing
my assignment on table i plus num off of table
I, right. But in addition to that, I also
need to include this choice of num. So I'm
just going to add that into this new array
as well using some syntax that we've seen
previously in the course. Right. So I'm just
copying over all the elements of the sub array
at table I, and adding on an addition to that
my current number. Nice. So this code is looking
pretty good. I think at this point, all we
need to do is let all these iterations finish,
and then wrap up by returning the last entry
of the table, or really the table at index
target some cool, so not that much different
from our last piece of code. Let's give this
a shot. So I'll run how some and here I have
a few diverse examples. And notice that some
of them should return null because they're
not possible. If we check these 32243, no
bunch of twos and another No, nice, it looks
like this code is totally working. Notice
that we already have a very efficient algorithm
kind of off the bat kind of comes free with
tabulation, we definitely have m iterations
in this for loop, we have n iterations on
the inner loop. But then we also have to consider
this copying over logic, right copying over
an array will be at most m. So it's m times
n times M, which is just m squared n, exactly
how we spoke about it before. It's something
I really want to emphasize is, you know, in
isolation, if someone just asked you to solve
like this house on problem, I don't think
it's an easy problem. However, it probably
feels almost trivial, especially since we
just did cancer, right? There's a really,
really straightforward progression to these
problems. If you compare the house some and
can some functions, they're very, very similar,
right, really just changing the type that
we store inside of our table, as well as the
assignment that we do when we transition into
our further elements of that table. Really
just adjusting that logic for the data type
that they're asking us for. Right? I had like
some array answers here. And here, I have
some Boolean answers. All right, so we're
smashing through all of these tabulation exercises,
let's do one more variation of this target
some problem, that way, we'll have a little
bit of an increase in the difficulty,
it's time to revisit the best sum problem.
So we're going to take in again, the target
sum as well as an array of numbers. But this
time we want to do is return an array containing
the shortest combination, that adds up to
the target sum. And if we have any ties for
the shortest combination, we can return any
one of those shortest. So you take a look
at an example kind of like we did before,
we have eight and an array of 235, there are
a few different combinations, I can yield
eight, right, I can do two plus two plus two
plus two, or I can do two plus three plus
three, or I can do three plus five. And among
these options, the shortest one is obviously
the three plus five. So that should be the
return value over here. Obviously, if you
returned five comma three, that would also
be a valid answer. Nice. So let's start tackling
this with our classic tabulation recipe. So
we need to decide on the size of our table,
like we usually say it's going to be based
on the target sum and not so much the length
of the numbers array. And like we've been
saying recently, it would be nice if the last
index of a table aligns with the original
target. So although the last index of this
table is eight, that doesn't mean that its
length would be nine, right? Let's start by
setting the proper values here. I always want
to begin my my value seed with the type that's
kind of relevant to this problem. In other
words, they want us to always return an array
if there is at least one valid way to generate
the sum. And I know that trivially if I wanted
to calculate the best sum for zero, no matter
what array of numbers, I'm given the answer,
there's always an empty array. So I'm going
to be sure to store that value at index zero
of my table. And now for the rest of the values
in the array, I can't be sure if I can generate
them yet. So I'm going to initialize them
as null just like our last problem. At this
point, we can begin our general algorithm
by iterating through the table. And so what
I'll do now is look ahead for my current position
based on the numbers of the numbers array.
So I'm gonna look two spaces ahead. Right
now I see that there's a no inside of that
position, which means I haven't quite found
a way to create two, but I'm actually finding
a way right now, right, I can copy over the
array from my current position. But I also
need to populate it with how far I'm looking
ahead by so just to inside, and do this for
the other numbers of the numbers array. So
something similar happens for three, as well
as for the five. Notice that since I just
began the algorithm, this is a really the
first time I'm finding any solution for these
further values. And so let's keep these iterations
going. I'm going to shift my frame of reference
by one since my current position, good things
and all that kind of entails that one is unreachable,
right have no way to generate a sum of one
it's actually don't do any logic from this
current position. So we move ahead to do,
since I do have a non null value, right, I
have an array over here, that means I should
look ahead to my future values. So I start
by looking two spaces ahead, I see that at
index four, there's a null, which means that
I actually need to replace that now. Alright,
I'm going to copy over my current array. But
then I also add the value for how far I'm
looking ahead by. So now I have two comma
two inside of that index of four. So now I
look ahead three spaces, which means I'm analyzing
index five, I'll notice that index five already
has an array there. And if I actually continue
my sort of standard process, I would consider
this array, I would copy over my current array
in yellow, which is an array of two, then
I would also add the element I'm looking ahead
by which is three. And technically two comma
three is one of the ways I can generate five.
But it's definitely not the shortest way right,
I can basically compare the length of these
arrays, and notice that the original array
of just five is definitely shorter, so that
one should get the stay in this spot. Cool,
I'll do something similar for five spaces,
I see five spaces ahead for my current position
yellow, there's a no right at index seven,
which means that I can just go ahead and put
this new array inside, so I copy over the
array of two, then I add the five, right,
because that's how far I'm looking ahead.
I keep this process rolling, I'm going to
modify two spaces ahead.
Notice that this sub array I'm considering
would still be longer than what's already
stored at index five. So I actually don't
use the three comma to write the five gets
the same. Now I look three spaces ahead. And
this would actually be the first time I found
at least a way to generate six. So I copy
over my current array, and also add my lookahead
value. And now if I look five spaces ahead,
there's a Knoll currently in that index eight,
which means that I'm actually finding the
first way to generate eight, so I copy over
my array of three, and then I add my five
for my look ahead. Cool. At this point, we've
actually already found a way to generate eight.
And you can probably foresee that this would
be the shortest way in the long run. However,
if we kind of continued this algorithm, there
would actually be nothing wrong with continuing
it right, it's not like we're ever going to
put something longer in that spot. So if we
continue our algorithm as normal, if I look
two spaces ahead for my current position,
that would mean I'm considering two comma
two comma two, to my array of three, three,
and obviously, I just maintain the shorter
one, so the three comma three gets to stay.
If I look three spots ahead, then I would
be comparing two comma two comma three to
a two, five. And of course, the two, five
is shorter, so it gets to stay. And this process
really just continues for the rest of the
array.
By the end of this algorithm, we do have the
correct sub array stored at index eight. So
before we jump into the code, let's look at
the complexity of this one. So we'll say that
MSR target's m, and n is the length of the
numbers array. And so we know that in terms
of the time complexity, it's going to be the
same as last time, right? Still m squared
times n, we don't really add any additional
like costly logic, all we're really adding
into the mix is just some conditional logic,
which I know is just a very simple if statement.
So that's not going to add any additional
time. And the same way, our space complexity
is still m squared, right, because I have
a table of size m. But I know every element
of that table could be an array, really just
a two dimensional array. I think with that,
let's hop into the code for this. Back in
the editor, let's go ahead and code this one
out. So we'll start by creating our table.
And I'll make this table have roughly size
of targets. But really target some plus one
that way the final index aligns. And when
I actually initialize this table, I want to
actually make sure I have no values inside.
So by default, all elements will be no basically
symbolizing that, hey, these quantities cannot
be generated yet, we have to actually prove
that there is some combination that can make
them. But the really important seed value
is to make sure that index zero is an empty
array, right? Basically, the one guaranteed
way I can make zero is by adding no numbers
of the array. This point I need to iterate
through every index of my table we always
do. I'll go up to the end including why not
the target some nice and as I iterate through
every position of the table, I only need to
do the heavy logic if my current position
is not no, right. So if my table and my current
position so table I that is not no then I
need to do some additional logic. So just
to review, why do I need to only do the logic
if my current position is not know? Well,
let's say that it wasn't All right, if my
current position is null, then I don't need
to bother considering any further moves from
this position if this position isn't reachable
in the first place, right? So only if I have
a non null position, then I'll actually iterate
through my options in the numbers array, or
I'll consider possible moves. So let's say
let num of numbers. And as I iterate through
these additional numbers, and then I need
to actually look ahead in the table basically
by that number amount. So I need to write
some logic about table at index i plus num,
right, just looking forward in the table.
And we know based on our previous problem,
it can some we ended up doing this logic,
we just replaced that position with a new
array, where we took all the elements from
our current position, so table I, we spread
out that array. Then we added additionally,
this current number that we're using, right,
so we have to actually add that into our move
list. Cool. However, now we want to actually
add some like, min value logic, I want to
prefer to always keep the combination array
that is shorter, right, I want the best way,
not just anyway. And so I think the move is
or refactor this code a little bit. I'm going
to actually do this step, maybe separately
above. So I'm going to save this to a variable.
And I'll call this my say, combination. This
is like my candidate combination, I'm not
sure if this one is actually the shortest
right now. And so if I do the assignment over
here, then I'll just use combination. But
I only want to do this assignment on line
nine, if a condition is met, right, so what
I want to express is, like, if this current
combination is shorter, than what is already
stored, right, I only get to replace something
if it's shorter. That's pretty straightforward
to express and an if statement, right? So
I want to check, hey, if. And my condition
needs to be if the thing already there. So
if the element at index i plus num. If that
thing is actually bigger than my current combination,
so combination, not length, and I also need
to be sure to do that element dot length,
right? If my combination is shorter than my
current thing being stored in at that future
position, then I'll go ahead and replace it.
Nice. So this code is looking pretty good.
There's one thing that's kind of missing,
but I think we'll just run it and we'll kind
of debug it together. So let's say at the
end, I return my table at index Parkinson.
Cool. So compared to our last code, we only
added this conditional logic. So if I run
this, something's gonna go awry. And kind
of foresee
it's very an error. And the error message
is pretty on the nose over here, it's saying,
alright, cannot read property length of null.
Right. So it's really about, particularly
this expression. So we know that our initial
state of the table has a bunch of null values.
So when I look ahead to a future value, and
for the first time, I actually have a way
to make it, then I'm going to check the element,
which is no dot length, or I cannot do null
dot length. Right. And so I need a way to
kind of get around that. If ever, I have like
a null value in my table, then I can just
go ahead and do the assignment, right, because
I found at least one way to make that. So
what I'll say is I can put an order here.
So I can still do the assignment will say
not table, i plus in JavaScript knows a falsie
value. So let's say table at index i plus
num is no. So this expression is no which
is really false. So if I say not false and
evaluates to true, so I'll go ahead and still
assign that combination to that position,
even if it isn't all, another great reason
for using this syntaxes. We know toward like
the tail end of our algorithm, we're going
to potentially look out of bounds, which means
that these elements could be undefined and
undefined is also a falsie value. Right? So
here I'm saying not false, which triggers
as true, which means I would still correctly
assign those positions. Right. The important
thing is I need to be sure to not do this
expression. When the element is null or undefined.
You can't say no dot length, and you also
can't say undefined, not length. So this expression
will guard against that. So with that change,
let's go ahead and run this. Cool. So 73544
and a bunch of 20 fives nice, especially looking
at that last example, like 20 fives is obviously
the best way to make 100. And just to be super
Sure, should be no different if I even switched
around the order of these sort of ways. So
what I put like, one, five in two. That should
still give me a bunch of 20 fives, right?
Because it's really looking for the best way
to generate each some, which would mean the
smallest summary. So there we have it a pretty
interesting tabulation a problem. However,
I do want us to recognize how similar it is
to our last how some problem, right? So here,
I have best some on the left and how some
on the right, notice how similar the code
is. Really, the only difference is this if
statement, right? For the best some problem,
I just added this conditional logic. And all
this does is prefer to keep the shorter combinations
over the longer combinations, right, because
that's what I want to return in the long run.
Whereas in houssam, we don't really have any
preference in either direction. Awesome. So
let's go ahead and go back to the drawing
board, I think we'll kind of switch things
up. Let's switch gears a little bit and revisit
those string problems with tabulation. Let's
begin with that can construct problem. So
we're going to take in a target string as
well as an array of words in a word bank.
And this version of the problem and I want
to do is return a Boolean, right, true or
false, indicating whether or not I can make
the target by concatenating, any number of
elements from the word bank array, and I can
reuse elements in the word bank as many times
as I want. So we've seen this problem before.
But just to refresh, let's take a look at
an example. So let's say my target was abcdef.
And I gave you this array of some different
substrings. In this particular scenario, it
is possible to create abcdef using members
of the array. So the answer here is true.
And one way you can actually create your target
string is by just doing ABC plus the fright.
Alright, let's start to apply our tabulation
to this one. So I'm going to create a table
and you probably already recognize that, why
I want to base the size of this table off
of the target string, right, because that's
really where I have some problems, I'm going
to be decreasing the size of my target, or
in other words, building up to my original
target over time. And so I know that I'm going
to make it about the target string and not
the array of words, because I'm never going
to remove a word out of the word bank. So
I'm gonna start with this table. And here
the sizing is is kind of particular, because
we need a way to have this table or represent
information of a string, right. Whereas before
with our number problems, it's very straightforward
to just use the index as the actual number.
So we're going to use a little clever have
an encoding here. And so what you'll notice
is here, I created an array of size seven,
right, table dot length is seven right now.
And in general, you'll want to size your table
by doing target dot length plus one. So we
still have that sort of off by one scenario,
that's kind of a very characteristic of these
tabulation problems.
And so what will this table represent? Well,
if I just think of the characters of my original
target string, I know they have corresponding
indices sort of like this, you're probably
wondering, then what's the point of having
that extra spot at the very end of the array,
right? What I need to store index six, if
it has no corresponding character. And the
reasoning is, we need a way to actually represent
information about the empty string. And so
here's the pattern we're going to use. If
I look at index zero of this table, then I'm
actually making a statement about the empty
string. So pretend that if you look at a spots
of this table, depending on what that index
is, you're considering the substring, that
starts at index zero, and goes up to but not
including your current position. So we'll
see how this scales over the rest of the indices
here. So imagine that now is at index one,
I'm looking at index one, and you're really
just looking at the A string, for at index
two, then you're looking at a B, if you're
at index three, then you're looking at ABC,
for index four, then you're going A through
D, if you're at index five, you're looking
at A through E. And so the really key insight
here is if I'm looking at index five of my
table, it means I'm making some logical statement
about the substring starting from index zero
going up to but not including index five,
right? So if I wanted to make a statement
about the entire target string, then I should
actually look at index six, right? Because
imagine you start your substring at index
zero always, and you go up to but not including
your current index. And again, the whole reason
for this is I need a way to actually make
a statement about the empty string.
And so speaking of the empty string, let's
go ahead and talk about our C values. We know
that a really core you know pattern in this
can construct problem is to use the fact that
hey, if your target string was empty, no matter
what array of words you were given in your
word bank, that is always possible. So it's
always true. And so that means at index zero
of my table, I can go ahead and seed a boolean
value. How do I know what type to even store
as the elements of my table? Well, if the
problem is asking me to return a Boolean,
then it's probably a good To actually just
begin with some boolean data in your table.
So if index zero is going to start as true,
I'm going to initialize the rest to be false,
right. So I'm going to consider all of these
other sub strings or prefixes as not possible
until I prove them otherwise. Alright, so
let's begin our general algorithm. So we'll
begin like we always do by just iterating,
from left to right through our table. And
just we have some notation to make it easier
to kind of translate the information in a
table to the statement it makes about our
target string, I'm going to have the characters
up top, and I'm going to like them up based
on the substrings that we're really considering
here. So if I begin at index zero, like we
said before, that means I'm making a statement
about the empty string, right, I see a true
inside of this position, which entails that
the empty string can be constructed using
the word bank. Cool. At this point, I have
to figure out how I can look ahead to my further
values in the table. And I know that I can
do that based on the choice of words in the
word bank. So let's look at one of our words
like a B. So something great about this option
of a B is it actually is something that begins
from my current position, right. In other
words, if you look at my current position
in yellow, the characters below it start with
a and follows with me. So taking an AB right
now would be a totally legal move, right those
characters align. And so what I'll do is,
I'll go ahead and look two characters ahead,
by look two characters ahead in my table,
that just means look two indices ahead. So
now I know that this position of the table
is actually reachable by just taking a B.
So I put a true here. And now at this point,
I would do this same logic for the other words
that have their characters aligned. In other
words, ABC is also some matching word. So
I'll go ahead and make that a true. And ABCD
would be the only other one that actually
aligned its characters. So I'll make that
one true. Again, how do I know to actually
put this information in the table, it's really
just the length of the word right, my current
position right now is at index zero. And I'm
looking at a word that is four characters
long. So that means I just look for characters
ahead to store my Boolean. Cool at this point,
I'm actually done looking at all the words
for this current position. So now I can move
my current ahead one. So now I'm at this position.
And so what you'll notice is in this current
position at index one, we have the value of
f, which means that it's false, right? It
is not possible to actually generate in a
write, there's no way you can ever just give
me back an A, because all of your substrings
in the word bank are too long, right? So I
don't actually need to do any of my heavy
logic from this position. However, on the
next iteration, when I have something that's
true, then I need to do my heavy logic. And
if I do a quick spot check, I have a true
stored in this position to write if I'm looking
at the value stored at index two, that means
I'm making some statement about indices zero
up to but not including tomb. So really just
the substring AB. And I know that if it's
true, that means it's possible. And looking
at the elements of the array, it's definitely
possible, right? You just took a beat even
get to this position. But I need to look ahead.
So I'm going to look at any words of the word
bank that match starting from my current position.
Really, the only option here is CD, right.
So if you look at my going characters, right
now, that means I can take this CD. And so
what I'll do is I'll look two characters ahead
and place a value at that position. That's
true. But the value stored at this position
of the table is already true. So nothing really
changes here. And there are no other words
of the word bank that actually begin with
a C. So I'm actually done with this pass.
So now I move my current again. And I look
for any matching words that begin with like
a D, and potentially other characters after
that, really, the only one here that works
out is D, F. And so looking at my going characters,
now I'm basically considering this chunk,
right ABC followed by TF. So I'm going to
look three positions ahead, because the word
I'm considering right now is three characters,
right def is just three characters. If I do
that, I'd be looking at this position. And
I'd be making this one a true now basically
saying that it is possible to construct abcdef
colon at this point, I would do the same thing
for the rest of the table, we know that nothing
else is really going to change within this
table.
And so by the end of the algorithm, we have
a true start at index six, which means that
our entire string is possible to be constructed.
Right? And so if we do a quick sanity check,
if I look at the table at index six, that
means I'm making some statement about the
substring that starts at zero and goes up
to but not including index six, which would
really be the entire A through F. I know that
it's true. So that substring is possible to
be generated, right, which was our final answer
fairly elsewhere. Like maybe at index five,
there's a false here, which means that I'm
making some statement about indices zero through
four, right, so ABS C, D E. And since there's
a false at this position, that means that
it's not possible to generate this string.
And looking at just the elements of the word
bank, it's definitely not possible to ever
get a, b, c, d, e. Cool. So the data within
our table a does look consistent with that,
let's actually talk about the complexity.
So we know that m is going to be our target
string, whereas n is going to be the number
of words in the word bank. And so we just
consider the time complexity right now, we
know that we're at least iterating through
every element of our table, and our table
was roughly size M, right? However, once we
were at some current position of a table,
we had to look ahead based on all of the words
in the word bank. And so that would be an
N operation for every iteration of m. And
even still, as always, considering the words
coming from my current position. And to make
sure that their characters aligned, right,
I can't just take arbitrary words, from the
word bank, I have to choose the ones that
have their characters matching right now,
I know that the maximum length of any word
or the maximal length of a match, I would
have to do would basically just be in terms
of M, so give me an additional m term. So
overall, I'm looking at m squared n for the
time complexity of this one. And besides that,
we already know that the space complexity
comes from the table, which is just a array
of Boolean, so just m space overall. And so
from a bird's eye view, it looks like this
strategy would be an efficient one, right,
we have a polynomial time complexity, but
more importantly, a non exponential complexity.
So let's code this one up now. Alright, let's
code up this can construct problem. So we'll
start by creating our table. And so we'll
say create a new array of size target dot
length, plus one just like we spoke about
in our drawing, then from there, I need to
give some initial values to my table. So I'm
going to go ahead and fill this one up with
all falses. So we're going to assume that
every like prefix of our target cannot be
constructed until we prove it otherwise, then
I need to actually also initialize table index
zero to be true, symbolizing that the empty
string can always be generated, right? Then
from there, I need to iterate through every
index of my table. So I'll say i equals zero,
just go up to the entire table. And here just
to be safe, I'll say is less than or equal
to target dot length. Nice. And as we iterate,
we actually need to check our current positions
value. Recall that in our strategy, we said
we only need to do like the heavy logic, if
our current position is reachable, so our
current position should be true. So I'm gonna
go ahead and check Hey, if my table at index
i is true, then I'll do some additional logic.
If I enter this if statement that I need to
consider any further choice of words I can
use to progress to other spots in the array,
right? So over here in this if statement,
I want to iterate through every word of the
word bank, right? So I'll say four letter
word of word bank. Nice. And so what I want
to do, as I iterate through all my possible
words is I need to make sure that these words
I iterate through actually match their characters
to my current spot that I'm at. In other words,
if I am at my very first index of a over here,
then when I iterate through all the options
of words, I need to make sure that I only
use a valid words that match like a, b, or
ABC, or ABCD. Right? There's no point of me
trying to use def right now. Right? I need
to actually kind of narrow down my words,
based on whether or not they match characters,
right. So to do that, I can check pay if.
And what I want to express is, you know, if
the word matches the characters, starting
at position, I
position I goal, it's not going to translate
that into some code. Well, checking if a string
matches to something straightforward, just
about using equality, right? But I have to
figure out how can I look at the correct you
know, substring of characters within my original
target, right? It's pretty straightforward.
All I need to do is say target dot slice.
I'm going to slice starting at index i. And
how far do I want to go? I basically want
to go like the length of my word. So the move
here is to say go from I up to i plus word
dot length. And so let's kind of break down
this logic. So what it's trying to do is check
if your word matches your characters starting
at position I. So let's check an easiest scenario.
Let's say that my current position is zero,
right? So right now is zero. That means I'm
at this position like this ABCD f example.
Let's say right now that my word is ABC. So
if I look at this slice, it's going to slice
starting at index zero, up to and not including
zero plus three, right, the length of my word
is three, zero plus three is just three, that
would actually look at this run of ABC. Good.
And let's say we were somewhere further in
the string. Let's say we were actually at
this D character over here. And so if I'm
at this D character, that means my value for
AI is going to be three Wragge, oh 0123. And
the current word I'm considering, let's say
is this def, the length of this word is three.
So this ending index is going to be three
plus three, which is six. And so I would actually
slice starting at this character, three, going
all the way through the end, right? 345. And
I always exclude the ending index of six here.
So this logic is good, right? All it does
is check if my current word matches the characters
starting at index i, goal. So if I enter this
if statement, then I have a successful word.
So I should actually set a true in that forward
looking position. So I can just set table.
And when I look ahead, how far do I need to
look? Well, you need to look exactly this
far ahead, right, i plus word dot length,
matching me we're at index zero of our target
string. If I take ABC, then I end up word
dot length characters later, three characters
later in this example, right. So I'm saying
table of i plus word dot length, that should
be set to true. Cool, notice how similar This
is to our previous number, like our target
some problems, except now we have to adapt
this four string data. So now I jump ahead
based on the length of the word I'm choosing.
So this code is looking pretty good. Let's
go ahead and do our final return value. So
I want to return the table at Target dot length,
right? Basically, if I'm at the last position,
or at Target length, a position of my table,
that means I have the information for the
entire target range starting at index zero
all the way through the end of the target.
So here are some examples. Let's give this
a run. So I get true, false, true, false.
Nice, and there we have a nice working solution.
So take a moment to let this code sink. And
really the most tedious logic here is probably
this particular slice. So really try to make
sure you kind of understand how this comment
is implemented using this code. If you remember
our previous recursive immobilization strategy
for this problem, we needed to actually have
logic to make sure our prefixes match. This
is sort of the analog for that, right. So
we already spoke about the time complexity
for this one, but it's already in plain sight,
right, we have m iterations here, we have
n iterations here. And then the additional
work we do is this slice, right, I'm slicing
from my target, which is also M. So overall,
I have m times n times m, or m squared, N.
And of course, the table just takes up definitely
m space. Cool. So with that, let's head back
into the drawing board. All right, now let's
revisit the count construct problem. So we're
still going to take in a target string as
well as an array of words in a word bank.
And this time, we want to return a number,
right, we want to turn the number of ways
that the target can be created by concatenating
elements of that word bank, we can reuse elements
of the word bank as many times as we want.
So let's take a look at an example of this.
So let's say I had this input, so I have the
target of purple, and I have an array with
some substrings. The return value here should
be two because they are exactly two ways to
create purple. You can do perp plus le, or
you can do p plus u r plus p plus le ran,
those are two distinct ways. So notice in
this problem, we really just want to return
to the numbers. So we'll just keep that in
mind. So let's follow that classic tabulation
recipe, we'll initialize our table with roughly
the size of the input that changes, which
is really going to be the target string, right,
we want to actually use overlapping subproblems
on the target string.
And like we always say, we're going to have
a little off by one scenario here. Although
the number of characters in my purple string
is six, I want to initialize a table of length
seven. In general, you want to make sure your
table has target dot length plus one a number
of elements inside. That way, I have a way
to represent the empty string, just like our
last tabulation. And so we'll start by thinking
about what are some proper seed values for
this problem. I know that when I have an empty
string, empty target strings, my input, no
matter what array I'm given, you can always
generate the empty string right by taking
no elements of the word bank. So the answer
for the target string should be one, right,
there's one way to make the target string
and that is to concatenate nothing together.
So I'm going to store the value of one at
index zero of my table. Now I have to decide
how to initialize the other values in my table.
Well, I know that it should be number data,
right? It's really important that you try
your best to make your table contain a consistent
data type. If I remember my similar counting
problems like Fibonacci, or even the grid
traveller of the move here is actually start
those other spots in the array at zero, basically
saying, you know, at the start, I have zero
ways to generate these different prefixes
of purple. And then as to actually find distinct
ways, I'll go ahead and increment those spots
in the table. But we'll get to that. So we'll
iterate through our table from left to right,
of course, beginning at index zero of the
table. And as we do this, I'll also up top
show the characters that we're considering
within our table. Remember, the really important
pattern here is when I'm at some position
of my table, that means I'm encoding some
information about the substring that starts
index zero, up to but not including my current
index, right. So if I have some information
stored at index zero, that information is
about the empty string. From my current position.
Now I need to consider any words of the word
bank that I can take right now to give me
another spot within the table. In other words,
since I'm at index zero, I need words that
start with P. So let's say we looked at this
first word of perp. And so if I looked at
that word, and I took it, that would bring
me a somewhere else within the table, right
have to look forward like we usually do. So
they'll end up at this position index four.
Again, notice that we have the kind of off
by one scenario here. So although I'm going
to write information into index four, that
informations about the substring, that spans
from zero, up through index three, right,
and what I need to do now is take my current
value in yellow, actually add that into my
future position. So I just add one into the
zero. And now index four contains a one, right
basically saying that so far, we found a one
way to construct the string perp. And then
from there, I look at any other words that
the word bank that match right, so I'll just
look at the next word of P. Again, just moving
left to right through our word bank, right
now, I'm still at my current position. And
what I do if I use this P is I only look one
character ahead, right, because p dot length
is only one. What I do in this future position
is of course, just take my current value in
yellow, and I added into this position, so
zero plus one is just a one. There is one
more word I can use right now from my current
position, that's purple without the E. And
if I look at that corresponding position,
they'll bring me all the way over here. And
again, I add the one into that position. Nice,
I think that ends are a very first pass. And
now we move our current position to the right.
So now my current is at index one. So now
I need to consider words of the word bank
that begin with a you and kind of match characters
throughout. The only option here is really
just you are in the word bank, if I took a
u r, that would bring me two characters ahead,
right, so bring me over here, what I should
do like always, is just take my current value
and add it into that position. Now I have
a one over here. There are actually no other
words of the word bank that match from my
current location. So I can just move ahead
to the next spot in the table. If we're at
index two, it looks like we need something
that starts with an R, there's actually no
words of the word bank that we can use from
this position. And what we also notice is
there's also a zero at this opposition. So
this won't really do anything in our table
anyway. So we can progress just the next spot
in the table. Here's where things start to
get interesting, right? So right now my current
is at index three. So I need to grab words
from the word bank that start with P and potentially
have an L enemy. So what I can do here is
just take this loan p, which will bring me
one character ahead. If I look one character
ahead, what I do now is I take my current
value, right circled in yellow, and I add
it into my look at value. So I increment that
to two now. Nice. And then from there, I need
to continue on my logic by just moving rightward
in my table, right shift my current point
of view.
At this point, what I do is I again, look
at any words that start with an le, and there's
really only one that matches perfectly, I
look two characters head because the length
of Le is two. And what I do is I take my current
value in yellow, and add it into that position,
right, my logic throughout this entire algorithm
is very consistent. And there we have a two
in the last spot, you can probably already
foresee that we have our final answer. But
if we continue the algorithm as normal, or
really, we've noticed that if we move to the
next position, there's no word of the word
that starts with E. So I don't do anything
here. And once we hit the very end, we're
actually done with our algorithm. Right? And
we see that, hey, we have a two in the last
spot a retailer which is consistent with our
expected answer. Something I think is really
important to do is not only recognize that
our final answer is in the last position of
the table, but really any element of this
table should make some logical statement about
our target string, right? So let's say I look
at index for over here. I see that there's
a two in that spot in the array. So what does
that really saying? Well, if I am looking
at the value stored at index four, that means
I'm considering the substring That starts
at zero and goes up to including four. So
that really means I'm looking at purp, right.
And if there's a two inside of the spot in
the array, that means that there are apparently
two ways to create perp. And if I do a quick
check in my word bank, that's exactly true,
right, you can just take the straight up perk,
because that's actually a literal word of
your word bank. Or you can do p plus u r plus
P. Cool. That's some consistent information.
And then from there, if I actually consider
now what I can do from that position at index
four, well, you could have taken an le, that's
basically what we did when we traced through
the algorithm. If you take an le, what are
you really doing? Why is that value in the
index six, also two? Well, for one, Ellie
has a length of two. So that's why I'm looking
just two spaces ahead in my table. And if
I think about what like logical operation
I'm doing, if I were to take an L e, and add
it to all of the ways that I have in blue
Rhino, then I would end up with all of the
ways to generate purple right in my last spot,
literally just taking the Le as an additional
move, right? Pretty elegant logic. Let's talk
about the time complexity for this though.
So we know that, hey, r m is going to be the
target and n is going to be the number of
words in the word bank, this is really going
to be about the same complexity as our last
rendition, right? You can't construct. So
we're gonna have m squared times n time, right,
we definitely have m time for just iterating
through every spot of the array. And we also
have an additional n, because we have to actually
look forward for every element of the word
bank. And so where does that final m come
from? Like we've been saying lately, it comes
from actually performing the match of the
check for matching characters. In a similar
way, the space complexity is just going to
be m, really just based off of the size of
the table, we're only ever storing just some
numbers within this table. So our space just
stays at linear o of M space. All right, I'm
feeling good about this plan, time to code
it up. Alright, let's code this one out. Let's
start by creating my table, it's gonna begin
as an array with roughly target length, size,
really target length plus one, that way the
index aligns, right, I'm going to fill this
entire table with zeros for now, because I
know in the long run, I'm going to add into
it. So zero is a great starting value. That
being said, I have a really important c value,
I need to make sure that my table at index
zero actually starts as one, right, because
there is one way to make the empty string
right. Now from here, I can start my core
algorithm by just iterating through every
position of the table. So set i equal to zero,
go up to an including target dot length, and
hit every index, right. And so what I'll do
is iterate through every word of the word
bank. So let's word of word bank.
And as I iterate through every word, I need
to check if the word matches my current location
right there has aligning characters. So you've
seen this pattern before, I'll check if target
that slice I'm gonna slice some characters
out of my target. Starting index i right,
this is my current position, I need to look
at the next couple of characters based on
the length of my word, I'm going to slice
i to i plus word dot length. goal. So my current
position is I, this will give me the next
word dot length number of characters starting
at position, I will check if that little segment
is equal to the word I'm considering right
now. And if it is equal, then I have a word
that I can actually take, I can modify some
further position of the table. In particular,
what I should do is need to modify my table
at index i plus word dot length. So I'm looking
to head remember that our current position
is I so I'm looking ahead in the table based
on my current words length, what I want to
do is actually increase that by some value,
want to increase it by the number stored in
my current position, right? That's what we
did at every point of the algorithm. Nice.
A common mistake that I see students make
is, usually they have a tendency to just increment
by one here, right? That's not the move Do
you want to do is increment by exactly the
number that's in your current position, right.
Now, at this point, I think all we need to
do is just return our final answer, which
like we always know, is basically table at
Target dot length. Cool, so I have some examples
below. With their expected results, let's
give this a shot count construct. So I get
to 104 and zero, that's that we have a fairly
large example, which should return zero, you
can't possibly generate this final f here,
because your word bank only contains a bunch
of E's, and it ran fairly quick. So this solution
is looking pretty good. Notice how small of
a variation it is from our last problem. Hopefully
you're really feeling the progression. So
let's kind of quickly just take a look at
That that was our can construct problem. So
let me split these guys. Very, very trivial
difference, right, instead of assigning a
true value. Now I actually just increment
because I have numbers within my table. That
was short and sweet. Let's head back into
the drawing board. Let's do one more problem
together, let's revisit that all construct
problem. So we're still taking in our target
string, as well as an array of words in a
word bank. But this time, you want to return
all of the ways that you could construct the
target by concatenating elements of the word
bank. So here, you need to return a 2d array,
that means a single element of the array represents
a one combination that makes it a target.
And like usual, we can reuse elements of the
word bank as many times as we see fit. So
we take a look at an example, let's say I
gave you the target of abcdef, I gave you
this array of words, you actually have many
ways to create the target string, there are
four ways over here. So each sub array represents
one combination, where if you concatenate
it together, you get the target. And so notice
that I want to return every single combination
as an element of the outer array over here,
right. So if there are many ways to create
something, then I want to return a 2d array.
That being said, there are a few examples
that we should keep really in mind having
to do with our seed values that we kind of
foresee. Right. So let's say I gave you this
example, where your target is the empty string,
and I gave you just some words in the word
bank. The point is, since your target string
is empty, your result should really be a 2d,
empty array. So recall that the outer array
here represents like the collection of multiple
combinations. And here, there's only one combination
that makes the empty string, right, so the
inner array represents like that empty combination,
we take no words of the word bank. And this
is a reasonable thing to do, because they'll
take give you this example, if your target
was birds, and I gave you an array of cat
and dog, then the result, there should be
just a one dimensional empty array, right?
The array over here represents the collection
of combinations. And there are no elements
here, right? There are no combinations at
every yield of birds. So we'll keep those
sort of seed value base case scenarios in
mind. So let's trace through this example
of abcdef. I'll start by initializing our
table, we're gonna need a lot of room in this
one. And so we know that the size of this
table is going to be based on the target string,
right, just like we usually do. And then we
have to figure out what our seed values are,
we kind of just spoke about them, we know
that if I have the empty string, then I need
to have a 2d empty array. And so we'll initialize
that in our table,
I know we're going to need a lot of room.
So I'm going to spread out these outer brackets.
Now for all of the other elements of our table,
we want to make them just one dimensional
empty arrays. And here's the reason why I
write for these further values in the table,
I have to actually check for ways to generate
them. So for now, there are no ways that I
found right, that's why I just have an array
with zero combinations inside, except for
index zero, right? index zero has one combination
inside, that happens to be the empty combination.
Cool. So let's start with our general algorithm.
A lot of this logic will feel very similar
to our last few problems. Now we're just adjusting
it have to generate these combinations, right.
So we know that we're going to try to visualize
how we look at our string in terms of some
prefixes, right. I know that if I'm highlighting
some spot in my table, then that grabs the
prefix or an index zero all the way up to
midnight, including my current index of the
table. And I'll light up those characters
at the top over here. So what I need to do
now is since I'm currently at index zero of
my table, I consider words of my word bank
that have matching characters from this position.
So I can look at this a B First, if I took
this A B move, then I should look two characters
ahead, right, because a B has a length of
two. So that brings me to this position in
light blue. And what I should do is take all
of the combinations in my current location
in yellow, and actually copy them over into
this future position. But when I do that,
I also need to be sure to include in those
combinations, the move of the word I just
took, right, so that would just be adding
an AB inside. Right. So again, kind of repeating
that step, I copy over the contents of my
current position in yellow. But then I have
to make sure I add my word that I'm consuming
right now into each of those combinations
I just added. Cool. And now we would actually
keep our current position here because there
are still some other words of the word bank
that have matching characters, right, I can
take an ABC from this position, and something
very similar happens write a copy over my
current array. And then I go ahead and add
ABC to it. This happens one more time for
ABCD
Awesome. At this point, I've considered all
of the words that match from this current
position. So I can move forward a little bit.
At this point, though, I need something that
starts with A, B, right? Because my current
position has to be on it. And I actually don't
find any words of the word bank, that kind
of match from this position. So I actually
moved my current once more. What about this
position, I have to consider words of the
word bank that have a seat, right, and there
are a few that can use here, I can use CD,
right. And if I do that, I look two characters
ahead or two indices ahead for my current
position. So I'm looking at this index. So
if I look at index four, I have a really interesting
situation, right? I already have a some combination
stored inside of index four. And that represents
one way we could make ABCD, right by just
taking that loanword ABCD. But what I can
also do is, I should take all of the combinations
from my current position and just add them
into that index for right, so I'm taking the
A B from index two, just adding it to index
four. But then I also need to add to that
new combination of the word I'm using right
now, which was CD. Cool. And then from here,
you already noticed that, hey, there are so
far, two ways to create ABCD, you can just
take that loan word ABCD. Or you can do a
B plus CD. So this logic is taking some some
nice shape here. For my current position,
there's actually one more word that matches,
it's really just a single character see, so
like I do, I look one character head or one
index head in my table just next door, and
I copy over the combinations from my current
location in yellow. But then I also append
the word I'm consuming, which is just an additional
C, right. So so far, I have two ways to make
ABC. At this point, I can progress my current
spot and table. And I look for any matching
words that start with a D, right? So that
would be the D f over here. d f has a length
of three. So I look three spots ahead in my
table. And I need to add some information
here, I copy over my current combinations
in yellow. And then I have to append at the
end of all of them the D F word that I'm using
right now. So it looks like this. At this
point, I can iterate my current position.
So now I'm at index four as my current. And
I look at any words that start with any, and
there's actually just one over here just as
EF. And so I look to character's head or to
indices ahead for my current position. And
again, this is a scenario where I need to
append new combinations to this existing list,
right. So if I look at my current position
at index four in yellow, I'm going to take
all of those combinations and copy them over
into my light blue position at index six.
And then from there, I also need to make sure
that I append to them the word I'm using right
now, which is an E, F. So those two combinations
also get an F at the end of them. Nice. At
this point, you see our final results at the
last spot on the table, we continue the general
algorithm, we would just move our current
position to index five, which is actually
a no words of x star with an F over here.
So nothing happens on this iteration. And
there we have our algorithm, right, that index
six of the table contains all of those four
ways we described how we can use to create
our original target string, take a moment
to look at this table. And notice how every
position of the table should make some logical
statement about the target string. Right,
I can see that if I chose some position, let's
say index three, that's giving me some information
about the substring ABC, right, that prefix
of my original target. And what saying is,
there are two ways to make ABC, you can just
take ABC, that's actually a word of my word
bank. Or you can do a B plus C, right? That's
the only other way that applies for all positions
within my table. If I look somewhere else,
like at index five, that means I'm reading
some information about A through E. And if
there's no combinations at this position,
means there's no way you can ever generate
ABCDE. And if you take a quick glance at the
words in the word bank, that is correct, you
can't possibly just generate ABCD. Overall,
the information in our table and our logic
that we did was very consistent. Before we
hop into the code for this one, let's do the
analysis. So we know that m is going to be
the length of our target string. And we'll
define n to be the number of words in the
word bank. So like we described, when we did
the memorization and recursive solution for
this problem, we really can't do better than
a sort of brute force, right? Because they're
asking us to return literally every single
way to generate our target string here. So
really, the time complexity is going to be
the shape of an exponential, right, so about
n to the M, again, it will have some extra
like multiplication terms of M
in it. But overall, we're looking at an exponential
time complexity. And what's the reason behind
that? Well, we know there's going to be an
exponent The number of actual combinations
that we need to return. And I have to actually
construct all of those combinations piece
by piece. And so I'm looking at at least exponential
time. And really, once something gets exponential,
that's really the limiting factor, right.
And similarly, we can say that the space complexity
for this is also going to be exponential.
Again, roughly, we know that we're going to
have at least m space just from the straightforward
sides of the table. But notice that every
element of the table itself is going to be
a 2d array. So in a sense, we're really dealing
with like a 3d table in this instance. And
so we know that at any particular position
of our table, we're going to have potentially
an exponential number of things, right, if
you consider the very last spot in our table,
just the last spot that already has an exponential
number of combinations inside of it, but then
I would actually have that throughout my entire
table, so it'd be really a little more than
just n to the M. But overall, I'll say it's
roughly exponential complexity. And you can't
really do any better here, right, especially
in terms of the time, I'm really asking you
to just do this in a brute force way, I think
we'll actually be able to see that once we
create the solution. Let's hop into it. Alright,
for one last time, let's solve this all construct
problem. So I'll begin by creating my table.
By now we're tabulation masters, this is very,
very formulaic. Create my table with roughly
target size really target dot length plus
one. And here, I need to initialize the elements
of my table as arrays. So here, I need to
be very particular and make sure I get a unique
array in every spot of the array. So I'm going
to do a fill using this index before, then
I'll map over it that way I can generate a
new array for every element here. Cool, let
me just style this up. And so this should
give me an array as every element of my table,
right? Notice that the elements right now
are just one dimensional empty arrays, right?
These arrays represent the collection of combinations.
At the start, they're empty, meaning that
I have no combinations for most of these elements,
except for one, right, we already spoke about
table at index zero, right? That should be
a 2d, empty array. And the reason was, still,
the outer array here represents the collection
of combinations. For the empty string, there
is one combination that you can use to make
it right, that is the empty combination, where
you take no words to the word bank. Cool.
So now I can begin my general algorithm by
just iterating through my target, and you've
done this many times before. So I'm iterating
through my table. And what I'll also do is
look at all of the words, right, so in every
iteration, I'm going to consider some words
of the word bank. So I'll say that word of
word bank. And like before I send you to check
that, alright, these words better have matching
characters based on my current position. So
I'll use that classic logic, right, seen it
many times by now. And I'll slice a segment
out of my target string, I'll say target dot
slice starting index i, and grabbing the next
word, dot length, number of characters. Cool.
I'm going to compare that chunk to the current
word that I'm iterating through. Nice. So
using this statement, I'm sort of filtering
down all the words, and only going to do some
logic on the words that match based on my
current position. Nice. And so we've seen
you know, this nested for loop an if statement
before, right, we're now we're adding our
new logic within this if statement. Cool,
all I need to do is really understand what
types of data I'm dealing with here. All right,
so let's say I just wrote this expression
table at index i, well, that's going to do
is just reference my current spot in the table.
And if I think about what data it's going
to be, it's definitely gonna be an array,
right? It's either going to be like an empty
array, meaning there are no ways to make this
current target. Or it could be a multi dimensional
array, where every sub array represents one
way I can make the current target. So if this
is all of the combinations that generate my
current, then what I'll do is I'm going to
map over them. Remember, in our drawing, what
we did was kind of copy over all of our current
combinations. But then make sure we also add
our word that we're using right now to the
end of each of those combinations. So that's
what I'm doing right here, and a map over
every summary. And what I'll do is, I'll just
copy over the elements of that summary using
that spread syntax that we've seen before.
And then also be sure to add on at the end
my word. Nice. And then that will give me
let's say, our new combinations. So I'll just
say that to a variable maybe. So new combinations
is going to be a 2d array, right where every
sub array represents some combination.
And I want to take these combinations and
add them into that further spots inside of
my table. So I know I need to kind of look
at in my table. So I can look at table at
index i plus word dot length. I know that
all positions of the table are going to be
arrays, right? So this is going to be an array,
there's going to be some data that might already
exist at this position, right? So what I don't
want to do is just assign you combinations,
because then that would overwrite any previous
existing combinations that I already found
for this position. Instead, I need to make
sure that I just add these new combinations
to that list, right. So what I'll do here
is I'll push to that array, I'll push all
of the elements of my new combinations right
here, I can spread this out, I want to spread
it out. That way, I don't add any additional
nesting over here, right. So this is looking
pretty good. I think let's go ahead and return
the table at Target dot length. Here, I have
some examples down below. Let's give this
a shot. Nice. And these answers look correct.
Right, notice that these last two examples
should return empty arrays because they are
impossible to generate. Cool, let's hover
over this code for a moment. Probably the
most tedious logic here would be these two
lines, right? Really try to understand how
like these two lines translate into the logic
we did in our drawing. So let's break down
these lines again, right? line 11 is going
to take all of the combinations in my current
position in my drawing that was like my yellow
box. And it's going to add our current word
to each of those combinations. And then we're
going to take each of those new arrays and
add them to the list add our further position,
right being sure not to overwrite, we already
spoke about the complexity of this one, it's
definitely going to be exponential, probably
a little more than exponential. Right? If
you imagine all the work we have to do using
these maps and like spreading, we have to
actually construct our result array, which
is going to contain an exponential number
of things. Right? So when I look at this last
example, let's say that I made it a little
longer, right? So let's say actually pull
up the size of that input. It's going to be
very, very slow might even crash, but let's
just do it. So let's say I had a bunch of
A's here, just for fun. So if we try this
example. Yeah, it looks like our program still
crashes, right? This is going to return a
really, really a massive array probably can't
even fit into memory over here, right? So
we'll get like a stack size exceeded, even
though this isn't even recursive, right? Just
calling functions way too much over here.
So no matter what we do, we really expect
this problem to sort of demand an exponential
solution. With that, let's head back into
the drawing board where you can wrap up this
course.
Alright, programmers, by now we solve many
different dynamic programming problems together.
And I want to leave us with some final advice.
So whenever you're starting to attack any
dynamic programming problem, start by really
taking a moment and noticing any overlapping
subproblems. And then from there really focus
on like the input to the problem, in particular
its type. And from there, you shouldn't be
able to recognize what is the trivial smallest
input? So in our string problems, usually
that means the empty string in our array problems,
it's the empty array, or in our number problems,
it's usually a number like zero or one, right?
Is there some input wherever you don't really
have to do any extra work to know the answer?
The answer just sort of is what it is. Once
you recognize this trivial scenario, or the
base case, really, then you'll want to realize
how you can relate this base case toward your
larger inputs. And then you have two options,
right? You can either think recursively, and
use memorization, or you can think more iteratively
and build a table using our tabulation formula.
I think as you practice dynamic programming
problems, I would actually always solve problems
in two ways, one using memoization and one
using tabulation. And of course, from that
point on, it's okay, if you have like a favorite
strategy. For me, personally, that's memorization.
But that being said, it really helps to have
options when you're in an interview. And once
you've made that decision on, you know which
route you're going to take, definitely, you
know, slow it down and draw a strategy first.
This is I think, the most important thing
about just data structures and algorithms
in general. Usually, when we draw our pseudocode,
or draw our process on the whiteboard, we
can recognize all of these edge scenarios.
And it's much harder to do when we just write
like the code out of the gate. And so I promise
if you slow it down and take a moment to draw
a visual, you're gonna find your work a lot
more productive, as well as more intuitive
when you explain it to someone else. And of
course, through all of that, you're gonna
have a lot more fun, you know, dealing with
these quite hard topics. Alright, programmers,
that's all I got for this course. Hopefully,
you had fun, you know, learning this new topic.
I definitely had fun teaching it to all of
you. So what you want to do now is head down
to the links in description and head to coder
byte comm where you can actually practice
this new topic. Thanks for watching, and I'll
see you in the next one.